THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. TODAY WE
WILL BE DISCUSSING THE CHILD
WELFARE AND FOSTER CARE PROGRAMS
IN CALIFORNIA. HIGHLIGHTING
DISPARITIES IN CHILD DEVELOPMENT
AND THE MATERNAL HEALTH
CONNECTIONS THAT IMPACT THE
SYSTEM. I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. TODAY WE ARE
PHYSICALLY DISTANCE IN ROOM ONE
THANKS IS ME FOUR FOUR FOUR HERE
AT THE STATE CAPITOL. THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
ON THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS. 1-877-692-8957 WITH
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE OF. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR.
IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE APPS
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN PERSON MAY
DO SO BUT WE ASK THAT YOU WEAR A
MASK AT ALL TIMES AND FOLLOW ALL
OTHER POSTED GUIDANCE IF
POSSIBLE AND IF YOU WISH. THOSE
ARE PREVIOUS INSTRUCTION TO HAVE
BEEN UPDATED THIS WEEK IF YOU
FEEL COMFORTABLE WE ARE
ACCEPTING THAT AS WELL. WE WILL
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER ALL
MEMBERS HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL THERE
WILL BE NO VOTES IN TODAY'S
HEARING AS THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TO DISCUSS
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS. I WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ALSO ACCEPTING WRITTEN
FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT AND THE ADDRESS IS
BUDGET SUB ONE AT ASM DOT CA DOT
GOV. FOR WE BEGIN OUR FIRST
PANEL I'LL MAKE JUST A FEW
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS AND
COMMENTS AND OPEN IT UP TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF THEY WOULD
LIKE TO DO THE SAME. OUR FOCUS
FOR SOMEONE THIS YEAR IS TWO
FOLD. WE ARE FIRST REVIEWING THE
PRIORITY ISSUES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND SECOND
WE ARE EXERCISING OUR CRITICAL
OVERSIGHT ROLE FOR PROGRAMS AND
INVESTMENTS. THAT ARE IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AS PART OF THESE
EXERCISES. WE SHALL DISCUSS AND
DELIBERATE ON WHAT ADDITIONAL
MEANINGFUL CHANGES THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. CAN FACILITATE TO MAKE
PROP PROGRESS TOWARD SOLVING.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS FACING OUR
STATE. AS WE DISCUSSED THE DIRE
REALITIES OF POVERTY IN OUR
STATE DURING OUR FEBRUARY TWENTY
THIRD HEARING WE LISTENED TO THE
MANY SUGGESTIONS THAT ABOUT WAYS
TO SUPPORT AND TO STRENGTHEN OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY NET PROGRAMS. WE
HAVE A VERY CLEAR INFORMATION
ABOUT THE MEANINGFULNESS OF
BREAKING THE CYCLE OF TO
GENERATION POVERTY AND HOW WE
CAN MOVE TOWARD GREATER EQUITY
AND JUSTICE. CHILD WELFARE IS AN
AREA WHERE WE SEE STARK
HISTORICAL DISPARITIES BUT WE
AREN'T NOW MORE EQUIPPED THAN
EVER TO BUILD THE PREVENTION
MUSCLE TO KEEP FAMILIES INTACT
WHEN IT IS SAFE FOR CHILDREN.
AND TO FIND AND RESOURCE FAMILY
BASED CARE WHEN IT IS NOT SAFE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE AGENDAS
FOR TODAY WITH THAT I'LL OPEN IT
UP TO SEE IF ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD LIKE TO DO THE
SAME. SEEING NONE WE WILL BEGIN
WITH. PANEL NUMBER ONE. ON THE
TOPIC OF CHILD WELFARE DISPARITY
IMPACTS ON CHILD DEVELOPMENT AND
THE ROLE OF MATERNAL. HEALTH
SUPPORTS. FOR THOSE PANELISTS OR
PRESENTERS PLEASE PRESENT IN THE
ORDER IN WHICH YOUR NAME APPEARS
IN THE AGENDA AGENDA. WE WILL
HAVE SEVEN DISTINGUISHED
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
INCLUDING. DANIEL WEBSTER. PHD
PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
BERKELEY SABRINA FORTE DIRECTOR
OF POLICY AND IMPACT LITIGATION
FOR THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS. STACEY LEE THE CHIEF
LEARNING OFFICER AT CHILDREN
NOW. ANGIE SCHWARTZ CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
KIM JOHNSON THE DIRECTOR FOR THE
JUSTIN FREITAS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ANGELES SHORTS WITH THE L. A. M.
WE WILL HOLD ALL MEMBERS
QUESTIONS ON THIS PANEL UNTIL.
AFTER ALL OF THE PRESENTERS HAVE
CONCLUDED LET US BEGIN WITH DR
DANIEL WEBSTER WELCOME PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY AGAIN WHAT
STIR THE DIRECTOR OF THE CHILD
WELFARE INDICATORS PROJECT AT UC
BERKELEY WE HAVE A LONG STANDING
PARTNERSHIP WITH GSS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES. TO PULL
INFORMATION FROM THE STATE'S
AUTOMATED CHAO WILL PERMISSION
SYSTEM AND REPORT INDICATORS OF
SYSTEM PERFORMANCE ON A PUBLIC
WEBSITE TO SUPPORT THE STATE
MANDATED OUTCOMES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. I'VE BEEN
OUT TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
ORIENTATION ON DEFINITIONS OF
DATA TRANSLATE THE RACIAL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AND
DISPARITIES IN CHILD WELFARE I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE A POWER POINT
FROM WHICH MY REMARKS ARE DRAWN
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS OFTEN
CATHOLIC THE MAIN POINTS WITHOUT
GOING TO THE INDIVIDUAL SLIDES
SELF. DEFINITION PERSONALITY
REFERS TO ONE. SAY CHILDREN
FOSTER CARE. ACT OF PROPORTION
THE LARGER. POPULATION OFF THIS
COMPARE POP. IS THE- CHILD
POPULATION SO FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY BLACK CHILDREN
ACCOUNTED 421% OF ALL CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE. BUT THEY MADE UP
ONLY FIVE POINT 6% OF THE
GENERAL CHILD POPULATION SO
BLACK CHILDREN ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY. OVER
REPRESENTED IN FOSTER CARE.
WHITE CHILDREN BY CONTRAST
ACCOUNTED FOR ABOUT 222% OF ALL
CHILDREN FOSTER CARE BUT THEY
MAKE UP. 31% OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION SO WHY CHILDREN ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY UNDER
REPRESENTED IN FOSTER CARE. JUST
DISPARITY REFERS TO UNEQUAL
TREATMENT OUTCOMES FOR DIFFERENT
GROUPS IN THE SAME CIRCUMSTANCES
OR AT THE SAME DECISION POINT IN
OUR SYSTEM SO IN INEQUALITY
BETWEEN THE RATE OF PLACE IN THE
FOSTER CARE FOR CHILDREN. OF
DIFFERENT ETHNIC GROUPS WOULD BE
A DISPARITY IN ENTRY RIGHT. THE
TRENDS. FOR THESE DISPARITIES
ARE REPRESENTED IN THE FORM OF
RATIOS THERE A SUMMARY MEASURE
BY WHICH WE CAN HELP SHOW THE
DEGREE OF THIS INEQUALITY AT
DIFFERENT DECISION POINTS ALONG
THE CHAO WALKER COULD CHANGE.
BASICALLY WE COMPARE THE RATE AT
A GIVEN DECISION POINT OF ONE
GROUP WITH ANOTHER SO FOR
EXAMPLE. IN TWENTY TWENTY BLACK
CHILDREN ENTERED FOSTER CARE AT
A RATE OF ABOUT EIGHT POINT
SEVEN PER THOUSAND. WHILE WHITE
CHILDREN ENTERED FOSTER CARE
RATE ABOUT TWO POINT ONE PER
THOUSAND SO THE BLACK WHITE
DISPARITY RATIO FOR ENTRIES.
WOULD BE THE EIGHT POINT SEVEN
DIVIDED BY THE TWO POINT ONE
GIVING US A COLLECTION OF ABOUT
ADJUSTABLE CORD THAT IS TO SAY.
BLACK CHILDREN WERE ABOUT FOUR
TIMES AS LIKELY AS WHITE
CHILDREN ENTER FOSTER CARE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY. THE RATIOS FOR.
TO FOR OF KERR WITH THE WHAT
FIRST SHALL BLACK AND DATA
AMERICAN. CHILDREN ARE ALMOST TO
FIVE TIMES OF LIKE AS WHITE.
COULD BE AMONG THOSE CLIENTS OF
THE TRIAL WELFARE TO. WHAT NEXT
CHILDREN ARE SLIGHTLY LIKE THAN
WHITE AND A- OVER BELIEVED. WHEN
THE TOM POPPY AND USE OF THE
REFERENCE AT RISK. THESE RACIAL
DISPARITIES ARE ROBOTS THAT HAVE
BEEN NOTED AS LONG AS WE'VE BEEN
TRACKING DATA YEAH. MANY
RESEARCHERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE RIGHTLY POINTED OUT THAT
POVERTY IS A CRITICAL FACTOR
THAT COULD INFLUENCE CHILDREN
FAMILY CONTACT WITH CHILD
WELFARE. SHOWS THE STEP IN THE
DIRECTION OF TAKING POVERTY NO
CAP IN THE CALCULATION OF
DISPARITY RATIOS WITH BERKELEY
HAVE USED THE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
SURVEY. TO GENERATE DISPARITY
RATIOS THAT ARE BASED OFF
POPULATION APOP YES AND IT'S
BASICALLY WE USE THE ACS
ESTIMATES. TO CHOP THE
UNDERLYING REFERENCE POPULATION
FROM THE GENERAL CHILD
POPULATION. TO THE SHOP ELECTION
OF POVERTY AND WE DO THAT WE
FIND TO THE DEGREE OF RACIAL
DISPARITY. DECREASES BETWEEN
SOME GROUPS BLACK TODAY AMERICAN
FOR EXAMPLE IN POPPY ARE STILL
MORE LIKELY TO BE SUBSTANTIATED
REMOVED AND BEING CARE AND
FOSTER CARE THAN WHITE CHILDREN
HOBBY BUT THE MAGNITUDE AS LAST
AND- LIST YET. WHEN YOU USE THE
GENERAL POPULATION OF THE OF THE
REFERENCE POINT ALSO IN SOME
CASES THE TRENDS REVERSE WHY
CHILDREN POVERTY ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BE REFERRED. THAN BLACK. OR
NATIVE AMERICANS ON THE PROPERTY
AND WHAT NEXT CHILDREN IN
POVERTY ARE NOTABLY LESS LIKELY
THAN WHITES. TO BE AMONG
CHILDREN AT EVERY CHILD OFFER
CONTACTLESS. ALSO LOG TALKED
SOME DISPARITIES WITH RESPECT TO
ETHNIC GROUPS IT BEARS NOTING
THAT OTHER GROUP SHOULD BE
RECOGNISED. IN DISCUSSIONS OF
MORE EQUITABLE SERVICE DELIVERY
FOR EXAMPLE CHILDREN WHO ARE
LGBTQ OR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES OR SPECIAL
HEALTHCARE NEEDS STATUS. FOR ALL
OF OUR EFFORTS TO AMELIORATE
LONGSTANDING DISPARITIES WE NEED
BETTER DATA. BOTH QUANTITATIVE
DATA AND ONGOING LINKAGES ACROSS
SERVICE SYSTEMS AS WELL AS
QUALITATIVE. DATA TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL INSIGHT YOUR CLIMB
RESPECT. ON THE WORK THAT WE DO.
THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK YOU DR
NEXT WE WILL FROM FORTE DIRECTOR
PAUL AND LITIGATION. FOR THE
ALLIES FOR RIGHTS PLEASE BEGIN.
AFTERNOON THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I'M
SABRINA FORTE FROM THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS THE
ALLIANCE ADVANCES THE RIGHTS OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IMPACTED BY
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HE LEGAL
AND SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND
POLICY ADVOCACY. LAST YEAR THE
ALLIANCE AND OUR CHILD WELFARE
ADVOCACY PARTNERS HOSTED A
SUMMIT TO DISCUSS THE ROOT
CAUSES OF AND POSSESS POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS FOR THE
DISPROPORTIONATE REPRESENTATION
OF BLACK AND NATIVE AMERICAN
FAMILIES AND CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. DO THIS SUMMIT AND
ONGOING ENGAGEMENT WITH
ADVOCATES CHILD WELFARE AGENCY
STAFF SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
PEOPLE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE
SYSTEM WE PUBLISHED A REPORT
LAST YEAR ENTITLED THE PATH TO
RACIAL EQUITY IN CHILD WELFARE
VALUING FAMILY AND COMMUNITY. IT
CONTAINS OVER A DOZEN
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR REFORM THAT
FALL INTO FOUR MAIN AREAS I'M
GOING TO BE VERY SUBSTANTIALLY
SUMMARIZE THEM HERE IN THE TIME
ALLOTTED. FIRST VALUING FAMILY
AND COMMUNITY THROUGH PREVENTION
STRATEGY IS AIMED AT AVERTING
MALTREATMENT AND HALTING
UNNECESSARY FAMILY SEPARATIONS.
AMYLASE HOPE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING CONDITIONS THAT PUT
THEM AT A HIGHER MAGNITUDE OF
RISK FOR CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVEMENT POVERTY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOUSING SECURITY FOOD
INSECURITY AND CHALLENGES
RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE. NEED TO BE ABLE
TO SEE CRISP THAT SUPPORT THAT
IS RESPONSIVE TO THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS FAMILIES WHO
HAVE BEEN TRAUMATIZED BY THEIR
EXPERIENCES CALLING NINE ONE ONE
FOR HELP HAVE LEARNED NOT TO
SEEK HELP FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
OR OTHER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
PERCEIVED AS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF BUILDING A
STRONGER ARRAY OF REMOTE AND
MOBILE CRISIS RESPONSE SERVICES
THAT THAT DISPATCH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS NOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO SUPPORT A FAMILY
IN CRISIS AND THE SERVICES HAD
THE LOWEST POSSIBLE BARRIER TO
ENTRY. WE ALSO RECOMMEND THE
EXPANSION OF THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM TO SERVE A
BROADER POPULATION INCLUDING
FAMILIES THAT DON'T HAVE A CHILD
WELFARE HISTORY. AT AND ALLOWING
FOR THE GROWTH OF SUCH A PROGRAM
WOULD ALLOW FAMILIES TO NOT HAVE
TO BE AND FOSTER CARE IN ORDER
TO GET HELP AND ALLOW FOR TRUE
PREVENTION. THE SECOND AREA OF
RECOMMENDATIONS INVOLVE
ADDRESSING THE POWER IMBALANCE
BETWEEN FAMILIES AND THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM THIS WAS
IDENTIFIED BY AND FAMILIES WITH.
WITH DIRECT EXPERIENCE OF IN THE
SYSTEM AS A MAJOR OBSTACLE.
WE'VE HEARD REPEATEDLY AND
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT ADEQUATE
LEGAL REPRESENTATION IS
ESSENTIAL TO WRITING THIS POWER
IMBALANCE AND TO REDUCING THE
RACIALLY DISPARATE OUTCOMES FOR
FAMILIES IN THE SYSTEM. BUT
THESE DISPARITIES BEGIN WELL
BEFORE THE FAMILY APPEARS IN
COURT AND GET APPOINTED COUNSEL
AND SO WE STRONGLY RECOMMEND
THAT THE STATE INVEST IN LEGAL
REPRESENTATION BEFORE A PETITION
IS FILED AT THE MOMENT THE CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY HAS MADE THE
DECISION TO SEPARATE. A CHILD
FROM THEIR PARENTS AND WE
SUPPORT HOLISTIC PRE PETITION
LEGAL REPRESENTATION THAT
INCLUDES ATTORNEYS WITH
EXPERTISE AND DEPENDENCY LAW OF
COURSE BUT ALSO ADVOCATES. WHO
CAN PROVIDE CIVIL LEGAL AID TO
ADDRESS THE FAMILIES UNDERLYING
NEEDS. THIRD WE RECOMMEND
STRATEGIES TO EMPOWER THE FAMILY
NETWORK AND CONNECT YOU TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES IF REMOVAL IS
NECESSARY. ALTHOUGH WE KNOW THE
EVIDENCE ON KINSHIP CARE YOU
KNOW THAT IT IMPROVES
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THE KEEP
SIBLINGS TOGETHER. ONE OF THE
MOST SELF EVIDENT BENEFITS TO
KINSHIP CARE AS THAT ALLOWS A
CHILD TO STAY CLOSE TO THEIR
COMMUNITY THEIR CULTURE AND
THEIR IDENTITY. WE'RE EXCITED TO
PARTNER WITH DSS ON ROBUST
IMPLEMENTATION OF LEGISLATION
FROM LAST YEAR THAT REMOVED
BARRIERS RELATED TO CRIMINAL
HISTORY AND CAPACITY THAT
PREVENTS RELATIVES AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK WHAT
THE NEXT A NATIVE AMERICAN
RELATIVES- IN COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM. FROM BECOMING A RESOURCE
PARENTS AND SUPPORT MORE UP
FRONT FAMILY FINDING AND
ENGAGEMENTS TO MAINTAIN FAMILY
CONNECTIONS AND EXPANSION OF THE
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM TO FACILITATE EARLY
PLACEMENTS WITH RELATIVES.
LASTLY AND RELATEDLY IT'S
CRITICAL TO PRIORITIZE FAMILY
AND COMMUNITY CENTERED PATHWAYS
TO REUNIFICATION AND PERMANENCY
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF REFORMS AND
INVESTMENTS THAT SUPPORT
FAMILIES PREFERRED PERMANENCY
ARRANGEMENTS. ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS
TO ENSURE PARITY FOR RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS WHO ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BE OLDER WOMEN OF COLOR WITH
FIXED INCOMES CARING FOR
CHILDREN OF COLOR. AT ALL STAGES
OF THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM A
FEW GAPS DO REMAIN. WE SUPPORT
GIVING JUVENILE COURTS MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO ORDER
GUARDIANSHIP WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
OF THE FAMILY'S CHOICE RATHER
THAN ORDER THE CHILD INTO FOSTER
CARE. AND THIS CAN ONLY HAPPEN
IF THE- PROPOSED CAN GAP PROGRAM
EXPANSION TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR THESE EARLY OFFRAMP
UNDER THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
ARE IMPLEMENTED. A SYSTEM THAT
REQUIRES A CHILD TO BE IN CARE
FOR A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE A ONGOING
PERMANENCY FIFTEEN UNDERCUTS THE
BROADER SYSTEMIC GOAL OF
TAILORING A FAMILY CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT TO THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND TIMELINES.
I KNOW THAT I MET TIME AND
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE TO SAY
ABOUT THESE VERY RICH QUESTIONS
BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ALLIANCE'S REPORT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM STACY LEAD CHIEF
LEARNING OFFICER. AND DIRECTOR
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD WITH CHILDREN
NOW AND I WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
BUDGET CHAIR FOLDING. HAS JOINED
OUR HEARING HERE TODAY. PLEASE
BEGIN MISLI. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THIS CAN I'M STACEY
LEAVITT CHIEF LEARNING OFFICER
AND SENIOR MANAGING DIRECTOR FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD WITH CHILDREN
NOW THE CHILL OF CHILDREN'S
RESEARCH POLICY AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON BUILDING
POWER FOR KIDS THERE TO TWENTY
SIX ACROSS EDUCATION HEALTH AND
CHILD WELFARE IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR QUESTION NINTENDO I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE A STEP
BACK AND LOOK AT THE POPULATION
OF YOUNG CHILDREN IN OUR STATE.
CALIFORNIA IS THE NATION'S MOST
POPULOUS STATE. TWO POINT THREE
MILLION CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO
FOR MORE THAN THE TOTAL
POPULATION OF FIFTEEN STATES.
70% ARE CHILDREN OF COLOR 63%
ARE LIVING ALONE CAN HOUSEHOLDS.
WE'VE THE MOST CHILDREN LIVING
IN POVERTY IN THE NATION.
CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST EXPENSIVE
STATE IN WHICH TO RAISE A CHILD.
FAMILIES OF COLOR ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN LOWER INCOME.
LEVELS TO THE LAYERS OF SYSTEMIC
DISCRIMINATION INCLUDING
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO JOBS
THAT PAY A LIVING WAGE. BACK OF
ACCESS TO QUALITY SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE ANY BLACK THE QUALITY.
GEN EXCLUSIONARY IMMIGRATION
POLICIES AREAS TO EQUITABLE
HOUSING AND DISCRIMINATORY
CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICIES. THAT
MAKE EXACERBATING THE NIGHT BUT
HE AS MANY AS ONE AND FAMILIES
REPORTED. PAYING FOR BASIC NEEDS
LIKE FOOD HOUSING AND UTILITIES
WELL ROUGHLY HALF OF LOW INCOME
BLACK AND LATINO FAMILIES
REPORTED CHALLENGES IN THESE
AREAS. A NATIONAL SURVEY
DESIGNED TO GATHER INFORMATION
ABOUT EARLY CHILDHOOD FAMILY
WELL BEING DURING THE PANDEMIC
SHOWED THAT IT INCREASED
MATERIAL HARDSHIP CORRELATES
WITH GREATER EMOTIONAL DISTRESS
FOR CAREGIVERS AND FAMILY.
ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN RESPONSIBLE
FOR CARING FOR A BABY DOES NOT
INCREDIBLY HARD THAT CAN BE
WHOEVER YOU ARE. BUT IF YOU'RE
ALSO NOT SURE WHERE YOU WILL
SLEEP AT NIGHT WHEN YOU WILL GET
A PAYCHECK NEXT MONTH. HAVE
ENOUGH TO. EXPERIENCE TRAUMA
AND- NOBODY TO TALK TO FOR
SUPPORT IT CAN QUICKLY BECOME A
CRISIS. HELPING FAMILIES HELP
KIDS. WELL AS YOU CAN PROGRAMS
THAT JUST MOMENTARY EVIDENCE
BASED HOME VISITING. FAMILY
LEAVE AND INCOME ASSISTANCE ARE
EFFECTIVE COST EFFECTIVE
INVESTMENT. CALIFORNIA'S MAKING
STRIDES IN REACHING FAMILIES
THROUGH THE SUPPORT OF PROGRAMS
THERE ARE STILL FAR TOO MANY
FAMILIES WHO MAY WANT ADDITIONAL
HELP BUT AREN'T GETTING IT.
CHILDREN NOW TWENTY TWENTY TWO
CALIFORNIA REPORT CARD IF STATE
LEADERS EPLUS FOR CHILDCARE SB
MINUS IN VOLUNTARY HOME
VISITING. A SIMPLE. EMILY AND
EVEN TODD WELFARE CATEGORIES.
NATIONAL RANKINGS IN THESE AREAS
ALSO SHOW CALIFORNIA FAR BELOW
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE OFTEN IN
THE BOTTOM QUARTILE FOR
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
SYSTEM. IN MOST OF THESE
CATEGORIES IT IS NOT THAT WE'RE
NOT DOING GOOD THINGS BUT WE ARE
SIMPLY NOT INVESTING ENOUGH AT A
BIG ENOUGH SCALE TO MAKE AN
IMPACT AT THE POPULATION LEVEL.
CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY SERVING
UNDER 2% OF THE POPULATION WHO
MIGHT BENEFIT FROM HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS. EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING MODELS HAVE DECADES OF
RESEARCH SHOWING THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT TYPE TWO
GENERATIONS SUPPORT. PREGNANT
AND PARENTING FAMILIES WITH
INFANTS AND TODDLERS MEET. HOME
VISITORS ARE TRAINED ON CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AND IMPLICIT BIAS.
TRYING TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
FOCUS ON STRENGTHENING SKILL
BUILDING TO LISTEN TO THE NEEDS
AND ASPIRATIONS OF PARENTS.
IDENTIFIED REINFORCE CULTURAL
CULTURAL PRACTICES AND PARENTING
THANK REFERRAL AND SUPPORT THEIR
CLIENTS TO SIX FEET OVER THE
SPAN OF TWO YEARS OR MORE. THE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE BENEFITS
OF EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
LAST A LIFETIME. FOR THE CHILD
AND PARENT. ECLIPTIC POWERED
HOMEBUILDING PROGRAM FOR EACH P.
THE PENTAGON DIFFERENT IT'S-
DIVERTED STOP AND POP HEALTH
EACH FOR ACTIVITIES OFTEN BUT
BEAT AT SUPPORT INCUMBENT. THIS
LED TO A SIX SLOWDOWN IN
ENROLLMENT OUTREACH FOR NEW
FAMILY THE GOOD NEWS IS FAMILIES
INVOLVED IN SPEAKING IN PROGRAM
IN THE RECENT ABOUT OF FOR THE
ATP THERE WERE OVER TWO SIX
SERVICES FAMILIES WERE THIRTY.
MOST FREQUENT WERE FOR THE
CHURCH OKAY HOW SUPPORT AND
MENTAL SERVICES. OF THOSE
REFERRED SERVICES SIXTY TO
NINETY OR MORE ACTS THEM OVER
THE OTHERS THE OF CONNECT TO
HELP ENSURE WE ARE MAX AND THE
REESE ALL IN PLAY FOR FAMILY AND
IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES. AS WE
MAKE OUR WAY TO FINDING A NEW
NORMAL IT WILL BE IMPORTANT TO
RAIN GAUGE OR AGENCY COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND ALL THE FAMILIES IN
THE PRAYER BOOK OPENING PROGRAMS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. WE NEED TO
ENSURE ALL ELIGIBLE FAMILIES ARE
AWARE OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN OFFERED
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADULTS WE MUST
ALSO ENSURE PROVIDERS REFLECT
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE AT
THE WORKFORCE IS TRAINED IN ANTI
RACISTSERVICE DELIVERY AND
UNDERSTAND THE PARTICULAR AREAS
BLACK WOMEN FACE AND HEALTHCARE
AND OTHER SYSTEMS. CULTURALLY
ALIGNED PARTS AND LANGUAGE
ACCESSIBILITY PRIORITIZE THAT WE
MONITORED TO FOUND FROM BLACK
BROWN RIGHT IMMIGRANT AND
MIGRANT POPULATIONS AREN'T BOTH
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM KIM JONG
WITH THE CAL DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL. PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
JERRY GOOD AFTERNOON KIM JONG AT
KALKA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL TO I
JUST WANTED NAY IN A- THE FOCUS
THIS AND- IS AFTER. AND
COMMITTEE TO COULD OUR WORK
TOGETHER TO REDUCE AND ELIMINATE
THESE DISPARITIES WAS IT EXIST
ACROSS OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
IN CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO ECHO IT
APPRECIATE YOUR NOTE ABOUT
STRENGTHENING OUR PREVENTION
BASSIL. I THINK THAT FORMER
FEDERAL LEADER AT WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION CHILDREN FAMILIES
THAT THIS WELL POVERTY IS A RISK
FACTOR FOR NEGLECT BUT POVERTY
DOES NOT EQUATE TO NEGLECT THAT
PRESENTS THE POVERTY ALONE DOES
NOT MEAN A CHILD IS AND SAFE AND
LOVED OR THAT A PARENT LACKS THE
CAPACITY TO CARE FOR HIS OR HER
CHILD. POVERTY CAN MAKEIT MORE
CHALLENGING FOR PARENTS TO MEET
CERTAIN. AT THE NEEDS OF THEIR
CHILDREN BUT WE MUST BE
REASONABLE CARE THAT THE CHILD
SHOULD NEVER BE REMOVED FROM HIS
OR HER HER. HOME DUE TO POVERTY
ALONE OR THEIR HOME SEPT ONE AT
LIFT THAT UP AND CERTAINLY
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THAT AT ROBUST
DIALOGUE IN THE AGENDA THAT'S
INCLUDED HERE. FOUR AT THE
QUESTIONS IN THE AGENDA AND HOW
DO THESE WEIRD PERSON TURNED IT
OVER TO OUR CHIEF DEPUTY
ACTUALLY MET AT THE DIRECTOR
SHORTS IN JUST A MOMENT TO SPEAK
MORE AND CHILD WELFARE SPACE NOT
TOUCH ON A FEW ITEMS I WANTED TO
START WITH OUR OVER ARCHING
PRINCIPLE OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. FOCUSED ON EQUITY WHICH
REALLY SPEAKS TO OUR ABILITY TO
CREATE A STATE FOR ALL OF US
HAVE A CHANCE TO THRIVE BASED ON
OUR EFFORTS AND HARD WORK. WE
CANNOT ALLOW CERTAIN GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS TO BE DISADVANTAGED
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN GENDER IDENTITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AGE OR DISABILITY
AND ADD NOTING THAT WE WILL SEEK
TO LIFT ALL BOATS BUT SOME FOLKS
NEED TO BE LIFTED MORE.
OVERARCHING OUR GOAL IS TO JUST
ABOUT POVERTY BY PROVIDING
STRENGTH BASED SERVICES AND
RESOURCES THAT TANGIBLY ADDRESS
THESE INEQUITIES AND I'LL GO
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE EXAMPLES
IN JUST A MOMENT BUT I'LL START
FIRST WITH ASK THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM
DESIGNED THE POLICY DEVELOPMENTS
THE DELIVERY OF THOSE SERVICES
AND WANT TO. I JUST AGAIN I'VE
SPOKEN. TO THIS ACTIVIST
COMMITTEE ON A PATH. ONE OF THE
FIRST. AT I DID COMING INTO THE-
OVER TO YOUR AGO NOW. WAS THE
ESTABLISH. OF OFFICE OF EQUITY.
REALLY REFER. THE PART MISSION
WHICH CALL ON US TO. EIGHT
PROTECT MEDIA PER. CHILDREN AND
ADULTS. TO DO THAT OF. LESS THE
ROOT CAUSES OF THEIR PROPERTY
AND SOCIAL VULNERABILITY. AND
ALSO EXAMINED THE UNEQUAL
DISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH AND
POWER. I WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS- AND I
APPRECIATE OUR LEADER IN THIS
SPACE AT THE DIRECTOR OF OFFICE
OF ACNE MARCELLA LEADS TO REALLY
IN BAD. EQUITY AND ENGAGEMENT
PRINCIPLES THROUGHOUT. THE
DEPARTMENT. REALLY ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE THE COMPETENCIES IN
CAPACITY. AS WE ARE ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES AND THE POWER THAT
WE HAVE IN THAT GAME DESIGN
THOSE PROGRAMS AND POLICIES TO
DO JUST THAT. IN SOME CASES THAT
MEANS ACTUALLY I'M DOING
POLICIES THAT ARE CONTINUING
THOSE DISPARITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY. AND OTHER
EXAMPLES IT'S ABOUT THE HOW
YOU'RE APPROACHING OUR WORK
WORKING HOW YOUR PRODUCT
PRIORITIZING IT. SO AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT I WANT TO LIFT
UP OUR OFFICE OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS
THAT HAD WAS ESTABLISHED PRIOR
TO MY COMING INTO THIS ROLE. I
WHICH REALLY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
BUILDING BETTER GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIPS WITH
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT. OF
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES COUNTY
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. AS WELL AS
OTHER NATIVE AMERICANS
STAKEHOLDERS PART OF THAT
MEETING CORE CHARGE OF THAT
OFFICE IS AROUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE ACT. WHICH WAS
ENACTED AFTER NATIVE AMERICAN
CHILDREN WERE SYSTEMICALLY
REMOVED OFTEN WITHOUT EVIDENCE
OF ABUSE OR NEGLECT. THAT WOULD
BE CONSIDERED GROUNDS FOR
REMOVAL AND PLACED WITH NON
NATIVE FAMILIES AND SO AGAIN.
OUR LINE CALIFORNIA TOGETHER WE
HAVE CONFIRMED THAT DOZEN INDIAN
CHILD'S BEST INTEREST TO ENHANCE
AND PROTECT THE CHILD
CONNECTIONS TO THEIR TRIBE AND
TRIBAL COMMUNITY. AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THAT FEDERAL
LAW. AS WAS REFERENCE JUST THAT
RAP PRICE MISLI BEFORE. AT THIS
ESTATE BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AT AND- ADAM THIS
LET. I HAS DONE AND THAT AT AND
NEVER OF THINGS IN TERMS OF
AREN'T. IN OUR APP POLICY. AT
THAT YET HAD PAID FAMILY WAS
MEANT WE'VE- THE- TURN INCOME
TAX CREDIT ALSO IN THAT SPACE.
AT THE TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE
THAT THE FEDERAL CHILD TAX
CREDIT MADE- ON AT FAMILIES AT
INCOME AND THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. OF COURSE A LOT OF
INVESTMENT AND CONTINUING TO
STRENGTHEN OUR QUALITY CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM
UNDERSTANDING AND RECOGNIZING
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT GIVES
CHILDREN NOT ONLY IN THE SHORT
TERM BUT ALSO IN THE LONG RUN. I
WE SPOKE TO THIS COMMITTEE
PRIVATE PREVIOUSLY ABOUT THE
INVESTMENTS WE'VE MADE TOGETHER
TO FIND THE GUARANTEED INCOME
PILOT PROJECT TO PROVIDE
UNCONDITIONAL INDIVIDUAL REGULAR
CASH PAYMENTS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT. THE BASIC NEEDS EVERY
STEP DANCING HOW LEARNING HOW.
HEARING THIS WITH OUR SOCIAL
SAFETY NET RESOURCES PRODUCES
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR FAMILIES.
WE'VE ALSO DONE THINGS LIKE THAT
HOW WORKS OUT COMES
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW INITIATIVE
REALLY IN RECOGNITION THAT WHAT
WE WANT FOR OUR PROGRAMS IS
MORE. THAN JUST- EQUATING TO THE
NUMBER OF HOURS THAT I
PARTICIPATE WORKS BUT REALLY
LOOKING AT FAMILY AND CHILD WELL
BEING OF THE FAMILIES
PARTICIPATING CALPERS HOW
THEY'RE ACCESSING. AND HOW THE
SERVICES ARE DELIVERED HOW
THEY'RE ENGAGING WITH THE
PROGRAM. HOW THEY ARE GETTING
RESOURCE ISN'T CONNECTED TO.
YOUR MOBILE. IN ADDITION. AND
AGAIN WHEN I APPRECIATE THE
CHURCH LEADERSHIP WE HAVE EVERY
MINUTE IN OPERATIONALIZE AS WAS
MENTIONED INVOLUNTARY STRENGTH
BASED HOME VISITING PROGRAM AND
CAL WORKS REALLY LOOKING TO
SUPPORT POSITIVE HEALTH
DEVELOPMENT WELL BEING OUTCOMES.
FOR PREGNANT PARENTING PEOPLE
FAMILIES IN INFANTS BORN INTO
POVERTY EXPANDING THEIR FUTURE
EDUCATIONAL ECONOMIC AND
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY
OPPORTUNITIES. IN IMPROVING THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY WILL EXCEPT
PROPERTY THAT INITIATIVE WILL
DESIGNED VERY SPECIFICALLY. I IN
MIND WITH THE LIKE WE WANT TO
THAT. OF THE VISITORS THAT BE
CULTURAL LANGUAGE BUT I. AS YOUR
AGENDA POINTS. THEIR ROLE AS MAY
REPORTERS ARE THEY- THAT THE- OF
RESOURCE IS AT A WAY IN WHICH
YOU'RE CONNECTING TO THE
RESOURCE. I AM HELPING THOSE
FAMILIES BECOME STABLE. ARE WE
ACTUALLY PROVIDE ALLOWANCES THE
MAC PROGRAM AS WE DO TODAY TO
ALLOW THE HOME VISITOR TO WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THOSE FAMILIES TO
ADDRESS IMMEDIATE NEEDS. AT A
GIVEN THE REFERRALS THAT WE SEEM
TO DATE HAVE BEEN AT AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS FOR FUTURE FOOD
SECURITY FOR ACCESSING MATERIAL
GOODS LIKE CAR SEATS CRIBS AND
OTHER ESSENTIAL ITEMS AFTERNOON.
AT PARENTS SO AGAIN WANTED JUST
RECOGNIZE THE INTENTION BEHIND
THE DESIGN OF THAT INITIATIVE
OUR CONNECTIONS TO HIDE THE
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT AGAIN
OUR INTEGRATED IN THIS
INITIATIVE AS WELL AS OUR
CONNECTION TO IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES WHICH WE NOW. PROVIDE
TOO GREAT A TRAJECTORY OF GOOD
OUTCOMES FOR FAMILIES IN OUR
CALIFORNIANS SO I LIFT THAT UP
AS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE WAYS
IN WHICH WE ARE ADDRESSING YEAH
DISPARITIES. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT IN CAL THE WORKS THAT'S THE
QUESTION ASKED WE DOWN IN A LOT
OVER THE COURSE OF. THE LAST.
PROGRESSED AND HOW WE'RE LOOKING
AT FAMILYREUNIFICATION POLICIES
AND CAL WORKS EVERYTHING FROM
OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO- WE
IDENTIFIED AND ALLOW FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF CAL WORKS
WELFARE TO WORK SERVICES BUT
ALSO LAUNCHING THINGS LIKE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME DESIGNED
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF FAMILIES
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
EXPERIENCING ART RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS TO INCREASE FAMILY
REUNIFICATION AND TO PREVENT
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT HOWARD'S
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM HOSTED
SYSTEMS AGAIN LOOKING AT MEETING
THE NEEDS. AB CURRENCY OUR PARTY
IN CAL. AND THEN A COURSE MOST
RECENTLY. AT BEGINNING JOE OF
THIS YEAR. IN THE FAMILY AT WHAT
IT CHILD WORKERS ARE CORE
ORDERED READ. PLANS MAKE LG TO
COULD RISK. THAT THE SUPPORTS
AND SERVICES THAT WILL HELP THEM
GAIN NEXT ABILITY TO ACT SURE
THAT REUNIFICATION IS
SUCCESSFUL. AND ALSO NOTED IN
THIS SPACE AND CAL WORKS THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE MOST
RECENTLY GOT TOGETHER I'M
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING FOR THE
STAFF AGAIN WORKING WITH
FAMILIES. FINALLY I JUST WANT TO
LIFT UP A PROJECT THAT WAS KNOWN
AS THE LINKAGES WHICH WAS A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE CAO
WORKS AND CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
TO PROMOTE YOUR CASE MANAGEMENT.
AGAIN OF FAMILY REUNIFICATION
ENSURING THAT WE WERE HAVING
CONFLICTING LAWS- THAT WERE IN
THE- MIDST IN ASKING AT THOSE
THE FAMILIES AND WE'VE HAD.
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS WITH THAT
INITIATIVE OVER OVER TIME AND
THE INVESTMENT IN THE DOLLARS
HAVE TO HAVE- VARIED OVER TIME
BUT WE ARE IN JUST ACTUALLY THIS
WEEK HAVE WATCHED LINKAGES TO
POINT OUT. AT TO REALLY LOOK AT
A NEW EMPHASIS ON THIS
PREVENTION FRAMEWORK IN THE
SPACE. SO I GET A LOT. IN THE
GIVEN THE TIME A LOT OF THOSE
ARE SOME OF ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS EXAMPLES BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE MORE WORK TO
DO HERE. WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND OUR COMPETENCIES AND
ABILITY DESIGNED THESE PROGRAMS
AND POLICIES TO RACIAL. EQUITY
LANCE AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I
HAVE WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
ON. I'LL NOW TURN IT OVER TO OUR
TECHNICAL RECTOR AND HE STARTS
TO SAY MORE ABOUT YOUR SECOND
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT. IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. GOOD AFTERNOON
AROUND ON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME DANCE IS FOR
IT BUT THE DIRECTOR THE CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION. I
WANT TO START BY ECHOING THE
APPRECIATION OF THE INCLUSION OF
THE PANEL IN TODAY'S HEARING.
AND THE RICH DISCUSSION TODAY. I
TRACTOR JOHNSON STATED THE FOCUS
ON RACIAL EQUITY AND ADDRESSING
THE DISPARITY AND THE
PROPORTIONALITY WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM IS AT THE CORE OF ALL THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING. AND OUR
MANY INITIATIVES AND PROJECTS
UNDER WAY THAT ADDRESS THESE
DISPARITIES AND PROMOTE RACIAL
EQUITY- HIGHLIGHTED KEOGH. FIRST
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF. A
EQUIPPED STATE. WHICH WILL
ENSURE. OF THE INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT WITH GREATER
FIDELITY ACROSS THE STATE AND
ENSURE THAT OUR TRAVEL YOU.
REMAIN CONNECTED TO THEIR
FAMILIES CULTURES AND
COMMUNITIES. I CAN'T I
CALIFORNIA CHILD WELFARE
REGIONAL TRAINING ACADEMIES
WHICH LEADS HEALTH WELFARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
AROUND THE STATE. HAVE DEVELOPED
AN OFFER COURSES FOCUSED ON
RACIAL EQUITY DISPROPORTIONATELY
AND IMPLICIT BIAS FROM THE TOP
SYSTEM INCLUDING NOW HOW TO
CONCRETE LEE ADDRESS BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION PRETTY PRACTICE
CHANGES. WE'VE ALSO BEEN WORKING
TO IMPROVE THE CALIPHATE CHILD
WELFARE COURT PRACTICE MODEL AND
THE INTEGRATED CORE PRACTICE
MODEL IN COLLABORATION WITH
COUNTIES AND OUR SYSTEM OF CARE
PARTNER. THE CALIFORNIA COURT
PRACTICE MODEL AN INTEGRATED
CORE PRACTICE MODEL ESTABLISHED
COMMON BEHAVIORAL EXPECTATIONS.
AIRLINE STAFF AND LEADERSHIP
INCLUDING RACIAL EQUITY AND
INCLUSION PRINCIPLE AND PRACTICE
AS- I'M MORE FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING OUR DATA SYSTEMS AS
WELL FOR EXAMPLE RCW STMS THE
SPAM HAS BEEN UPDATED TO TRACK
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY AND EXPRESSION BEIJING
INFORMATION. MANAGEMENT
DEVELOPING NEW CARE SYSTEM WORK
FOCUSED ON ENSURING THAT THERE
IS NEW DATA ELEMENTS ALLOW US TO
BETTER TRACK DISPARITIES AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY. WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM. IMPORTANTLY EVERY LAST
THAT YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL REFORMS AIMED AT
IMPROVING INSURING THAT CHILDREN
WHO ARE REMOVED FROM A PARENT.
CAN REMAIN CONNECTED TO THEIR
OWN RELATIVES IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES THESE EFFORTS HAVE
INCLUDED EQUAL FUNDING FOR
RELATIVES THROUGH THE CREATION
AND EXPANSION. OF THE APPROVED
RELATIVE CAREGIVER PROGRAM
CREATION OF THE EMERGENCY CARE
GIVER PROGRAMS SO THAT CHILDREN
CAN BE IMMEDIATELY CONNECTED
WITH A FAMILY MEMBER AND
SUPPORTED IN THAT HOME. AND
EXPANSION OF THE INFANT
SUPPLEMENTS ALONGSIDE WORK TO
CHANGE POLICIES AND PRACTICES
THAT IMPACT OUR PARENTING
DEPENDENT AND NON MINOR
DEPENDENT TO SUPPORT THESE YOUNG
PARENTS AND AVOID REMOVAL OF
THEIR CHILDREN EMPLACEMENT IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. AND WE
HAVE FAR. ON DEVELOPING A MORE
ROBUST AND COMPREHENSIVE
CONTINUUM OF PREVENTION SERVICE
SAYS. IN AN EFFORT TO PREVENT
CHILDREN FROM COMING INTO FOSTER
CARE IN THE FIRST AND THEN AND
THIS WORK IS BEING DONE VERY
EXPLICITLY FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
AND EQUITY LINES. THE DATA
HIGHLIGHTED TODAY REMINDS US
THAT THERE'S MUCH MORE TO BE
DONE AND WE APPRECIATE. THE
RECOMMENDATION SHARED BY THE
FORTE AND THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS I ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE BREAKDOWN OF THE
RECOMMENDATION TO ADDRESS THE
THIRTY AT EVERY STAGE OF OUR TOP
WELFARE BUT SAM. AND I'M LOOKING
AT THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE CAN
SEE THAT THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT WORK DONE IN JUST
THE LAST YEAR TO ADVANCE SOME OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE REPORT. I THINK
THE NEXT ACTION OF PREVENTION
FUNDING FOR THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET OF TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT COUNTY EFFORT IN
DEVELOPING THAT COMPREHENSIVE
ARRAY OF PREVENTION SERVICES.
AND ENSURE WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
CULTURALLY RELEVANT AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES BUT.
THEN OUR PREVENTION CONTINUE ON.
WE'RE ALSO CREATING A CAN. PASS
WE ARE ABLE. OF THE FAMILY
PREVENTION BUT THE BACK TO
ENSURE THAT TRUSTED COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. CAN DELIVER PREVENTION
SERVICES TO SUPPORT FAMILIES
WITHOUT REQUIRING THEM TO
DIRECTLY ENGAGE WITH CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY IT. OUR
PREVENTION PLAN ALSO ENSURES
THAT ARE EXPECTED IN PARENTING
YOUNG PEOPLE WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
THE FULL ARRAY OF PREVENTION
SERVICES THE PREPAID THE PLAN.
IMAGE FOURTEEN MENTION AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM WHICH
CONTINUES TO SHOW TREMENDOUS
PROMISE. WE'RE INTERESTED IN
EXPLORING HOW TO EXPAND THAT
MODEL TO SUPPORT A GREATER
NUMBER OF CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
IN ADDITION THE CALIFORNIA
PARENTS NEED HELP LINE THAT WE
PROPOSE CONTINUING AND- THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS HAVE
BEEN A GREAT SUPPORT IN
PREVENTION STRATEGY OUR FAMILY.
WE BELIEVE THE START OF LINES.
GROUPS AND MOBILE RIFAI TEAMS
THAT. IMPORTANT TO PREVENT
INJURIES IN THE FOSTER CARE AND
TO ENSURE PLACEMENT STABILITY
AND FIX THAT. THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT THE TIME KEEPING THE
CHILDREN HARLEM FROM. CONNECTED
TO THEIR- OWN FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITY. WE AGREED THE CHILD
OKAY TEAM NEED TO BE CENTERED IN
CULTURAL COMPLEX. AND CONTINUED
DEVELOP CONTINUE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT. PETER DELIVERING ON
THOSE GOALS. WE'VE SEEN GREAT
SUCCESS OF THE SCREENING
APPROACH WENT WELL AND WE'RE
WORKING TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE.
THAT AT THE TEAMING UP TO
INTEGRATE ALL THE ASPECTS OF OUR
INTEGRATED CORE PRACTICE OF.
FILING THE PARKING MENTION THE
PASSAGE OF SB THREE FIFTY FOUR
LAST YEAR MORE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS NOW TO FINALIZE THE
GUIDANCE THE PERFORMANCE WHICH
WE BELIEVE WILL FURTHER THE
EFFORTS TO KEEP CHILDREN.
CONNECTED WITH THEIR OWN
FAMILIES AND THEIR OWN COMMUNITY
. WE GREATLY OF. THE DISCUSSION
. AND THE- FOCUS ON THE FERRY
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM. UNLESS FORTY.
ENGAGEMENT AND WORKING TOGETHER
TO ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES AND
ENSURE EQUITY PRODUCT THAT'S
THEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM JUSTIN FREITAS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THAT'S JUST RAISED BERMAN OF
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTS ARE
COMMENTS TO MAKE THIS TIME BUT
AVAILABLE FOR ANY RESPONSES OR
ANSWERS TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OF NECESSARY. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM ANGELES SHORT
WITH THE L. A. L. THANK YOU CHEN
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON ANGELES
SHORT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. I'LL BE
PRESENTING TODAY USING A HAND
OUT WHICH I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
COPY UP. IT'S ALSO AVAILABLE ON
THE ALEJO'S WEBSITE AS WELL AS
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S WEBPAGE. THE
FIRST QUESTION IN YOUR AGENDA
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO ADDRESS IS
ONE OF OUT OF OBSERVATIONS AND
POINTS OF INTEREST IN THIS
CONVERSATION. CURRENTLY IS IN
THE MIDST OF ANALYSIS AIMING TO
HELP THE LEGISLATURE UNDERSTAND
RACIAL DISPROPORTIONATELY IS AND
DISPARITIES IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. AND TO IDENTIFY POLICY
LEVERS THAT COULD HELP ADDRESS
THOSE INEQUITIES. WORKING ON THE
ANALYSIS BECAUSE AS YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY TALK WELFARE IS AN AREA
WHERE THERE ARE VERY CLEAR AND
PERVASIVE INEQUITIES THAT HAVE
PERSISTED OVER TIME. ARE ALSO
RESPONDING TO THE LEGISLATURE
INTEREST AS DISCUSSED BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LAST SPRING IN
IDENTIFYING STATE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE NATURAL CANDIDATES FOR FOCUS
AND WORK TOWARD ADDRESSING
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES IN
THE HUMAN SERVICES AREA. BUT
THAT TWENTY TWO PAGES ONE AND
TWO OF THE HANDOUT I'LL BRIEFLY
DISCUSS SOME KEY DATA
ILLUSTRATING CURRENT DISPARITIES
WHICH HAVE HELPED TO- PROMPTS
AND REALLY INFORM OUR ONGOING
RESEARCH. I THINK HER TODAY
HELLO IN CALIFORNIA BLACK AND
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH IN
PARTICULAR ARE OVER REPRESENTED
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
RELATIVE TO THEIR RESPECTIVE
SHARES OF THE POPULATION AS
ILLUSTRATED BY THE FIGURE. IN
ADDITION RESEARCH AUTHORED BY
DOCTORS AND WE PUT IMPORTANT
QUARANTINE DANIEL WEBSTER YOU
HEARD FROM EARLIER ON THE PANEL.
AND OTHERS ON CUMULATIVE CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT OF A
CALIFORNIA BIRTH COHORT. FOUND
NEARLY 50% OF BLACK AND NATIVE
AMERICAN CHILDREN EXPERIENCED
SOME LEVEL OF CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT BY THE TIME
THEY TURNED EIGHTEEN. AND THIS
IS COMPARED TO LOWER ALTHOUGH
STILL SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGES OF
CHILDREN OF OTHER RACES. THE
SAME RESEARCH ALSO FOUND THAT
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
BOTH WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
INSURANCE EXPERIENCED CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT AT MORE THAN
TWICE THE RATE OF THOSE WITH
PRIVATE INSURANCE. BUT I NEED TO
PAGE THREE OF THE HAND OUT.
RACIAL DISPARITIES ARE PRESENT
WITHIN INITIAL ALLEGATIONS AND
PERSIST AT ALL LEVELS OF THE
SYSTEM BECOMING THE MOST
PRONOUNCED FOR YOUTH AND KERR-
AND AGAIN THIS WAS ALSO
DESCRIBED EARLIER BY DR DANIEL
WEBSTER AND IS SHOWN IN THE
FIGURE. THE PAGE FOR THE HANDS
UP HANDS OUT- NOW ADDRESS THE
SECOND QUESTION IN YOUR AGENDA.
WHAT ARE THE KEY AREAS OF POLICY
THAT THE STATE CAN FOCUS ON TO
POTENTIALLY MAKE AN IMPACT TO
REDUCE AND ELIMINATE DISPARITIES
IN CHILD WELFARE. THERE ARE FOUR
MAIN POLICY AREAS WE PLAN TO
EXPLORE ON GOING RESEARCH AND
HEALTH. WE AT WE PLAN TO
IDENTIFY MORE SPECIFIC POLICY
OPTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER AS WELL AS TO- WAIT
WAIT IS THE TRADE OFF AND
POTENTIAL BUDGETARY IMPLICATIONS
OF THE OPTION. THE DAY- I'LL
START BY SHARING SOME INITIAL
KEY QUESTIONS GUIDING THE FIRST
PHASE ABOUT RESEARCH. FOR ALL
THE AREA THAT WE'RE RESEARCHING
IS MANDATED REPORTING. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF MALTREATMENT
ALLEGATIONS COME FROM MANDATED
REPORTERS TO INCLUDE THE
TEACHERS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
WARM. THANK YOU QUESTION FOR
EXPLORING AROUND THE POLICY AREA
INCLUDE DEMANDED DO MANDATED
REPORTERS RECEIVE SUFFICIENT
TRAINING IN PARTICULAR IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING. SHOULD ALL
MANDATED REPORTERS GO DIRECTLY
TO THE CHILD WELFARE AGENCY OR
COULD SOME REPORTS INSTEAD BE
REFERRED FOR SERVICES OR SOME
OTHER TYPE OF INTERVENTION. AND
HOW CAN THE STATE IN SHORTSTOP
WHAT CHILD SAFETY IS PRIORITISED
WATER FORMING MANDATED REPORTING
. THE NEXT POLICY AREA FOCUS OUR
RESEARCH IS REMOVAL DUE TO
NEGLECT. AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
FIGURE ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
HANDOUT THE REASON CITED FOR
MOST REMOVALS IT'S NEGLECT
RATHER THAN ABUSE. HOWEVER WE
DON'T HAVE EASILY QUANTIFIABLE
DATA ABOUT THE SPECIFIC HARM OR
RISK TO THE CHILD THAT UNDERLIES
NEGLECT ALLEGATIONS. IN OTHER
WORDS WE DON'T KNOW ENOUGH AT AN
AGGREGATED STATE LEVEL ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC SITUATIONS CAUSING
CHILDREN TO BE REMOVED DUE TO
NEGLECT. I PLEDGE FROM SHE
QUESTIONS WERE EXPLORING FOR THE
OF THE AREA INCLUDE OTHER
STATUTORY CHANGES OR
CLARIFICATIONS THAT SHOULD BE
MADE TO THE DEFINITION OF
NEGLECT. AND WHAT DATA SHOULD
THE STATE COLLECTED TO DATE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE CAUSES OF
NEGLECT FOR EXAMPLE TO WHAT
EXTENT IS NEGLECT PRIMARILY DUE
TO PARENTAL SUBSTANCE ABUSE
MENTAL HEALTH PRINT FRONTAL
ABSENT. AND HOW COULD KNOWING
THIS HELP INFORM POLICY CHANGES
TO PREVENT AND REMEDY NEGLECT
MOVING FORWARD. TURNING TO PAGE
SIX THE THIRD POLICY AREA WHERE
RE RESEARCHING IS PREVENTION.
ARE CURRENTLY AT STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES GENERALLY IS
AVAILABLE TO FAMILIES ONLY AFTER
THERE'S BEEN AN ALLEGATION AND A
FAMILY COMES TO THE ATTENTION OF
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. THE
KEY QUESTIONS WERE RESEARCHING
IN THIS AREA ARE WHAT SUPPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER TO
TARGET DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES PRIOR TO
TRAVEL OUR SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT.
AND FINALLY THE FOURTH RESEARCH
FOCUS AREA- FOR OUR ONGOING WORK
IS LINKING VULNERABLE FAMILIES
TO ECONOMIC SUPPORT. RESEARCHERS
FOUND THAT POVERTY AND ECONOMIC
STRESSORS MAY CREATE CONDITIONS
IN WHICH CHILD MALTREATMENT IS
MORE LIKELY TO OCCUR- IN
ADDITION RESEARCH HAS FOUND A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN INCREASED
STATE SPENDING ON PUBLIC BENEFIT
PROGRAMS. SUCH AS CASH IN KIND
ASSISTANCE AND HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND DECREASED CHILD
MALTREATMENT. AS SUCH THE KEY
QUESTIONS WERE BORING FOR THE
POLICY AREA INCLUDE HOW CAN THE
LEGISLATURE HELP ENSURE POVERTY
ALLEVIATION PROGRAMS AND CHILD
WELFARE SUPPORT ARE
COMPLEMENTARY. AND WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE MOST LIKELY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO IT TO A REDUCTION
IN CHILD MALTREATMENT. STOP
THERE AND HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT I WILL BRING IT
UP TO THE DÍAS TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS. WILL
BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROSS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ON THOSE
QUESTIONS AND REALLY LOOKING AT-
SOME OF THE PRESENTATION
PARTICULARLY INTO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN. COMPONENT OF IT- THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL.
SERVICES HAS BEEN WORKING TO
IMPROVE CHILD. WELFARE OUTCOMES
FOR SEVERAL YEARS BUT- WE KNOW
THAT THEY'RE STILL ACCORDING TO
THE GRASS OR STILL IS A LOT OF
WORK THAT STILL NEEDS TO BE
DONE. SO WHAT ONE OF MY FIRST
QUESTIONS IS WHAT ARE THE
BIGGEST BARRIERS THAT YOU'RE
SEEN- ON WHY WE'RE STILL SEEING
SUCH A HIGH RATE- WITHIN THE
NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN
JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AB. RESTATE THE
QUESTION AND I WOULD DEFINITELY
SAY- THAT PART OF THIS WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING RELATED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AN INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT PLAN REALLY ENSURING
THAT- WE ARE VERY STRATEGIC IN
PRIORITIZING THE RIGHT
COMPONENTS AS WE'RE GOING
FORWARD ON THE LAND IS KEY. AT
TO MAKE STRIDES AND WE ARE UNDER
THAT'S UNDER DEVELOPMENT NOW I
WOULDN'T IT FEW DIFFERENT THINGS
IN TERMS OF OUR RELATIONSHIP OF
IMPLEMENTING IT QUICKLY BEING
DEVELOPING NEW POSITIONS FOR IT
WITH FIELD SPECIALISTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO HELP. OUR BE A
BRIDGE BETWEEN IN A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDER BETWEEN
TRIBES AND COUNTIES AS WE'RE
GOING OUT. ON AS WELL BUT I
THINK ULTIMATELY AT MANY OF THE
ITEMS THAT I COVERED IN TERMS OF
HOW YOU'RE MORE APT PROBABLY
LOOKING TO BE INVESTING IN
PREVENTION AND DESTRUCTING
PROPERTY ARE WAYS IN WHICH WE
ARE SPECIFICALLY AT ADDRESSING
THAT THE INTRICATE INTRODUCTION
OF- NATIVE CHILDREN INTO THE
SYSTEM AS WELL. AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. SHORTS ANYTHING YOU'D
ACT THERE. NO I AGREED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE EQUITY PLAN
WILL HELP US CREATE THOSE
PRIORITIES THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY- WHAT THE
TRIBES OF ISRAEL ARE OFFICE OF
TRIBAL AFFAIRS IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE WORK CONNECTING ON THE
ISSUES. WHERE WE KNOW THERE
NEEDS TO BE GREATER ENGAGEMENT
SUPPORT INCLUDING TRYING TO
REALLY SUPPORT TRIED AND
DEVELOPING THEIR OWN FOUR YEAR
AGREEMENT- WITH THE STATE IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO. I'M REALLY
SUPPORT THEIR CHILDREN- THAT
WORK BETTER WITHIN THEIR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES- THE EFFORT TO DATE
AND THAT LET'S CULTURALLY
RELEVANT WAYS THEY KNOW THAT
MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR CHILDREN
IN THEIR COMMUNITY. IF IT'S OKAY
WITH YOU SIMPLY MEMBER I'D LIKE
TO BRING IN SUPREME FOR AS WELL
AS- LEAD TO PROVIDE COMMENTS TO
YOUR QUESTION. THANK YOU MISTER. AT THE SABRINA FORTY FROM THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS.
WELCOME THE INVITATION TO
COMMENT ON THIS. CRITICAL
QUESTION- AND VERY GRATEFUL TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR THE EFFORTS TAKEN
THAT'S FAR ECWA IS SEEN AS- A
GOLD STANDARD IN THE WAY- THAT
COMMUNITIES- SHOULD. SHOULD BE
APPROACHING REMOVALS- FROM THE
HOME AND CHILD WELFARE
INTERVENTIONS AND EXPLORING OUR-
RECOMMENDATIONS IN OUR REPORT WE
ACTUALLY LOOK TO- WHAT IT
IMPLEMENTATION OF A QUOTE WITH
FIDELITY WOULD LOOK LIKE AND
WHAT TAKE AWAY IT'S- TIME COULD
BE INCORPORATED INTO- OUR STATE
AND COUNTY LEVEL CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEMS INCLUDING THINGS LIKE
TROUT TRIBAL CUSTOMARY ADOPTION
SO. AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
THAT WE ARE EXPLORING AS WELL
AND VERY SUPPORTIVE OF. I'M
THANK YOU CHAIR I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT IN FROM THE PREVENTION
PERSPECTIVE THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THE DATA ABOUT HOW-
FAMILIES IN NATIVE COMMUNITIES
WHETHER THEY'RE- WITHIN YOUR
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY OR IN.
INDIA'S TOGETHER ARE HAVING
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT AND ARE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE SUPPORT
THAT'S AVAILABLE AND WE ALSO
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE STAFF
WERE WORKING ON THESE PROGRAMS
ARE. TRAINED AND UNDERSTAND THE
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES AND OR
DIFFERENCES OR I'M COMMUNITIES
AND FROM THE NATIVE. COMMUNITY
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER FOLKS. ARE
REACHING OUT TO YOU SO I THINK
THAT IT'S ABOUT EDUCATION I
THINK IT'S ABOUT A MONITORING
AND MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE
FABRICATED DATA TO ENSURE THAT
OUR FOLKS ARE UTILIZING THAT
REPRESENTS THE PART THAT ARE
AVAILABLE- UNDER ALSO- FEDERAL
STRENGTH THE FUNDING
PARTICULARLY DIRECTED FOR OUR
NATIVE COMMUNITIES INCLUDING FOR
HOME VISITING. THEIR OTHER I'M
SOURCES THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE EVERYTHING. TO
THE MAX. DEGREE THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND SOME HEARTENING KNOW
THAT YOU REACHING TO THE TRI
COME. TO LEARN FIRST HAND OF.
WHAT ISSUE STILL- COULD BE
CONSIDERED- BARRIERS- TO ENSURE
THAT- NATIVE AMERICAN FOSTER
CARE KIDS- ARE. ALSO KEPT WITHIN
THE NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY-
CERTAINLY IT WAS CREATED TO
CREATE THE CULTURE- THE HERITAGE
VERY MUCH ALIVE EVEN THOUGH. THE
GOVERNMENT AT TIMES AND YOU
COULD SEE IT RESEARCH IT-
STRIPPED NATIVE AMERICANS OF
THAT CULTURE ITSELF. IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ME AND FOR OTHERS-
THAT ARE ENGAGED IN THIS TYPE OF
DISCUSSION ESPECIALLY WITH IT
QUOTE AND WHAT'S GOING AROUND ON
AROUND A QUOTE CURRENTLY WITH
THE SUPREME COURT IN SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT DECISIONS. SO I WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT AT LEAST
WERE CHIMING IN AND WE'RE WE'RE-
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE IN
THE AREAS TO ENSURE THAT THE
NUMBER ONE REASON NICHOLAS
CREATE IT WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT
CULTURE. REMAINS STRONG AND
THOSE THAT- THROUGH A
GOVERNMENTAL SYSTEM THE TRIED TO
SIMULATE- AND TAKE AWAY THAT
CULTURE THAT NOW. WHEN IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM THAT THEY'RE
NOW BEING LOOKED TO BE ENGAGE
WITH A NATIVE AMERICAN FAMILY.
AND WITHOUT- MOVING FORWARD ON
THOSE THOSE ISSUES AND- IN THOSE
TOPICS AND WE KNOW THAT IT QUA
AND CAL EQUIPMENT AND SOMETIMES
COUNTIES- HAVE TO BE. REMINDED
TO BE ENGAGED IN THAT PROCESS
OF. HAVING NATIVE AMERICAN
CHILDREN TO NATIVE AMERICAN
FAMILIES- IN IN THE IT
CHRYSOSTOM BUT- HOW DO YOU SEE-
AND THIS IS A QUESTION WE'RE
POSING MISTER. CHAIRMAN YOU
COULD FIGURE OUT- AND IMPOSE THE
QUESTIONS OF THOSE THAT COULD
BEST ANSWER. AND IT'S A GENERAL
QUESTION IS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
HOW ARE WE BEST TO PROTECT THE
CITIZENS IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. AND THAT IT IS GOING
TOWARDS THE NATIVE AMERICAN-
CHILDREN HERE IN THE STATE. ON
AT ALL DIFFERENT THAT CAN
CERTAIN TALK ABOUT THE STATE BUT
HOW DO WE ENCOURAGE THE COUNTY
TO THE ENGAGE WITH THAT
ESPECIALLY. AS WE SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON AROUND THE TOPIC OF
ECWA NOW. LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
DIRECTOR AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
POSSIBLE. SURE I WOULD SAY I
THINK YOU SOMEWHERE I THINK THAT
AT THE FIELD SPECIALISTS AT
POSITION THAT I REFERENCE IS ONE
OF THOSE WAYS WHERE WE ARE IT'S
THE IT'S THE CONNECTOR THE
BRIDGE BETWEEN THE COUNTY AND
THE TRIBES AS SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO EQUIP LIMITATION. AT
THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO-
BOTH HOLD TRAVEL ADVISORY AT
COMMITTEE MEETINGS ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS WITH TRIBES OF
WHICH THIS IS ONE OF THAT
PRIMARY TOPICS OF THE STANDING
AGENDA ITEM THAT WE DISCUSSED
BUT WE ALSO. ARE CONSIDERING
FORMAL CONSULTATION WITH TRIBES
ARE RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF EQUUS- BUT
THERE'S CERTAINLY A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT WE ARE
OBTAINING THROUGH THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND IN BETWEEN
THOSE AT MEETINGS AND
CONVERSATIONS AROUND ANY
CHALLENGES AND BARRIERS ARE
BEING EXPERIENCED IN
RELATIONSHIP TO IMPLEMENTATION
SO. THAT WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION I
PARTICIPATE ON THE TRAVEL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND CONTINUE
TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH COUNTIES I
IN THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CAPACITY. TO ENSURE
IMPLEMENTATION IS OCCURRING.
MISTER CHAIR A IN THROUGH THE
CHAIR OF ITS A- WE COULD SEE
SOME TYPE COMPARING DATA- MAYBE
THREE YEARS FIVE YEARS PRIOR. TO
WHERE WE'RE AT NOW TO SEE IF
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS IN THE
WAY THE APPROACH THAT'S TAKING
PLACE IS A TRULY HAVING. AN
IMPACT- WITHIN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND IF SO
GREAT WE'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IF NOT THEN MAYBE
THAT'S WHEN WE NEED TO- COME
BACK TOGETHER AND HAVE SOME MORE
DISCUSSIONS AND I BELIEVE IN
COLLUDING. AGAIN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY INTO SOME OF
THESE AREAS- WOULD BE BENEFICIAL
WE SEE THE NUMBERS THAT ARE HERE
WE SEE THEIR HIGH WE SEE THEIR
ALARMING. BUT THROUGH THE CHAIR
THE NUMBERS THREE YEARS AGO FIVE
YEARS AGO WITH A SIMILAR ARE TO
HAVE WE MADE AN IMPACT. I MISS
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN I CAN SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT- BECAUSE OF
THE POINT IT'S A IT'S A VERY
GOOD POINT BECAUSE SPECTACULAR
PLACE UP BUT HOW WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF THESE DISPARITY
INDUSTRIES THAT MAKE THE
COMPARISONS BETWEEN THESE GROUPS
AND THEY- IN SOME CASES SIMPLIFY
SOME OF THE UNDERLYING. TRENDS
THAT ARE GOING ON SO WITHOUT
TAKING ANY FOCUS AWAY FROM THE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THIS AREA
ABSOLUTELY WE NEED TO I WILL SAY
THAT THAT THE DRAPES IF WE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE UNDERLYING RATES
OF ENTRIES FOR EXAMPLE THEY HAVE
BEEN DECLINING IN OUR STATE. FOR
AMERICAN INDIAN CHILDREN AS WELL
AS FOR ALL THE CHILDREN AND SO
THE DECLINE OVER THAT TIME IS
GOING DOWN FOR ALL OF OUR ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT GROUPS SO THAT THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THEM- ARE
START WORK WILL RETAIN THEM EVEN
THOUGH WE MAY WE ARE MAKING SOME
PROGRESS IN TERMS OF OUR
INTEREST. RATES FOR THAT
PARTICULAR GROUP SO I COULD SAY
PARK- FIVE YEARS AGO THE RATE OF
REMOVAL OR AMERICAN INDIAN
CHILDREN WAS- ABOUT- ELEVEN PER
THOUSAND SENATE AND THEN NOW IT
STATES THAT EIGHT POINT SO I
THINK IT'S OVER EIGHT SO IT'S
STILL. VERY HIGH COMPARED TO THE
OVERALL RATE FOR OUR STATE BUT
IT HAS BEEN BEEN COMING DOWN SO
AND WHEN YOU COMPARE THE
AMERICAN INDIAN RIGHT. TO THE
TOP FLIGHT- INTEREST ENTRY RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE STILL THAT THAT
DISPARITY STILL THIS PERCEPTION
WE DEFINITELY NEED TO WORK ON IT
BUT I BUT SPEECH YOUR POINT
ABOUT ARE WE MAKING PROGRESS IT
DOES APPEAR FROM THE DATA. IS
THAT WE ARE MOVING IN A GOOD
DIRECTION I WILL SAY TO ECHO
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES POINTS WE
NEED BETTER DATA TO EXAMINE
THOSE AREAS THOSE INTERVENTIONS
THE MORE GRANULAR LEVEL TO SEE
WHERE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THE
BARRIERS ARE THAT WE CAN
OVERCOME AND FIND OUT WHICH
PROGRAMS MAY BE HAVING. A BETTER
A FACT THAT WE CAN ONLY DO THAT
BY FOCUSING IN ON SPECIFIC
INTERVENTIONS AND SPECIFIC
TARGET POPULATIONS TO HELP
EVALUATE THE SUCCESS. OF THOSE
TO DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. THANK
THANK YOU MISS CHAIRMAN YOU.
VERY EXPLAINED IT AND- LOOKING
FORWARD TO MORE DATA SO WE COULD
I'M TYING WAS ANOTHER SPEAKER. I
WANTED TO KNOW ONE OTHER THING
THAT WAS INCLUDED. IN OUR- IN
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THIS YEAR
WHICH WAS FUNDING TO SUPPORT OUR
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES- IN
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO COUNTY USE THAT DEVELOPMENT
AT TRIBAL CONSULTATION POLICIES
WHAT THEY COUNTIES- ARE COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES AND
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS. DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE THE TRIBAL
CONSULTATION POLICIES IN PLACE
AND WE HAVE THEM AT THE STATE
LEVEL BUT TO YOUR POINT IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE OUGHT TO HAVE
THOSE CONSULTATION POLICIES. IN
PLACE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
THAT'LL WE HAVE THE INTERAGENCY-
COMMITTEE IS SET AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THAT ARE WORKING TO
DEVELOP THE PROTOCOLS TO ADDRESS
THE BARRIERS- ACROSS THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM OF CARE THAT THAT'S
INCLUSIVE OF TRIBAL
CONSULTATION. ON A SOUTHERN
SPENDING- PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR TO ALLOW TRIED. TO
FUND THE TRIED TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT TO COUNTY. DEVELOPING
THEIR POLICY. THANK YOU FOR FROM
UP THE IN. TOPIC WE'RE TO AT
THIS LEVEL BUT IT'S AT THE
COUNTY LEVELS ALSO WE HAVE TO
ENCOURAGE- COMPLIANCE AND
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING- WITH THE
LOCAL TRIBES SO THAT WE CAN.
START TO HAVE AN IMPACT CHIU
IMPACT ON ON- THE NATIVE
AMERICAN- CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AND ALCOA INDIAN-
CHILD WELFARE ACT AND CAL ITS
WORK HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WE'RE WATCHING
THAT MONITORING IT AND I THINK
NOW MORE THAN EVER. WE NEED TO
BE MORE- AWARE OF IT BECAUSE OF
THE DIFFERENT COURT- CASES THAT
ARE GOING ON WITH IT. I THANK
YOU FOR THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO LISTEN TO
LEARN TO HEAR FROM HISTORY AND
TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS GOING
FORWARD. APPRECIATE YOUR INPUTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND BELIEVE
THAT. IT WILL ALLOW OUR STATE TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE ADDRESSING THIS
DISPARITY HEAD ON AS WELL. WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT. WANT TO
SEE IF ANY OTHER ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS. SEE NON-
BRING IT TO THE CHAIR I FIRST
WANTED TO START WITH- DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AND MISS SHORTS IF I
COULD I REALLY WANNA APPRECIATE
THE OFFICE OF EQUITY. AND I'M
ALWAYS REMINDED THAT EQUITY IS
BUILT INTO THE LAST MILE OF
IMPLEMENTATION. BUT I WANTED TO
HEAR A LITTLE MORE ABOUT YOUR
CORE PRACTICE MODEL. CAN YOU
HELP TO SHARE SOME OF THE
EFFORTS. THAT HAVE BEEN FOSTERED
BY THE STATE'S TO CONFRONT AND
REDUCE IMPLICIT BIAS. THAT WE
HAVE WITHIN CHILD WELFARE AND
HOW CAN WE AS A STATE HAVE
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA. VERY
MUCH CHAIR FOR THE QUESTION NOT
ALL TURNED OVER TO DEPUTY
DIRECTOR SPORTS IN JUST A MOMENT
I WILL JUST TELL YOU THAT-
OFFICE OF EQUITY PART OF THAT
CREATION OF THAT WAS BORN OUT OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S PARTICIPATION
IN THE GOVERNMENT ALLIANCE FOR
RACIAL EQUITY INITIATIVE OUR
GEAR. I WHICH WE WERE ONE OF
TWELVE OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS
AS PART OF A COHORT GOING
THROUGH SOME EXACTLY THOSE AT
HISTORICAL. AT COMPONENTS OF OUR
SYSTEMS AND HOW THEY CAME TO BE
AGAIN ONE OF KNOWLEDGE TO WORK-
AT THE ALLIANCE HAS DONE I THE
REPORT THAT SPEAKS TO FROM ABOUT
HISTORY HERE AS IT RELATES TO
CHILD WELFARE- IT REALLY THAT
WORKS TO CREATE- IF YOU WILL THE
TRAINING OF TRAINER MODEL
AMBASSADORS AT THAT CAN COME
BACK. AND HAVE COME BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO BUILD AGAIN OUR
COMPETENCY ON WHAT IT MEANS TO
LEAD WITH RACE EQUITY WHAT IT
MEANS TO LOOK AT OUR- POLICIES
THROUGH A LENS WITH ALL KINDS OF
TOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN DENTAL
DEVELOPED IN THAT SPACE. BUT I
WILL SAY AS IT RELATES TO YOUR
SPECIFIC QUESTION IN CHILD
WELFARE AND AGAIN THAT THE
STAFF. THAT WE ARE ONE AND I WAS
GONNA OF BODY OF WORK IN IN A
LOT OF WORK THAT HAVE
POTENTIALLY. AT ABSOLUTELY MIGHT
ALSO SPEAK TO THAT FROM THE
COUNTY'S PERSPECTIVE THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT PROVIDING
THAT KIND OF TRAINING AND
SUPPORT WITHIN. OUT STATE CHILD
WELFARE WORK FORCE AFTER
SOMETIME NOW I PUT THE COUNTY
LEVEL AND AGAIN AT THE STATE
LEVEL. ENSURING THAT OUT THERE
PROCESS SEES AND THEIR- STAFF
UNDERSTAND HOW BIAS IMPACTS THE
DECISIONS IN CRITICAL LIFE
CHANGING DECISIONS THEY'RE
MAKING EACH AND EVERY DAY. AND
SO THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER AS-
TRAINING COMPONENTS OF THE GOOD
PART AS- THAT WORK THAT CONTINUE
ON- BUT I THINK AGAIN A LOT OF
THE LATEST CONVERSATION OF
LITERATURE ABOUT AND HOW WE ARE
THINKING. ABOUT A POLICY THROUGH
THIS LENS IS REALLY WHAT WE'RE
FOCUSED ON AND AGAIN A LOT OF
THE EFFORTS INITIATIVES THAT I
MENTIONED IN THAT. BUT SHORTS
MENTIONED ARE IN RELATIONSHIP
AND ACTUALLY DIRECT RESULTS.
ESTIMATE BACK AT TRAINING IN
DIALOGUE BUT- ACTIVITIES RECORDS
WHAT'S MAKING US SHE. ADDED
RELATED TO THE QUESTION. WHAT
YOU'RE- JOHN SAID BEING. CORE
COULD MODEL IS KEY AND WE ARE IN
A- IT. CORRAL OUR WORK IN TURN
THAT HOW WE CAN YOU TELL THEM
FAMILY TEAM. IN ENGAGEMENT OF
CARE PARTNER NETWORKS AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE REGULAR AND ON
GOING. ENGAGEMENT WHETHER YOUR
PARTNER WE DEVELOP EXPENSIVE
TOOLS AND RESOURCES THAT WE CAN
POINT YOU TO JAIL. ON THE
INTEGRATED CORE PRACTICE MODEL
REPORT PAGE WE HAVE A TRAINING
GUIDE- IT AND ARE YOU THINK THAT
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OF OUR SERVICES. ARE REALLY
DRIVEN REAL COLLABORATION- AND
COORDINATION WITH THE ACTUAL
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES WHO
ARE- THE RECIPIENTS OF THE-
SERVICES AND THE COURTS TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THEY ARE EFFECTIVE.
AS POSSIBLE. I'M GONNA NOW TO
THE OF THIRTY WITH THE- WHERE-
SOME PRACTITIONERS AND ADVOCATES
HAVE EMBRACED KINSHIP CARE. FOR
US AS A WAY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE RACIAL DISPROPORTION HOURLY
THAT WE SEE WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
AND YET THE AGENDA STATES THAT
THIS RESULTS IN A PHENOMENAL
PHENOMENON KNOWN AS HIDDEN
FOSTER CARE. THAT I'D LIKE TO
GET AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
COMMON. THIS IS HAPPENING AS I
BELIEVE IT DEPRIVES US OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THE OTHER
RESOURCES AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES THAT ARE SO PIVOTAL. OF
A TOLL AS WE HEARD POVERTY IS A
CRITICAL FACTOR IN THIS AREA AND
FOR ABLE TO INCREASE RESOURCES
WERE BETTER ABLE TO SUPPORT
THOSE YOUNG FAMILIES I'D LIKE TO
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
COMMON OF A PRACTICE THIS IS. I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE DATA
TO ACTUALLY INFORM HOW COMMON OF
A PRACTICE IT IS I KNOW THERE
WAS AN EXTENSIVE- REPORT DONE BY
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS BASED ON FOCUS GROUPS AND
SURVEYS THAT AT LEAST GAINS
THAT. THE MARKET ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE- PREVALENCE OF THE
PRACTICE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND THERE WAS A BILL THAT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR AB TWO SIXTY-
IN ORDER TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS. COORDINATION
BETWEEN OUR PROBATE AND OUR
DEPENDENCY COURT- AND WE ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF. GETTING THAT ALL
CAN YOU LETTER RELATED TO THAT-
YOU ARE OUT NOW SO THAT
HOPEFULLY FAMILIES. ARE
CONNECTED TO THE RIGHT THE
SPENDING REPEAT THAT THE COURT
PERFECT SENSE THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO. RE UNIFY IN ORDER TO
AVOID ENTRY INTO FOSTER CARE IN
THE FIRST INSTANCE HELLO WE ARE
FOR TWENTY INTERESTED IN
EXPLORING. THE TOPIC- IN GREATER
DETAIL AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS THAT WE CAN GET AT THAT. I
BOTH NUMBERS THAT YOU'RE
SPEAKING BUT I BUT WE DON'T HAVE
DATA THAT REALLY TRACKS THAT THE
PROBLEMS THAT. THE PRACTICE-
EARLIER WE HEARD WERE HAVING
DECREASING NUMBERS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN OUR CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES SYSTEM AND-
WONDER. HOW MANY OF THEM MAY BE
SHOWING UP IN THIS HIDDEN FOSTER
CARE THAT WE HAVE IN BELIEVE
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO-
UNDERSTAND THAT SCOPE AND SO
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. UP WANT TO FOLLOW
UP NOW WITH DOCTOR WEBSTER AS
WELL AS THE ADMINISTRATION TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXPERIENCE OF ARE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION IN. THIS
SYSTEM EXPLICITLY. AND HOW
DISPARITIES LOOK FOR THIS
POPULATION WITHIN CHILD WELFARE. SERVICES DO WE HAVE THAT
INFORMATION- THIS IS DANIEL
WEBSTER TO KNOWLEDGE WE DON'T
HAVE A GOOD READ ON THAT- I
DON'T KNOW THE DEGREE TO WHICH
IT'S CAPTURED IN OUR DATA SYSTEM
WITH ANY KIND OF. RELIABILITY
AND IT CERTAINLY HASN'T BEEN
SOMETHING THAT THAT MY TEAM HAS.
LOOK AT SPECIFICALLY CELL WOULD
HAVE TO YOU KNOW I TOOK TOOK
TOOK CIRCLE BACK ON THAT ONE
ACROSS MY COLLEAGUES. AT THE
STATE AND WE HAVE DONE SOME
PRELIMINARY LOOKS BUT FROM MY-
UNDERSTANDING THE SYSTEM IT'S
OUR- I DON'T KNOW HOW WELL WE'RE
TRACKING AT THIS POINT. I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
IF THEY HAVE A RESPONSIBLE. I
WOULD AGREE WITH MR WEBSTER I
THE ONLY THING I WOULD SAY WOULD
YOU BE A SUBSET OF THE
POPULATION TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION IS WE DO- AT AT
ANDERSTON AND ACCOMPANIED AND
DOCUMENTED MINOR SPECIFICALLY AT
THE SPECIFIC PROGRAM YOU YOU
HAVE. A PROGRAM THAT WE TOGETHER
WITH AT THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
UNVESTED LEGAL SERVICES AND- IN
TERMS OF A PATHWAY- THE OTHER
KIND OF WITH A PARITY PROGRAM
BUT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY AND
DOCUMENTS AND ACCOUNT IT'S
EXCUSE ME IT'S THE- AT. REFUGEE
MINORS PROGRAM AND ADULTS AGAIN
ARE AT YOU THROUGH HAVE REFUGEE
STATUS SO THEY WOULDN'T CUT KIND
OF FOLLOW THEM I THINK THE
BROADER QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
ASKING- BUT AGAIN AT- GOOD GRIEF
MISTER WEBSTER THAT IT'S A PLACE
THAT WE WOULD NEED TO HAVE. MORE
DATA TO BE MORE SPECIFIC TO YOUR
TO YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTION- I
WILL THEN DRAWS- FOR MY NEXT
QUESTION TO THE L. A. O.'S GRAPH
ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE FOURTEEN.
WHICH IDENTIFIES THAT- OFTEN TO
MANY OF OUR FOR. WHO AN X.
FAMILY. ARE WITH DIMINISHED
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS MANY OF
THE- POVERTY CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE THAT I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND-
THE NUMBER OF UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN WHO WE HAVE IN OUR
SYSTEM TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS. TO CAL WORKS
BASED ON THE GRAPH THAT WE HAVE
FROM THE L. A. L. Y. I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS
FINANCE AND L. A- SOME OF THEIR
THOUGHTS AND POTENTIAL COSTS
THAT WOULD COME WITH US
INCREASING GRANTS FOR FAMILIES
WHO DO HAVE AN EXCLUDED FAMILY
MEMBER. AND I'M HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH MORE DETAILS BUT WANTED
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN CAL WORKS AND
THOSE WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
WITHIN OUR CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES SYSTEM. HOPING TO GET
UP. AT LEAST INITIAL THOUGHTS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS. I'LL I'LL ED DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IF HE WANTS TO ADD
ANYTHING MORE SPECIFICALLY HERE
BUT YES I THINK AGAIN WE HAVE A
WITH YOU AND MAKE THE COMMITMENT
TO RAISE THAT THE GRANT LEVELS
OVER TIME AND NOTING THAT THERE
I WE STILL HAVEN'T ACHIEVED AT
SOME OF THE- THRESHOLD IN WHICH
LEGISLATURES ASSET OUT FOR GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES- SO I IN TERMS OF
GETTING COST ESTIMATES THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS. ADDED GLAD TO
WORK WITH YOU TO FORGET MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE PROPERTY
FINANCE IF YOU. SEE JUSTIN. OF
FINANCE THINK. I THINK SOME THAN
EVER- AND- HAS BEEN PROVIDED
FROM THE DEPARTMENT REGARDING
THOSE GROUND LEVELS AND- JUST
RECOMMEND IT'S I BELIEVE IT'S IN
THE FOOTNOTES AS WELL ON NINE-
CHART THAT. YEAH GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROJECT SEVEN POINT 1%
GRANT INCREASE PER COW WORKS AND
WE WILL BE RE- RE EVALUATING
THAT AGAIN HERE THEY MAY
REVISION PROCESS AS IT'S BASED
OFF OF REVENUE PROJECTIONS FOR.
THE CHILD POVERTY AND FAMILY SUB
ACCOUNTS SO- IT'S- DIED THE
GREAT INCREASE JUST NOTING FOR
EVERYONE IS DEPENDENT UPON WHAT
THE REVENUES ARE COMING IN AT AS
WELL AS CASELOAD. ASSUMPTIONS
FOR THE COW WORKS PROGRAM. I
JUST FEEL OBLIGED TO REMIND US
THAT- WE BASED THE AMOUNTS THAT
WE GIVE BASED ON THE A. U. AND
THE NUMBER OF FAMILY MEMBERS
THEY HAPPENED WHEN WE DON'T
COUNT CERTAIN FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
STILL LIVE IN THE HOUSE SINCE
THE ONLY DEFEAT. WE ARE
DIMINISHING THE OVERALL
RESOURCES THAT THE REST OF THE
FAMILY IS ABLE TO. RECEIVE AND
THUS ARE EXACERBATING MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE HEARD
TODAY I'D LIKE TO NOW MOVE TO
SABRINA FORTE IF I COULD- WITHIN
THE- PATH TO RACIAL EQUITY
REPORT I REALLY APPRECIATED THE
QUICK SYNOPSIS THAT YOU GAVE
FOR. PREVENTION EXPANDING- FIRST
TALL KIDS THE LEGAL REP BEFORE-
AS WELL AS BUILDING UP THE
FAMILY NETWORK THAT I WANTED TO
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO STATE WHAT
ARE SOME OF THOSE KEY PRIORITIES
SPECIFICALLY. THAT THE STATE CAN
DO IN THE NEAR TERM TO BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT MUCH OF WHAT YOU
BROUGHT FROM YOUR REPORT. AS AS
MUCH SHORTS INDICATED EARLIER
THE STATE HAS ALREADY MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS OVER AND I'M
JUST THE PAST YEAR AND-
IMPLEMENTING IN S. B. ARE
BEGINNING TO IMPLEMENT SB THREE
FIFTY FOUR TO ADDRESS RELATIVES
WITH CONVICTION HISTORIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED- I
WANT TO BUILD ON THAT- PROGRESS
AND SAY THAT ONE THING- ONE AREA
FOR EARLY- AND- SHORT TERM
ACTION IS REALLY THINKING ABOUT
THE WAY. ON THAT ARE COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR DEFINE- EMILY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
OUR TRIBAL PARTNERS- FROM OUR
PARTNERS AND IN THE BLACK AND
LATINO X. COMMUNITY IS AND THINK
ABOUT HOW TO SUPPORT THE FAMILY
NETWORK REALLY BROADLY- NOT
WITHSTANDING THE LONG STANDING
IN. RULES AND REGULATIONS
RELATED TO YOU KNOW THE CHILD
AFFAIRS PERCEPTION OF WHAT AN
APPROPRIATE HOME IS- SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR- REVIEW SB THREE FIFTY FOUR
IMPLEMENTATION TAKE SOME DATA-
PER PER THE LANGUAGE AT THE
BELL- AND THEN. RETURN NEXT
YEAR- BUT WITH SOME REFLECTIONS
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO CLOSE GAPS-
THERE ALSO CONTINUES TO BE IN A
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM- EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY
POPULATION OF THE FIRST PROGRAM.
AS YOU NOTED- AND ALSO CONTINUE
CLOSING THOSE GAPS WHERE
RELATIVES ARE STILL NOT
RECEIVING IN THE SAME FUNDING
AND RESOURCES AS NON RELATIVES-
THAT'S VERY EVIDENT FOR YOU KNOW
RELATIVES AND HAD IMPOSTER CARE
AND IMMEDIATE STEP THERE IS TO
COLLECT AS MUCH DATA AS POSSIBLE
TO FIGURE OUT. HOW MANY CHILDREN
ARE LIVING AND THE IS- SETTINGS
THAT THAT ARE NOT WITHIN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND DON'T
HAVE- SUPPORT. AND SERVICES- AND
- I'LL I'LL STOP THERE- AND IT'S
SORRY THE LAST THING I'LL SAY
AND IN TERMS OF RELATIVE PARITY
IS MAKING SURE THAT THEY CAN GET
PROGRAM ALSO COVERS ALL RELATIVE
CARE GIVERS WHO EXITS A
GUARDIANSHIP THROUGH THE
JUVENILE COURT- IT'S ONE OF OUR
ONLY REMAINING GAPS AFTER ABOUT
A DECADE- OF EXCELLENT PROGRESS-
AND WILL LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN I'M BEING
PLACED IN KINSHIP CARE AND
EXITING FOSTER CARE TO RELATIVE
CARE AND HAVE BEEN THAT THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED- TO
THRIVE AFTER THEY LEAVE THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM- FOR STACEY
LEE I'M GOING TO ASK YOU THE%
SAME QUESTION. WHAT IS A
CONCRETE STEP THAT YOU CAN
ADVISE THE STATE TO TAKE TO
CONFRONT AND REDUCE RACIAL
DISPARITIES WITHIN CHILD WELFARE
AND I WILL- UP LIFT YOUR COMMENT
ABOUT NOT INVESTING ENOUGH- INTO
OUR HOME VISITING MODELS HAVING
BEEN SOMEONE WHO FOUGHT SO HARD
TO MAKE SURE WE WERE EXTENDING
THAT SERVICE- BUT WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR ANY OTHER CONCRETE STEPS
THAT YOU HAVE. SURE ABSOLUTELY-
AND AGAIN YET WE DEFINITELY
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP ROLE YOU PLAYED IN
HELPING CALIFORNIA'S X. ART
CREATE THE FIRST STATEWIDE
INVESTMENT. IN HOME VISITING WE
ARE VERY PROUD OF THAT-
INITIATIVE AND I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT HAS DONE A WONDERFUL
JOB- INITIATING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT PROGRAM.
WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES WITH
EIGHT IN ADDITION TO MY COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC SLOWING DOWN
THE- EXPANSION AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT EFFORT.
IS THAT- HOME VISITING IN ORDER
TO BE EFFECTIVE REQUIRES THAT
THOSE IN THE FIELD ARE CONNECTED
TO ALL OF THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORT AND I UNDERSTAND WHERE
THEY CAN REFER FAMILIES CHOOSE
THAT THEY NEED TO BE EMBEDDED IN
WELL THAT WORKED. AND THERE HAS
TO BE LOCAL THE STUDENTS FOR
THOSE I'M HOPING THAT ARE HAVE%
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR COUNTY
AGENCY PARTNERS WITH OTHER CEOS
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS. SO WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXPAND LOCAL ON AN
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT THERE ARE
ALREADY CONVERSATIONS THE
EFFORTS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
STATE L.A. COUNTY HOUSE- A
STELLAR MODEL IN TERMS OF THEIR
HOME VISITING CONSORTIUM WERE
ALL PROVIDERS. ARE CONNECTED-
AND COLLABORATE ON REFERRALS-
THEY- SUPPORT EACH OTHER IN
TERMS OF IDENTIFYING RESOURCES
AND OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE COUNTIES HOW. THOSE
KINDS OF INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RELATIONSHIPS EXPANDED- ACROSS
THE STATE SO THEY CAN MAXIMIZE
SMALL AMOUNT OF RESEARCH THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FOR HOME VISITING
AND OBVIOUSLY OF COURSE I THINK
EXPANDING. OUR INVESTMENT IN
HOME VISITING WOULD BE A GREAT.
STAFF THAT ALSO REQUIRES THAT WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE NATIONAL
MODEL PROGRAMS THAT THEY CAN.
MEET US WHERE WE ARE BECAUSE IN
CALIFORNIA EXPANDS OUR
INVESTMENT BY A FEW PERCENTAGE.
IT KIND OF OVERTAKES THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE
COMPARED TO OTHER PLACES SO IF
WE NEED TO TRAIN A COUPLE
HUNDRED OR THOUSAND. NEW HOME
VISITORS. YOU KNOW THAT CAN-
MAXIMIZE THEIR CREDIT TO PASS
YOU WORKING WITH THEM ON HIS
PLANS EXPANSION- AND THEN.
COLLECTING THAT DATA ABOUT WHAT
WORKING HOW CAN BE MORE. IN
MAKING THAT WE- TRULY REACHING
ALL OF THE CAN. WHO CHEN BE HAVE
A ACCESS INVOLVING AND ARE
SUPPORTED WELL BY THOSE PROGRAMS
IN MAKING WE MAKE IT. AT THANK
YOU FOR THAT. FINE QUESTION FOR
DIRECTOR JOHN IS GOING TO BE ON.
THE LINKAGES TO POINT- THAT YOU
MENTIONED- YOU STATED THAT
THERE'S A NEW EMPHASIS ON
PREVENTION AND HOPING YOU COULD
GO INTO A LITTLE MORE DETAIL. ON
WHERE THIS WILL BE GOING. SURE
GLAD TO CHAIR AT BEGIN THE
PROGRAM IN PROJECT ORIGINALLY
STARTED OUT OF THE IDEA THAT
THERE WERE CONFLICTING. ASK
FEDERAL POLICIES AT BETWEEN THE
CHILD WELFARE AND ATTENDANCE
SYSTEM ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
WAS REALLY WE WERE RECOGNIZING
ON THE GROUND WITH THAT
TRANSLATED TO WAS THAT WE COULD
BE ASKING THE SAME FAMILY. AT TO
COMPLY WITH ONE PROGRAM THAT
MIGHT RESULT IN NON COMPLIANCE
OF THE OTHER NOT SIMPLY I WASN'T
ACCEPTABLE SO THEY REMEMBER AS
AB POLICY COMPONENTS IN WAYS IN
WHICH WE AT AT. IT YOU'RE A
DRESS THOSE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED. AGAIN AS I MENTIONED
OVER TIME THAT THE FUNDING FOR
THIS PARTICULAR INITIATIVE HAS
VARIED SIGNIFICANTLY AND SO WE
HAD SOME COUNTIES OVER THE
COURSE OF THE HISTORY OF THE
PROJECT. CONTINUES TO WORK I'M
LOOKING AT THOSE AT CONNECTIONS
ACROSS- BUT BY AND LARGE AND WE
HAVE KIND OF READ. IT WITH THIS
AT THE LAUNCH AT THE SPRING THE-IDEA THAT WE REALLY LOOK AT THE
PREVENTATIVE ASPECTS- I BOTH
BOTH SIDES OF THE HOUSE IF YOU
WILL TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO. AT
TO BRING THEM TOGETHER THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
LOOKING AT. WHAT'S INTERNAL TO
THE DEPARTMENT HOW ARE ALL OF
THE- EFFORTS INTERVENTIONS AND-
CONNECTIONS THAT WE ARE HAPPY
THAT ARE HAPPENING- DIRECTOR
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND
ESPECIALLY AS THERE AS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED. AT TO
ADDRESS ANY ANY PROPERTY EXPERT
RECKONS ARE EXPERIENCING HOW IS
THAT CONNECTING- VERY
SPECIFICALLY INTUITIVE EXAMPLE
THAT WAS GIVEN AROUND VOLUNTARY-
STRAIGHT FACE SOME VISITING
APPROACHES HOW ARE WE GETTING
AHEAD OF THE FRONT SO. THE IDEA
IS TO CREATE THE SPACE AND SET
THE TABLE FOR THE. COUNTY IN THE
STATE TO COME TO GET. SEE WHAT
ELSE WE CAN BE JUNE. AS IT
RELATES TO PRIMARY SECOND
TERTIARY PREVENT- IN IN
ADDITIONAL THAT WOULD OUT OF
THAT OBVIOUSLY. AT AT DIRECTOR
SPORTS MENTIONED AT COUNTIES ARE
RIGHT NOW IN GAUGING IN THE
FAMILY'S FIRST APPREHENSION. AT
PLANNING PROCESSES AS WELL AS
THE STATE AS IT WORKS TO GET ITS
PLAN FINALIZED SO A LOT MORE TO
COME THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE BOTH ON THIS
LINK IT JUST EFFORT BUT ALSO.
AFTER THAT PREVENTION PLANNING
EFFORT NFF PSA. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND BEFORE WE GO ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM I WANT TO THANK THIS
ENTIRE PANEL FOR HELPING US TO
SET THE STAGE AS WE- SPEAK IN
MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE CURRENT
STATE EFFORTS. TO IMPROVE OUR
FAMILY BASED CHILD PROTECTION
SYSTEMS AND PREVENTION EFFORTS
GEARED TOWARDS HELPING US TO
REDUCE DISPARITIES IN CHILD
WELFARE. I'D LIKE TO FORMALLY
REQUEST PARTICIPATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. AGENCY CHILD
WELFARE POLICY COUNSEL. AT THE
UPCOMING APRIL SIXTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO HEARING. PARTICIPANTS
WILL BE ASKED TO DISCUSS THE CAL
WORKS CAL OR- THAT IS THE
OUTCOMES AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REVIEW POLICY ASSIGNMENT REPORT.
AND TO ADDRESS THE INTERSECTION
OF CAL WORKS AND CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES IN THE CONTEXT OF
DISPARITY REDUCTION. TO IMPROVE
THE OUTCOMES FOR OUR LOW INCOME
DISADVANTAGED CHILDREN OF COLOR
IN CALIFORNIA. PERSOON PURSUANT
TO THE RECOMMENDATION A ONE OF
THE PATH TO RACIAL EQUITY AND
CHILD WELFARE REPORT. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER THE
FINAL RECOMMENDATION OFFERED IN
THE PATH TO EQUITY IN CHILD
WELFARE REPORT. WHICH ASKED FOR
FIRST THE INSTITUTIONALIZATION
OF ANTI RACIST TRAININGS WITHIN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. SECT
AN OUTLINE OF SPECIFIC TARGETS
FOR REDUCING RACIAL
DISPROPORTION OUR LADY AND
DISPARITIES. AND THIRD FOR THE
RELEASE OF AN ANNUAL REPORT
ANALYZING PROGRESS ON THIS
AGENDA. IF THE ADMINISTRATION
COMPLETION OUR THOUGHTS AND
INFORMATION ON THE ASSOCIATED
COSTS FOR THESE FORMATIVE STEPS
TO REDUCE DISPARITIES THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT FEEDBACK BY APRIL FIRST.
AND I'D LIKE TO ADDITIONALLY ASK
FOR ASSISTANCE FROM THE L. A. O.
WITH FACILITATING THIS REQUEST
AND AIDING US TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MAY ARISE.
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT BACK TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE BY APRIL SIXTH
ON THE PROPORTION OF OUR
IMMIGRANT YOUTH POPULATION IN
FOSTER CARE. SEPARATE AND APART
FROM RACIAL DISPARITIES. THANK
YOU AND WITH THAT WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND PANEL. WE
WILL HAVE SIX PRESENTERS ON THE
PANEL FOR ISSUE TWO WE WILL
BEGIN WITH CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
JENNIFER TROIA WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
FOLLOWED BY ANGIE SWARTS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR CDSS. THEN
WE WILL HAVE JUSTIN FRAYED US
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANGELES SHORT WITH THE L. A. L.
KATHY SANDERLING MCDONALD'S WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND CHRIS STONER
MARKS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. LET'S BEGIN WITH IT
JENNIFER TROYER OF DSS WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU CHAIR
ARAMBULA AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IT IS
AN HONOR TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
MOST CRITICAL ISSUES FACING OUR
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. F. THE
PANDEMIC IN AN INCREASE IN
NATURAL DISASTERS HAS CHALLENGED
OUR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR. CDSS AND OUR
PARTNERS HAVE BEEN TASKED WITH
RESPONDING TO MANY URGENT NEEDS.
WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING OUR ENERGY
AND ATTENTION URGENTLY ON THOSE
RESPONSES WHILE ALSO CONTINUING
TO IMPLEMENT VERY CRITICAL
CHANGES. UNDER THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM. AND AS WE'LL
DISCUSS LATER. MAJOR NEW FEDERAL
LAW. WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ALLOWED ALL OF
THIS WORK TO MOVE FORWARD
SIMULTANEOUSLY. IT. EXCUSE ME
FOR MY TEAMS AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO THE COUNTIES AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS ON THE GROUND TO THE
ADVOCATES WHO RAISE CRITICAL
CONCERNS TO OUR ATTENTION
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND OF COURSE OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATURE
WE BELIEVE THAT WE ARE AT OUR
BEST WHEN WE ARE COLLABORATING
TOGETHER TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
ALL OF THESE ARENAS. AS WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM OR C. C. R. OUR
VISION HAS ALWAYS BEEN AT ITS
HEART ABOUT EQUITY. DIVISION IS
TO RECOGNIZE THAT EVERY CHILD
SERVED BY THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
NEEDS. DESSERTS AND HAS THE
ABILITY TO BE PART OF A LOVING
FAMILY. TOWARD THAT VISION MANY
OF THE REFORMS CONNECTED TO C.
C. R. HAVE HELPED TO ENSURE THAT
MORE CHILDREN ARE CONNECTED AND
SUPPORTED INFAMILY SETTINGS
IDEALLY AND MOST OFTEN THEIR OWN
FAMILY AND EXTENDED FAMILY.
POLICY CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN
CENTRAL TO C. C. R. HAVE
INCLUDED. A BROAD EXPANSION IN
THE USE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMING. CREATION OF AN
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER PROGRAM
WHICH ALLOWS YOU TO BE
IMMEDIATELY PLACED WITH
RELATIVES OR FAMILY MEMBERS.
ESTABLISHING GREAT EQUITY FOR
CHILDREN PLACED IN RELATIVES
HOMES. ESTABLISHING A NEW HOME
BASED FAMILY CARE RATE STRUCTURE
WHICH IS GIANT TIED TO THE
CHILD'S ASSESSED LEVEL OF NEEDS.
EXPANDING THE INTENSIVE SERVICES
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM SUPPORTING
INNOVATIONS AND FAMILY FINDING
AND RESOURCE PARENT RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION. AND NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONGREGATE CARE
PROVIDERS AIMED AT ENSURING THAT
FACILITIES ARE PROVIDING HIGH
QUALITY THERAPEUTIC SUPPORTS TO
MEET INDIVIDUAL NEEDS. THE
DEPARTMENT RECENTLY RELEASED AN
ISSUE BRIEF WHICH HIGHLIGHTS
SOME OF THE SUCCESSES OF CCAR
AND THESE POLICIES TO DATE AND
ALSO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE WORK
THAT REMAINS TO BE DONE IN
PARTNERSHIP. SOME OF THOSE
SUCCESSES INCLUDE THAT YOUTH
PLACEMENT INTO CONGREGATE CARE
SETTINGS HAS DECREASED BY MORE
THAN SIXTY PERCENT. WELL
PLACEMENT INTO HOME BASED
SETTINGS HAS INCREASED. OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS IN FACT THERE
HAS BEEN A 53% INCREASE IN YOUTH
WHO HAVE HAD THEIR FIRST
PLACEMENT WITH A RELATIVE OR
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBER AND A 92%
INCREASE IN YOUTH WHOSE
PREDOMINANT PLACEMENT IS WITH A
RELATIVE OR EXTENDED IN.
PLACEMENT STABILITY INDICATORS
FOR CHILDREN REMAINING IN THEIR
FIRST PLACEMENT HAVE ALSO
CONTINUED TO GROW SO 75% OF
YOUTH WHO HAVE THEIR FIRST
PLACEMENT WITH A RELATIVE AND
ARE STILL IN CARE TWELVE MONTHS
LATER. ARE STILL WITH THAT RIGHT
. THE NUMBER OF RESOURCE FAMILY
HOMES APPROVED EACH QUARTER HAS
ALSO STEADILY INCREASED. MORE
THAN 87% OF YOUTH IN SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
ARE RECEIVING CRITICAL MENTAL
HEALTH AND THERAPEUTIC SERVICES.
NOT SURPRISINGLY THERE'S ALSO
BEEN A NOT INCREASE AND THE
NUMBER OF FACILITIES WITH
INTEGRATED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IN TERMS OF
STRENGTHENING THESE EFFORTS WE
MUST CONTINUE TO UTILIZE FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORTS THAT ARE
INDIVIDUALIZED TO THE CHILD
WHENEVER POSSIBLE. IT'S ALSO
CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER WITH OUR PARTNERS
TO IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS GAPS IN
OUR SYSTEMS OF CARE. OUR WORK ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHTY THREE WHICH
MISSED FOURTH WILL SPEAK MORE
ABOUT IS CENTERED AROUND THESE
EFFORTS. WE ALSO NEED TO REDUCE
THE LENGTH OF STAY AND S. T. R.
T. P. IS THAT TOO MANY OF OUR
YOUTH AND PARTICULARLY OUR BLACK
YOUTH ARE STILL EXPERIENCING.
AND FINALLY AS WE WILL DISCUSS
MORE LATER WE ARE SUPPORTING AND
WORKING TOGETHER WITH COUNTY
SOME PROVIDERS TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF YOUTH WITH COMPLEX CARE
NEEDS. OUR GOALS INCLUDE
STRENGTHENING PROACTIVE
APPROACHES TO IDENTIFYING AND
MEETING YOU NEEDS ACROSS THE
SYSTEMS OF CARE AND BEFORE THEY
REACHED A CRISIS. SO WITH THAT
OVER ARCHING INTRODUCTION AND
RESPONSE I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
DEPUTY DIRECTOR INTO SPORTS TO
TALK FURTHER ABOUT CRITICAL
SUPPORTS HER FAMILY BASED CARE
AND SOME ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU TEHERAN
BLOOD MEANT THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND APPRECIATE AGAIN
THE FOCUS ON THE VISION OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM.
ACCEPTED AND ALL I'M GOING TO
DIG INTO SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
QUESTION POSED WITHIN THEIR
GENDER WHICH CENTERED AROUND THE
WORK WE ARE DEALING AND THE
STRATEGIES THAT WE HAVE FOUND
SUCCESSFUL. IN BUILDING FAMILY
BASED CARE. PARTNERED ED ARE
MOVING IN A VERY POSITIVE
DIRECTION AND HAVE BEEN FOCUSED
INTENTLY ON HOW TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE. THE NUMBER OF UNITS
BEING CARED FOR IN FAMILY BASED
PLACEMENT. I DO WANT TO ADDRESS
THE QUESTION POSED IN THE AGENDA
ABOUT THE CHANGE AND FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENT EVERYTIME I'M EITHER
WORKING IN A DECREASE IN THAT
FAMILY BASED PLACEMENT. THE DATA
CITED AND THE AGENDA BREAKS DOWN
THE PERCENTAGES. I THANK I. IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN. AND
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. BUT FOR.
WITH THE IF BY OUR NON MINOR
DEPENDENT POPULAR. WHICH DID
ACCESS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN MOST OF THOSE NON MINOR
DEPENDENT PUTS OUR YOUTH BETWEEN
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY ONE. ARE
PLACED IN INDEPENDENT LIVING
SETTING OUR TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM. AS OPPOSED TO BEING IN
FAMILY BASED PLACEMENTS WHICH IS
MORE CONSISTENT BUT THEIR
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS. IF WE CALL
THE NON MINOR DEPENDENTS OUT OF
THE DATA NUMBER IT'S JUST THAT
THE PLACEMENT FOR. THE SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD WE SEE AN INCREASE IN
FAMILY BASED PLACEMENTS BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN APART
WITH SEVENTY TWO PERCENT. IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY WHERE WE'RE
AT 78% IN TERMS OF WHAT IS A- TO
THE THANK. WE FOUND SIX. WHEN
FAMILY FINDING ENGAGE.
INDIVIDUAL PARTICULARLY WHEN WE
FOCUS ON THE CHILD ON FAMILY AND
EXTENDED FAMILY INCLUDING A
FOCUS. ON THE PATERNAL FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT. TO DEFEND. THE
SERVICE CONTRACTS AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT COUNTY AN INDIVIDUALIZED
CHILD SPECIFIC RECRUITMENT.
THINGS LIKE ARTIST PROGRAM WHICH
SUPPORTS EXTENSIVE FAMILY
FINDING ENGAGEMENT AND LYFT
PERMANENT THESE SERVICES AND IS
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE TRAINING
AND COACHING AS WELL AS
CONDUCTING REGULAR WEBINARS.
THAT ARE AVAILABLE ONLINE ON A
RECORDED FOR THAT COUNTY USE
THAN OTHERS CAN WATCH WHATEVER.
WHENEVER THEY'RE ABLE TO SCALE
THOSE WOMEN ARE COMPELLED TO
FUND THINGS LIKE WORKING THREE
ISSUE FOR GRIEF AND LOSS. GRIEF
AND LOSS VERY. AND SPECIALIZED
PERMANENCY SERVICES AND BEST
PRACTICES. AROUND UP FRONT THE
ONLY FINDING. WE ALSO PARTNERED
WITH DALY FELICE. I COMMUNITY
CAN FIRM THAT'S THE POINT COUNTY
IN MICRO TARGET DID YOU RESTART
RECRUITMENT WHICH IS THE WAY
USING ANALYTICAL DATA TO TARGET
HOMES THAT HAVE SPECIFIC
CAPACITIES TO THIRD YOUTH WITH
SPECIALIZED NEEDS. THIS IS
RECRUITMENT WITH THE DIFFERENT
POPULATION ALLOWING COUNTIES TO
MARK THAT LABOR GROUP FAMILY
JUST BEAR PEOPLE CONTENT THAT
SERVICES NEEDS I THINK BACK
POPULATION ARE THE ISSUES THAT
ARE STEPPING DOWN FROM AN F. T.
R. T. P. ANY USE OF THE DAILY
SOLUTION- STRATEGIES HAVE BEEN
VERY THINK THAT ALL TO GIVE YOU
AN DEA OF THE CONTRACT THE
STATE. WE HAVE SEEN ONE COUNTY
HAVE A MEDICALLY FRAGILE USE
REQUIRING AN INTENSIVE SERVICES
FOSTER CARE HOME NOT ONLY DID
THE COUNTY FIND A NURSE THAT HAD
TRAINING SPECIFIC TO THE CHILD
WE NEED- COULD BECOME THE REPORT
THE ONLY FOR THAT CHILD THEY
OFTEN REPEATS FIFTEEN ADDITIONAL
THE- ANOTHER EXAMPLE ONE COUNTY
PROBATION AGENCIES RAN A
POPULATION SPECIFIC CAMPAIGNS.
TO RECRUIT HOMES FOR TEENAGERS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF FOURTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN HADN'T CONSERVATIVES
NEED. EVERYTHING THE. HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE TARGETED LEADS.
THERE ARE WORKING WITH THE U.
DAVIS MIND INSTITUTE. IN ORDER
TO. A KEEP CALM. THROUGH THE OF
LIFE EMPLACEMENT. FOR AND- YEAR
- ADDRESS. IT ABOUT. DISORDER IN
THINGS LIKE AUTISM IN EDH.
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURIES AND A
LOT FOR THE FACILITY YEAH THE
DEPRESSION. AND AGAIN HAVE BEEN
REAL SICK FAT- IN WORKING WITH
THE TEAM IN ORDER TO YOU KNOW-
CABLE LICENSE SUPPORT CHILDREN
WE HAD. A SIX YEAR OLD WHO
UNDIAGNOSED AUTISM IN A SEVERE
EATING DISORDER IT WAS BROUGHT
TO THE UC DAVIS. EMERGENCY RAM
CAL THE NEVER BEEN IN SCHOOL OR
RECEIVED ANY TREATMENT FOR
AUTISM OR THE EATING PROBLEMS
THAT WE WORK WITH THE UC DAVIS.
MIND INSTITUTE TEAM. IN ORDER TO
HELP PREPARE THAT USED FOR HOME
BASED PLACEMENT BY IDENTIFYING
INTERVENTIONS FOR THAT CHILD AND
THAT YOU HAVE NOT BEEN CONNECTED
WITH A FOSTER FAMILY- AND IS
EATING AND THRIVING- AND HAS AND
HAS HAD A- DRAMATIC DECREASE- IN
VERBAL OUTBURSTS AND OTHER
TRICKS ABOUT THE FED. AND THE
GOAL FOR THAT YOUNG PERSON IS IT
FOR UNIFICATION AND THE AND THE
FATHER IS ALSO INVOLVED FINALLY
WE HAVE FIFTEEN COUNTIES THAT
HAVE DONE THINGS LIKE THEIR UP
FRONT THE ONLY FINDING I LOOKED
UP WE KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL
COUNTY HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN
TWENTY THOUSAND AND- SIX- THEY
HAVE FOUND ACROSS THE TEN
OFFICERS WERE THEY'VE
IMPLEMENTED THE PILOT. BUT THEY
CONSISTENTLY ARE CONNECTING
BETWEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND 80% OF
THEIR YOUNG PEOPLE TO RELATIVES
INCLUSIVE OF THE NON OFFENDING
PARENT RELATIVES AND EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS. THE FOURTEENTH
ROUTE YOU TO THE SUCCESS OF ITS
INDIVIDUALIZED CHILD SPECIFIC
ENGAGEMENT SUPPORT WE'VE ALSO
LEARNED THAT FINDING FAMILY IS
NOT ENOUGH WE MUST ALSO DROPPED
ADDRESS THE GAP IN THE SYSTEMS
OF CARE. TO ENSURE THAT THE
FAMILY THREE FEET THE ROBUST
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT THEY
REQUIRE IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY. CARE FOR AND
SUPPORT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE. OR
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE WORK FOR BY
A TWENTY EIGHTY. BUT FOR THAT
AND ALL. THE GAPS WITHIN OUR
SYSTEM OF. AND STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS THEM. I'M ALL WORKING
COULD COMPLETE THE DATA. AND
DATA SHARING OUR SYSTEM. WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED FOCUS AREAS THREE THE
CHILD'S. TECHNICAL ASSISTANT
CALL THE CONSISTENT THAT KERRY
TEAM ENGAGES THEM. YOU KNOW NEED
TO ADDRESS GIVE. IS- ONLY THING
YET COMPLEX IS- INVOLVED IN
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS AND WE KNOW
THAT NO ONE SYSTEM CAN MEET ALL
OF THE NEEDS. WE NEED TO IMPROVE
OUR CLASS WITH THEM COMPETENCIES
IN COLLABORATION TO MAKE SURE
ALL OF THE SYSTEMS ARE WORKING
TOGETHER- AND ADDRESS THE LACK
OF ACCESS TO SPECIALIZED
SERVICES FOR OUR- AND FEEDBACK
POPULATION AND DUE TO THE FACT
THAT HE SUPPORTERS AND OTHER.
SPECIALIZED POPULATIONS OF WILD
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE INTENSITY
AND FREQUENCY ESPECIALLY MENTAL. PEOPLE AND ENSURE THAT
PERMANENT AND ENSURE THEIR
PERMANENT CONNECTIONS TO
FAMILIES. THE RESOURCES THAT WE
REQUESTED PROCTOR CARE PLACEMENT
SERVICES BCP ARE AIMED AT
INCREASING OVERSIGHT OF
PLACEMENTS AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE CONNECTING OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO FAMILY BASED
PLACEMENTS WHENEVER POSSIBLE I'M
AN EMPLOYEE BEING ANY AND YOU
WANT TO STAY IN CONGREGATE CARE
SETTING WE DO KNOW THROUGH THE
DATA REPORT- THAT ABOUT 30% OF
YOU ARE IN ARE AT YOUR T. P.
OVER THE LAST YEAR HAVE BEEN
CONGREGATE SETTINGS FOR ONE OR
MORE YEAR IF WHICH IS CONTRARY.
TO THE SHARED VISION THAT WE ALL
HAVE- WITHIN PPR AND FELT MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DOUBLING DOWN ON
THE SUCCESSFUL EFFORT BUT I
OUTLINED ABOUT IT CONNECTS
CHILDREN TO FAMILIES AND SUPPORT
CHILDREN IN THE FAMILY BASED
PLACEMENT THE CRITICAL. DIVISION
FTP ARE FOR ALL CHILDREN GROW UP
IN LOVING FAMILY I'M NOT
ESSENTIAL ALSO TO ENSURING
EQUITY AND WELL BEING I
THROUGHOUT OUR CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS BUT WE'RE KEENLY AWARE
TO PICK MORE DETAIL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS TO CONTINUE. TO ACHIEVE
THE VISION OF THE C. R. THANK
YOU. DIRECTOR WILL HEAR FROM
JUSTIN. WITH THE OF. YEAH YES
JUST MARC- NO COMMENTS TO AND-
THE GENIE OF THE- NARRATIVE
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT BUT HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE COMMITTEE
AS NECESSARY. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM ANGELES SHORT
WITH THE L. A. L. THANK YOU. YES
AGAIN ANGELES SHORT WITH THE L.
YOU JUST HEARD FROM- DFS WE ARE
UNDOUBTEDLY MAKING PROGRESS
TOWARD ACHIEVING THE GOALS OF C.
C. R. INCLUDING REDUCING OUR
STATE'S RELIANCE ON LONG TERM
CONGREGATE CARE PLACEMENTS. AND
INCREASING- INDIVIDUALIZED AND-
TAUGHT IN FAMILY CENTERED CARE.
THAT'S SAID- OUR COMMENTS TODAY
ARE GOING TO FOCUS ON THOSE-
AREAS OF CPR WHERE- THERE
REMAINS ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT OR
PROGRESS TO BE MADE-
SPECIFICALLY IT CERTAIN ELEMENTS
OF C. C. R. SUCH AS UNIVERSAL
USAGE. OF AND CONSISTENT
REPORTING AROUND HOW TO FAMILY
TEAM. AND CAN ASSESSMENT FOR
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS ASSESSMENT. ARE THESE
ELEMENTS REMAIN LESS THAN FULLY
IMPLEMENTED WHILE OTHER ELEMENTS
SUCH AS- RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL HAVE YET TO REACH THEIR
GOALS. AND CONSIDERING NOT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL THE
VARIOUS COMPONENTS OF CCR REALLY
ARE IMPORTANT TO INSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE MAKING PROGRESS TOWARD
ACHIEVING THE GOALS OF C. C. R.
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO ASK
THE DEPARTMENT WHAT
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT OR
GUIDANCE MAY BE NEEDED.
REGARDING THE ELEMENTS THAT HAVE
YET TO BE FULLY ROLLED OUT. OF
FOR EXAMPLE. WHAT IF THE DENTIST
FOR THE COUNTIES THAT FACE
CHALLENGES INCLUDING ANY DATA
SYSTEM AND REPORTING ISSUES.
AROUND CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM AND
CANS SUSTENANCE. WHAT IS NEEDED
TO ACHIEVE CONSISTENT CAN STATE
REPORTING ACROSS ALL COUNTY-
SOME OTHER QUESTIONS FROM OUR
INITIAL ANALYSIS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL- HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SPOKEN TO TODAY SO
I WON'T REITERATE THOSE. BUT I
DID JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ONE
ADDITIONAL POINT RELATED TO-
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL OR RFA
. I HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT BACKLOG OF
RESOURCE FAMILY APPLICATION
PENDING BEYOND NINETY DAYS.
HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT BEGINNING
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
STATUTE SPECIFIES THAT THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF TIME- THAT
RELATIVE TO OUR EMERGENCY CARE
GIVERS. AND RECEIVE STATE FUNDS
FOR FOSTER CARE MAINTENANCE
PAYMENTS PRIOR TO COMPLETING THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL WILL
DECREASE TO NINETY DAYS. AND
THIS IS A DECREASE FROM ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS- WITH
THE OPTION OF A GOOD CAUSE
EXTENSION UP TO THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS. ALLOWED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR- RFA APPROVAL TIMES
ARE TRENDING IN A POSITIVE
DIRECTION HOWEVER THE MEDIAN
APPROVAL TIME DOES REMAIN ABOVE
NINETY DAYS- SO CONSIDERING THE
CURRENT BACKLOG. AS WELL AS THE
FACT THAT THE- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING WOULD NOT BE
ALLOCATED UNTIL AFTER JULY
FIRST- WHEN THE AMOUNT OF
ALLOWABLE TIME FOR STATE FUNDS
IS SET TO DECREASE. WE RECOMMEND
A LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER AMENDING STATUTE TO
ALLOW FOR THE CONTINUATION-
PROJECT WILL HAVE A GOOD BECAUSE
EXTENSION OPTION ON AN ONGOING
BASIS BUT ESPECIALLY DURING THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC. THIS CHANGE
WOULD ENSURE EMERGENCY CARE
GIVERS ACROSS ALL COUNTIES.
DON'T LOSE ACCESS TO STATE FUNDS
FOR FOSTER CARE PAYMENTS IF THEY
EXPERIENCE ANY DELAYS AND THE
RESOURCE A- RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL PROCESS. THANK YOU TO
ANSWERING. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM KATHY SANDERLING
MCDONALD'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
CAPPING CENTER LANGUAGE CW DNA.
WE HAVE TO RESPOND TO A FEW
QUESTIONS ON THE- I AM IN THE
AGENDA TODAY FIRST OFF- WHAT
COULD HELP ME SEE AND STILL
BEING UNFINISHED BUSINESS WHEN
IT COMES. CPR KELLY SERVICES
AGENCIES AGREE THAT CCR HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN A NUMBER OF WAYS.
ADDED SHOOTING THE BALL SET
FORTH IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION AND WHAT
THAT. AND CAN I HAVE A SERVICES
AGENCIES ARE REALLY PROUD OF
THESE EFFORTS AND VALUE ARE
STRENGTHENED PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS. COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS AND OTHER
AGENCIES THAT WORK WITH US TO
DELIVER SERVICES TO CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES. WE'VE CUT
THE NUMBER CONGREGATE CARE
PLACEMENTS ORE YOUTH AND
FAMILIES ARE INVOLVED IN THEIR
OWN SERVICE PLANNING TO CHILD
AND FAMILY TEAMING AND WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO RAMP UP AT THE
STATE REQUIRED. RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL PROCESS. WE APPRECIATE
THE DEPARTMENT DISCUSSING DATA
BOTH ON THIS PANEL AS WELL AS OF
THE FIRST PANELISTS WHILE I WANT
TO KNOW WE'VE GOT SOME QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE DATA. THAT WERE
PRESENTED IN THE LARGER ISSUE
BRIEF THAT THEY RELEASED OUT
LAST WEEK AND PLAN TO ENGAGE
WITH THEM AS WELL AS DR WEBSTER
WHO YOU HEARD FROM ON THE FIRST
CHANNEL. THAT SAID AS WE LOOK AT
DATA WE DO STILL SEE AREAS WHERE
THERE'S ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT AND
AN UNFINISHED BUSINESS AT THE
WORK. FIRST WE CONTINUE TO
REDUCE STATE CONGREGATE CARE
THERE'S- MORE PRESSURE ON OUR
SYSTEM TO MAINTAIN. A ROBUST
SUPPLIER FOSTER HOMES WHO ARE
WILLING TO OPEN THEIR HEARTS AND
HOMES OF FACIA. AND A GREAT NEED
TO CONTINUE AND BETTER SUPPORT
FAMILY CAREGIVERS. POINT IN TIME
DATA AS OF OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SHOWS THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF ALL PLACEMENTS
THAT ARE WITH RELATIVES. HAVEN'T
CHANGED ALL THAT MUCH TWENTY
FIFTEEN. THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENT WAYS TO LOOK AT THE
DATA OF COURSE BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT AND HOW WE IDENTIFY.
RECRUIT AND SUPPORT FAMILY
CAREGIVERS I WILL TALK A BIT
MORE IN JUST A FEW MINUTES ABOUT
THE WAY THAT THESE EFFORTS CAN
BE SUPPORT. AND OUT ONTO THE
ISSUES DISCUSSED IN THE PRIOR
PANEL AROUND DISPROPORTIONATE
ALITY AND DISPARITIES. FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN AMERICAN INDIAN
CHILDREN AS YOU DISCUSSED
DISPROPORTIONATELY INCREASES AS
THEY GO DEEPER IN THE CHILD
WELFARE INCLUDING A CONGREGATE
CARE THERE ARE NEARLY SIX TIMES
AS MANY AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHILDREN IN CONGREGATE CARE AS
IN THE GENERAL POPULATION AND
FOUR POINT SIX TIMES AS MANY
AMERICAN INDIAN CHILDREN. OF
COURSE FOR US THE TCR TOPICS
EATING FOR EVERYONE ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN OF COLOR WE HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS IN
ADDRESSING DISPARITIES THAT I'LL
SHARE A PANEL THREE REGARDING
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT THE FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES ACT
GIVES US. FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE DEEPLY IMPACTED BY FOSTER
CARE AND THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THE VSPHERE WHAT THE
JUST ONE CHANGE IT WAS A SERIES
OF MULTIPLE COMPLEX CHANGES THAT
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE TO THIS DAY.
SOME AREAS WHERE WE THINK
CONTINUED WORKING IS TO BE DONE
AND CLEARED LIKE I MENTIONED
RECRUITING AND SUPPORTING FOSTER
FAMILIES OF RELATIVE CAREGIVERS.
IMPLEMENTING CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMING IN THE WAY THAT WE WOULD
LIKE IT TO BE IMPLEMENTED SO
THAT CHILDREN FAMILIES HAVE A
TRUE VOICE IN THE PROCESS.
BUILDING AND STRENGTHENING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER AGENCIES
AND ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVE OUR
CHILDREN AND YOU. TO ENSURE THAT
ROBUST SUPPORTS ARE AVAILABLE
AND AVAILABLE TIMELY WHEN
THEY'RE NEEDED. UNFORTUNATELY
SERVICES ARE NOT ALWAYS READILY
AVAILABLE IN THE HOME AS WE
INVEST IN THE INITIALLY WITH THE
C. R. WE THINK THAT THE CAL GAME
SYSTEM BEING IMPLEMENTED AT DH
CS. SHOWS GREAT PROMISE ENABLING
OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH. TO
ACCESS THAT U. P. S. D. T. A
TITLE MEANT. FOR FOSTER YOUTH
FOR MENTAL HEALTH. CAN'T
COUNTIES CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH SERVING FOSTER CHILDREN.
THAT HAVE VERY INTENSIVE IN
PUBLIC HEARING MENTAL HEALTH
AND- DD RELATED ME. A TWENTY
EIGHTY PASS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AS THE SHORT SPECIAL REQUIRES
THE CREATION OF BOTH STATE LEVEL
AND LOCAL LEVEL BODIES WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS BUT THE WORK IS
DEFINITELY I'M GOING IN THIS
AREA. AND THAT'S SUPPORTING
INTERVIEWS WITH THE MOST COMPLEX
NEEDS FOR HOME AT LEAST ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS I TAILORED SET
OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ARE
NEEDED IN A MORE HIGH END
PLACEMENT IN ORDER TO HELP THEM
MOVE FORWARD AND STEPPED DOWN.
INTO THE MOST FAMILY LIKE
SETTING POSSIBLE. FINALLY WE
BELIEVE IT MAKES SENSE TO REVIEW
THE S. T. R. T. P. MODEL
TOGETHER. WE WENT FROM A SYSTEM
THAT HAD FOURTEEN RATE LEVELS
AND DIFFERENT TYPES OF
STRUCTURES THAT ARE CONGREGATE
CARE FACILITIES TO A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL MODEL. DID WE GET IT
RIGHT PROBABLY NOT ENTIRELY.
PROPOSING A WORKGROUP THAT WOULD
GET TOGETHER THAT HAS
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ACROSS THE
THAT COUNTIES AS WELL AS THE
CHILD SERVING AGENCIES OF THE
ALLIANCE SO YOU'LL HEAR FROM-
NEXT ON THIS PANEL. WOULD ALLOW
US TO REALLY. TURN THE BOTTLE
AROUND AND TAKE THE TIME TO SEE
WHAT WE GOT RIGHT BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. WHAT MIGHT NEED TO BE
CHANGED IN PARTICULAR COUNTIES
IN OUR SERVICE PROVIDER PARTNERS
ARE STRONG AND TO RESPOND TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. THAT THE
BUILDING OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS FOR CHILDREN IN.
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T HAVE A REALLY
ROBUST RESIDENTIAL BASED
ALTERNATIVE TO A PSYCHIATRIC
LEVEL OF CARE THAT SPECIFICALLY
OPERATED FOR CHILDREN. OTHER
THAN AN EMERGENCY ROOM. AND WE
KNOW THAT IF YOU'RE CHEAP EVEN
FOR OUR STRUGGLING FOR VARIOUS
REASONS TO MEET MOMENT. IT'S
EASIER TO MEET THEM FOR VARIOUS
REASONS WHICH I'M SURE NEXT
PANELISTS WILL SHARE. IN
ADDITION THE ANALYSIS- THAT IS
REQUIRED BY EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE OF NOW YEARS OF RETAIL AND
SO IT REALLY I THINK IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE SAYS. DO IT. TARGETED
AND IDEALLY WAY REVIEW WHAT WE
HAVE NOW. AND THINK ABOUT THE
RESULT. THE FACT QUESTION A
RELATED TO THE FAIR. THAT HAVE
BEEN SIX. IN THE FAMILY BASE
CARE AT HOW WE CAN BETTER SERVE.
OUR FAMILY BASED CARE GIVERS.
RCC ARE QUITE A NUMBER OF THINGS
IN THE PLACE THAT WERE VERY
HELPFUL IN ENABLING US TO
RECRUIT AND SUPPORT FAMILY BASED
CARE. THE PARTICULAR INCLUDE
FOSTER PARENT RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND SUPPORT ALSO KNOWN
AS THE FIFTH FIRST FUNDING AS
WELL AS THE STATE WIDE IN ASPEN
OF RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL A
NEW WAY FOR US TO LICENSE AN
APPROVED. FOSTER PARENTS AND
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS. THE FIRST
PROGRAM PROVIDED US WITH A VERY-
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AND IT COULD BE BROADLY YEARS TO
BOTH OF RECRUIT AND RETAIN AND
SUPPORT OUR FOSTER FAMILIES. WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF EXAMPLES OF
WHAT COUNTIES HAVE DONE WITH
THESE FUNDS WHICH HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL BUT- UNFORTUNATELY NO
LONGER AVAILABLE TO OUR MEMBERS.
THE FUNDS I'M SHALLOW DOUBTS
OVER TIME AND THEN THEY WERE
ZEROED OUT STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND NOW AGAIN
HERE AT TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS NO FUNDING IN THIS
AREA. WHAT WE'VE LEARNED SO IS
AS WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
RECRUITING AND SOCIALLY FAMILY
BASED CARE RELATIVE AND NOT
RELATED EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS.
THEY ARE TYPICALLY SERVING.
CHILDREN IN THE FAMILY. THANK
THEY KNOW THE CHILDREN THEY THE
FAMILIES AND- WHILE THEY ARE
THERE FOR US AND THERE FOR THE
CHILDREN WHILE THEY'RE IN THE
HOME. IDEALLY THE CHILDREN ARE
REUNIFIED WITH THEIR BIOLOGICAL
FAMILIES OR SOME OTHER
PERMANENCY THE CHEAPER AFTER
GUARDIANSHIP. AND THEN WE HAVE
SEEN THOSE FAMILIES EXIT THE
SYSTEM THEY DON'T REMAIN IN THE
SYSTEM TYPICALLY TO BE CARE
GIVERS TWO OTHER CHILDREN WHO
ARE NOT PART OF THEIR FAMILY.
AND SO WHEREAS I THINK AT THE
BEGINNING A FEW C. R. IT WAS
BELIEVED THAT WE COULD KIND OF
RECRUIT CADRE OF FOSTER PARENTS.
THAT WE WOULD HAVE THE BEARING
THEY WOULD BE THIS KIND OF
ONGOING RESOURCE FOR US. IT
TURNED OUT THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE REPLENISHING THAT
RECRUITMENT AND THOSE SUPPORT TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE VERY SPECIFIC
CHILDREN IN OUR SYSTEM AND THEN
CONTINUE TO DO THAT OVER TIME
IT'S NOT BEEN. SORT OF A. ONE
AND DONE AS I THINK WE HAD
EXPECTED. WE ALSO FEEL THAT WE
LAST FOR WITH THE P. AND WHEN WE
WALK THAT FUNDING FOR THE FOR
THE PAPERS. HELLO YOU FROM
REPORTING SEEING DROPS IN
AVAILABLE RESOURCE FAMILIES WHO
ARE NOT RELATED TO CHILDREN IN
CARE. OF A LOT OF OUR LONG TIME
RESEARCH FAMILIES RETIRED DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC IT WAS STRESSFUL-
WE JUST SAW A LOT OF LOT OF
LONGSTANDING FAMILIES ACROSS
COUNTY. AND SO WE'RE FOR-
CONTINUED FUNDING OR RESTORED
FUNDING OF A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR FAVORS-
THIS IS ENOUGH THAT WERE CO
SPONSORING WITH THE- COUNTY
PROBATION CHIEF OF CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS AS HERE YOU STATE
COUNCIL. AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE SOME EXAMPLES OF SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE CAN USE THE
FUNDING FOR- I JUST A COUPLE AND
WE CAN PROVIDE THAT THE FULL
LIST TO THE COMMITTEE AFTER. IS
IN ADDITION TO EXPANDING KINSHIP
FOCUS SUPPORT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE REALLY KIÞM CIVIL
SUPPORT. AND ASSISTANCE TO
FAMILIES TO GET THEIR HOMES
APPROVED. IT MIGHT INCLUDE-
BETH. OR A QUICK MINUTE-
PLAYPENS OTHER MATERIALS IN THE
HOME SO THAT A RELATIVE IS ABLE
TO QUICKLY. I THINK APPROVAL AND
BECOME APPROVED AS A RESOURCE
FAMILY- AT TIMES IT'S REQUIRED
HOUSING REPAIRS IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT THERE ARE.
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS THAT MUST
BE BACK. IN ALL HOPES INCLUDING
RELATIVES ABOUT RELATED EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS. WE'VE ALSO PAID
THE- RESPITE CARE TAKE CARE
GIVERS SOMETHING THAT WE LEARNED
AS WE'VE IMPLEMENTED. THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM. OF WHICH
WAS CHAMPIONED BY SHARE ARAMBULA
AND HAS ABOUT- BEGAN TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. IS THAT RIGHT BUT
IT IS. A REAL AN ONGOING NEED.
FOR STRESSED CAREGIVERS AND IT
ALSO GIVES YOU A BREAK. AS WE
MAY SEE- YOU KNOW KIND OF
INCIDENTS OR DISAGREEMENTS
OCCUR. THAT COULD RESULT IN THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE PLACEMENT.
BEING ABLE TO SORT OF- HAVE
SOMEONE WHO CAN. HELP STEP IN
AND NOT JUST ARRANGE TREATMENT
OR OTHER SERVICES BUT ALSO-
TEMPORARILY- FOR A VERY SHORT
TERM CARE FOR THAT. YEAR IS UP
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. SO- THE
OTHER AREA THAT WE ARE- SEEKING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS FOR THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL AS I
MENTIONED. BOB AS YOU KNOW THIS
IS A HUGE CHANGE TO HOW WE
LICENSE AN APPROVED FOSTER
PARENTS ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS. SPONSORED
THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION- IT WAS
A BACK IN THE- OFFICE IT WAS
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
TEN YOU KNOW THAT IN TWENTY
ELEVEN WE REALIGN THE REMAINDER
OF CHILD WELFARE UNDER THE
TWENTY WHAT THAT. REALIGNMENT AT
THAT TIME- IT WAS NOT A
CANDIDATE FOR EVERY COUNTY TO DO
RFA FIFTY THREE ARE LEGISLATION
AND- TWENTY FIFTEEN I'M MADE OF
THE STATEWIDE REQUIREMENTS AND
WE- I KNOW WHAT WE KNOW EXACTLY
HOW MUCH IS BEING SPENT. WARRANT
AREN'T PAID BY COUNTIES BECAUSE
WE HAVE A TRUE UP. STATUTORILY
REQUIRED PROCESS THAT IS RELATED
TO OPPOSITION THIRTY THAT
REQUIRES FUNDING OF A NEW
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE ENACTED
AFTER TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT.
AND SO IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION A YEAR- WE APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
APPROVING EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CURRENT YEAR ON
A ONE TIME BASIS FOR THAT. OF A
COUNTIES ARE USING THESE FUNDS-
TO OFFSET THE OTHERWISE UNFUNDED. ARCTIC IT IS A SIGNIFICANT
THOUGH AN ALL INVEST. AND WE
KNOW THAT THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THIS FUNDING BECAUSE IT
CARRIES A SHIFT THEIR RESOURCES
AWAY FROM OTHER TYPES OF
SERVICES IN ORDER TO COVER THAT.
UP AND IT NEEDS TO BE AN ONGOING
FUND. AND THEN FINALLY THE THIRD
QUESTION IS RELATED TO ENSURING
THAT THEIR SUFFICIENT EMERGENCY
PLACEMENTS FOR YOU. TO COME INTO
THE SYSTEM AND EXPECTEDLY
ESPECIALLY THOSE ON A RELATIVE
WHO ARE WILLING OR ABLE TO CARE
FOR THEM. AND AT TIMES WE HAVE
NOTICED THAT WERE ABOUT TO I
NEED TO BRING A CHILD INTO
CUSTODY FOR THEIR SAFETY. IT CAN
HAPPEN UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT IT CAN HAPPEN ON THE
WEEKEND WE MAY NOT IMMEDIATELY
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THAT
FAMILY AND WHO. WOULD BE A GOOD.
PLACE MATT WAS PART OF THE
FAMILY ARE NOT RELATED EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBER. SO IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL THAT WE WORK WITH THE
STATE WILL WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS NEEDED TO DEVELOP
AND FUNDING OPTIONS FOR COUNTIES
TO SAFELY. TEMPORARILY PLACE
CHILDREN IN UGANDA DIVERSITY
BATES SAID IF A RELATIVE OR
OTHER POTENTIAL. CARE GIVER IS
NOT IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE. WHEN
I FOR STARTED IT W. D. MORE THAT
YEARS MANY COUNTIES OPERATED
SHELTERS. WHERE CHILDREN COULD
BE TAKEN FOR SHORT TERM STAYS.
AND TYPICALLY WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THOSE CHILDREN WHO HAD
JUST ENTERED THE SYSTEM. LACK OF
TALKING ABOUT- OVER TIME THE
MOST COUNTIES HAVE CLOSE THE
TEMPORARY SHELTERS. THERE WERE
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT THE LENGTH
OF STAY AND WHETHER THERE WERE
ADEQUATE SERVICES BEING PROVIDED
THERE. THERE ARE EIGHT COUNTIES
THAT CONTINUE TO OPERATE A
MODIFIED TEMPORARY TEN DAY
SHELTER TYPE FACILITY FOR MOST
NO LONGER HAVE THE FACILITY. SO
WHAT WE'VE ALSO SEEN IN RECENT
YEARS IS THAT YES CHILDREN
BECOME INDICATOR UNEXPECTEDLY
BUT ALSO WE HAVE COUNTIES
REPORTING A GROWING NUMBER OF
SITUATIONS. WHERE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THE MOST COMPLEX NEEDS.
THAT ARE IN A PARTICULAR PLACE
AND OFTEN A CONGREGATE CARE
PLACEMENTS HAVE AN INCIDENT OR
DISAGREEMENT OF HER. AND AS A
RESULT THE CAREGIVER OR PROVIDER
ASKED THE COUNTY TO COME AND GET
THE YOUTH LITTLE NOTICE. AND
MANY COUNTIES ARE STRUGGLING TO
FIND A QUICK ALTERNATIVE
PLACEMENT FOR TREATMENT AND
SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE. YOU HAVE
AS A RESULT. OF THE SITUATION
FOR YOU BECAUSE I COUNTY OFFICE
OR IN A HOTEL WITH TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. SOCIAL WORKER SUPPORT.
BUT NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE THESE
PLACES HAPPENED THIS IS NOT A
PLACE WHERE TREATMENT AND
HEALING CAN HAPPEN THESE ARE NOT
PLACES THAT WE CAN LIKE THAT. OR
THAT WE WANT TO PLACE CHILDREN.
SO WE PROPOSE THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
OTHER AGENCIES THAT SERVE. OUR
CHILDREN AND USE THAT JUST
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THE
REGIONAL CENTERS IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM TO TRY TO
DEVELOP MORE OPTIONS. WHAT I
ACTUALLY THINK WORTH EXPLORING
IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF WHAT WE'RE
CALLING AN INTENSIVE. ASSESSMENT
TRANSITIONAL TYPE OF FACILITY OR
HOME. THESE ARE THE SHORT TERM
SERVICE RICH JOINTLY STAFFED BY
THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES THAT I
MENTIONED. WHILE WE- AND SO THEY
WOULD ENSURE THAT SERVICES ARE
ACTUALLY PROVIDED WHILE CATHOLIC
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE AGENCY. IS
WORKING AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE I
GOT. APPROPRIATE SAKE ONGOING
PLACE. SO WE THINK THAT IN
ADDITION TO SOME OF THESE COUNTY
BAY. TYPES OF HOME WE WERE ALSO
BETTER. FROM WORKING WITH THE
STATE TO IF WE DEVELOP. A OF
REACH OF OMAHA AS WELL NOT A
COUNTY COULD RELEASE- THAT THAT
TIME KIND OF. WE ALSO THINK MORE
WORK NEEDS TO DONE TO A PLACE
SURVEY. MUCH MORE QUICKLY WHEN A
CHILD IS BORN UNTO CARE. THIS
WOULD INCLUDE BUT NOT BE LIMITED
TO. SUPPORTING FAMILIES WHO
AGREED TO ACCEPT YOU FROM LITTLE
NOTICE. THIS COULD BE SOMETHING
WE COULD USE FOR EXAMPLE THE
PEPPERS FUNDING THAT I MENTIONED
FOR WE ALSO TO LOOK AT
RESTRUCTURING THE NAME OF
COUNTIES TO PARTNER. WITH
RESOURCE FAMILIES TO HOLD
EMERGENCY PLACEMENTS AVAILABLE
FOR COUNTY. WE ALSO KNOW THAT I
FUNDING RFA THAT IS THE PROCESS
THAT BEGAN AS A SHORT NOTED.
THAT HE MET. PRIOR TO APPROVAL
FOR RELATIVES. AND SO ALLOWING
GROWERS SHOULD IMMEDIATELY
TOGETHER FUNDING SUPPORT. WE
NEED TO HAVE ADEQUATE RFA STAFF
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN BEGIN AND
COMPLETE THE PROCESS TIMELY. AS
YOU HERE THERE IS A CERTAIN
POINT AT WHICH THE FUNDING IF
THAT TO TURN OFF IF IT CHANGES
NOT MAY. AND THEN FINALLY FAMILY
FINDING AND GIVEN SUPPORT WHAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT A FEW TIMES
ON THESE FIRST TWO CANDLES.
THERE'S A REALLY GREAT VALUE OF
THIS HOW DO YOU THINK IN THE
SEARCH AS SOON AS THE UTERUS
CARE. AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
EVIDENCE BASED MODELS ONE THAT
WE KNOW OF THAT A LOT OF COUNTY
USE OF CALLED THIRTY DAYS TO
FAMILY. PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
PROVIDE GUIDELINES FOR SEARCHING
AND SUPPORTING RELATED FAMILY
MEMBERS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT JUST FINDING A PERSON IS
NOT ENOUGH. AT THAT POINT YOU
ALSO NEED TO ENGAGE WITH THEM.
THEY MAY NOT KNOW THAT THEY EVEN
HAVE A RELATIVE. WHO IT HAS A
CHILD AND A CHILD WHO HAS BEEN
BROUGHT IN THE FOSTER CARE DUE
TO ABUSE OR NEGLECT OR BOTH. AND
SO REACHING OUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT- WE HAVE TO DO WHAT I
REALLY A THOUGHTFUL WAY. TO
EXPLAIN WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
FAMILY I TRIED SHE BROKE MAKE A
CONNECTION BETWEEN THAT
RELATIVE. AND THAT CHILD ABUSE.
EVEN. IF IT DOESN'T RESULT IN A
PLACE. WE WERE STILL WANT TO
POTENTIAL PRESERVE AFTER THAT.
AND SO FOR FINE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT LAYERS TO IT NOT JUST
I KNOW RELATIVE. SPEAKING WORKED
OUT. THERE'S WORK TO BE DONE
WITH THESE. TO ENSURE THAT THEY
WERE STEP IN. AND BECOME A KEY.
THAT FOR THE YOU. AND SO WE ARE.
INVESTMENT OF FIFTEEN POINT YOU.
GENERAL FUND TO HELP DIRECTLY
THIS WORKING WHICH WOULD BE NEW
FUNDING AT THAT IS NOT CURRENTLY
DIRECTLY FUND- OUT WITH THAT. I
WILL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS ON THE
THREE QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND OF COURSE BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
CHRIS STONER MARKS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR. CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH TERROR ARAMBULA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- SO HAPPY TO
BE HERE TODAY. I'M GONNA JUST
TURN MY TALKING POINTS HERE.
SORRYHAVING A JUST A MOMENT OF
TECH TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES JUST
ONE MOMENT.
MY APOLOGIES I'M NOT SURE WHAT'S
HAPPENING CAN'T HANG ON ONE
MOMENT.
I'M HAD LOST MUCH LOCKING POINTS
FIRST. I'M NOT SURE ABOUT IT- TO
GETS HIS BACK UP HANG ON. IF
IT'S OKAY I'LL BRING IT UP TO
THE DÍAS AND WILL COME BACK TO
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY EITHER
NOW OR IN FUTURE PANEL SAYS. TO
ALLOW YOU TO WORK ON THE TALKING
POINT IF THAT'S OKAY. UP THAT
SHE CERTAINLY. OKAY CL JUST TAKE
ME THIRTY SECONDS TO GET IT BACK
HOLDEN WE CAN WAIT THIRTY
SECONDS SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
IN ORDER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I'M GONNA JUST TALK
THE WITHOUT MY TALKING POINTS-
AS I'M HAVING TROUBLE GETTING
THE LOVE OF MY COMPUTER HERE BUT
I WANT TO JUST THANK AGAIN THE
COMMITTEE. FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
OF WE HAVE ALLOWED THE ALLIANCE
HAS PUT TOGETHER A- A DOCUMENT
CALLED KEEPING USED AT HOME- AND
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF AREAS.
THAT WE HAVE FOUND OF OUR GAPS
IN SERVICES AND POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS. ISSUES
FACING MANY OF OUR YOUTH AND
FAMILIES- AS WE LOOK TO INCREASE
AND THE INITIATIVES ACROSS THE
STATE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
FACING CHILDREN FAMILIES. WE
HAVE FOUND IT CRITICAL TO
INTEGRATE SERVICES- ACROSS
SYSTEMS SO GETTING AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND THE LOCAL LEVELS BOTH-
THE- CARE THREW CAL AIM THROUGH-
THROUGH OUR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
EFFORTS AND THROUGH MANY OTHER
EFFORTS LIKE THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER. TO
ADDRESS THE INTEGRATION OF
SYSTEMS- AS WE LOOK AT THE GAPS
THAT STILL EXIST IN C. C. R.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF- AREAS
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT STILL
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. TO START
WITH WE REALLY FOCUSED THIS IN
THREE DIFFERENT AREAS- THE FIRST
OF WHICH IS FAMILY FINDING AN
ENGAGEMENT- AS MISS UNDERLING
SAID FAMILY FINDING ENGAGEMENT.
IS CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES AROUND EQUITY TO
ADDRESSING GETTING FAMILIES AND
YOUTH TO BE TOGETHER WE- WE HAVE
ACTUALLY A BUDGET REQUEST
FOCUSED ON THOSE CHILDREN WHO
HAVE BEEN IN CARE. FOR EXTENDED
PERIODS OF TIME. AND WHO HAVE
NOT. HAD VERY SPECIFIC
PERMANENCY PLAN PUT IN PLACE SO
WE ARE LOOKING UP FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO SUPPORT GRANTS TO
COUNTIES AND PROVIDERS TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN IN
FOSTER CARE FOR EXTENDED PERIODS
OF TIME GET THOSE THAT SUPPORT
TO IDENTIFY FAMILY MEMBERS AND
OTHERS. BOB SO THAT THEY CAN IN
FACT BE CONNECTED AND HOPEFULLY
EVENTUALLY ACTUALLY BE REUNITED
WITH FAMILY THE SECOND AREA THAT
WE FEEL IS CRITICAL TO ADDRESS
IS THE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES
WHO HAVE REALLY FOCUSED THEIR
ATTENTION. ON PROVIDING
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE.
THIS IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND WE HAVE TO
GET THIS RIGHT. IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT CHILDREN ARE BEING
MOVED OUT OF RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES AN END TO FAMILY
BASED CARE- FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES ARE SERVING CHILDREN
WHO ARE OLDER FOSTER YOUTH
THEY'RE SERVING CHILDREN. WHO
HAVE MEDICAL MEDICAL NEEDS THAT
ARE VERY SPECIALIZED THEY ARE
SERVING- L. G. B. T. YOUTH AND-
THIS THESE AGENCIES DO NOT HAVE
THE SUPPORT HAVE NOT HAD A ON
GOING- COST OF LIVING INCREASE
AND SO WE ARE REQUESTING AN AND
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
SUPPORT ON THIS THAT WE MUST
ENSURE THAT WHILE THE STATE IS
WORKING ON THE- CHANGES TO THE
LEVEL OF CARE. THAT WE PROVIDE A
SHORT TERM. TEMPORARY COST OF
LIVING INCREASE TO THESE
ORGANIZATIONS. FINALLY WE MUST
ADDRESS THE CRITICAL BEHAVIOR
HEALTH NEEDS OF CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND THAT. IS FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON OUR S. T. OR TNCS
ANTHONY TO PROVIDE SHORT TERM
CRISIS RESIDENTIAL SERVICES FOR
NOT JUST FOSTER YOU THOUGHT ALL
USED WE- R. S. T. R. T. P.'S
HAVE STRUGGLED MIGHTILY THROUGH
KOPEN- WE HAVE. THEY HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH INCREASED
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
ACCREDITATION- HAVING MENTAL
HEALTH CONTRACTS FOR MANY OF
THEM- MUCH MORE OVERSIGHT THAN
CERTAINLY MANY OF THEM SAW OF
PRIOR TO THIS YOU SEE ARE. AND
INSTEAD OF HAVING A- PROCESS
WHERE SIGNIFICANT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE HAS BEEN PROVIDED WE
HAVE SEEN MUCH MORE COMPLIANCE
AND REGULATORY FOCUSED AND WE
NEED TO REALLY LOOK AT WAYS TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEM.
PRIMARILY WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
RATE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN PAID
WHICH AS WE LOOK AT THE LEVEL OF
MATURITY OF CHILDREN THAT ARE
PLACED AND ASKED YEAR GP'S- AS
MISS SANDERLING SAID WAIT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
VERY INDIVIDUALIZED CARE. AND
MORE NOT ABLE TO DO THAT. GIVEN
THE CURRENT RATE STRUCTURE THAT
EXISTS FOR US TO YOUR GPS. WE
THERE IS ALSO NO CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT METHODOLOGY FOR
FUNDING OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN THESE PROGRAMS SO
YOU WOULD SEE A VERY WIDE RANGE.
OF THE KINDS OF SERVICES THAT
ARE PROVIDED IN TERMS OF MENTAL
HEALTH WE NEED TO LOOK AT HOW WE
CREATE A CONSISTENCY ACROSS
THESE PROGRAMS. BOB AND FINALLY
AND WITH THE BIG THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER RAMOS WE ARE
ALSO CRITICALLY IN NEED. OF
THOSE CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES AND AN AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN WOULD HELP US
ACCOMPLISH THAT. SO WOOD THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE
LOTS OF SUCCESS IS JUST HAVE
BIRTH WE HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO
DO TOGETHER. AND AGAIN
INTEGRATION IS CRITICAL BOTH AT
THE STATE AND THE COUNTY LEVELS
. WHAT AND WORK PRIMARILY WITH.
WITH THE PROVIDERS WHO ARE WHO
ARE ON THE GROUND SERVING THESE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR AND NOT HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT I WILL BRING IT
UP TO THE DÍAS TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS WE WILL
BEGIN WITH DOCTOR WHAT YES IT'S
A QUESTION AND IT GOT MY
ATTENTION- THERE WAS A REFERENCE
BY KATHY- CERTAINLY MCDONALD
ABOUT A BILL TWENTY EIGHTY THREE
THAT HAD REPORT THIS YEAR'S
OVERDUE- HOW DO WE GET THAT
REPORT EXPEDITED AND COMPLETED-
IT'S KIND OF DISCOURAGING. THE
CARD ACTUALLY WHAT DONE I JUST
KIND OF IT'S PRETTY DISCOURAGING
THAT LEGISLATION CALLS FOR
SOMETHING AND IT- IT'S OVERDUE
AND- SOMEBODY COULD SOMEBODY
ANSWER THAT PLEASE. BECAUSE WILL
BE HAPPY TO GIVE YOU A DUE DATE
LIKE. YEARS AGO. WHAT I'D LOOK
TOWARD CDSS IF WE COULD GET A
RESPONSE. PREVIOUSLY THE OUTSIDE
CHEN ARE GOING TO TRY. WE CAN
TAG TEAM AND G. M. I WAS JUST
GOING TO SAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER WHITE AND THERE IS QUITE
A BIT OF WORK THAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING IN RESPONSE TO AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE- THERE WERE TWO REPORTS
THAT WERE REQUIRED BY THE
LEGISLATION THE FIRST REPORT IS
ALREADY COMPLETED. THE SECOND
REPORT IS THE ONE THAT MISSED
CENTER THAN MCDONALD'S WAS
REFERRING TO AND WORK HAS
ALREADY BEGUN ON THAT REPORT IN
ADDITION- FOLKS CDSS AND THE
NUMBER OF OUR AGENCY PARTNERS
WITHIN HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- WORK TOGETHER VERY
COLLABORATIVELY AND CONSISTENTLY
AMONGST THE STATE TEAM AS WELL
AS WITH OUR COUNTY PARTNERS.AND
OTHER PARTNERS TO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING TOGETHER TO STRENGTHEN
OUR RESPONSES REGARDING THE
OVERALL SYSTEM OF CARE. SPOTS IN
THE SLED. AND WE DID NOTIFY-
FOLKS THAT THAT REPORT WAS GOING
TO BE LATE IT'S REALLY THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE THAT-
INTERRUPTED THE PROGRESS ON THAT
REPORT AS WELL AS THE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR DATA ACROSS THE
SYSTEM SO THAT WE COULD. PAINT A
COMPREHENSIVE PICTURE OF ANY OF
THE GAPS IN THE SYSTEM OF CARE
SO WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING THAT DATA
MAPPING. AND DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS AMONG THE AGENCIES TO
MORE FULLY PAINT THAT PICTURE
STUFF QUITE A BIT OF WORK IS
HAPPENING AND THAT LEGISLATION
HAS ALREADY MADE AN ENORMOUS
DIFFERENCE. WE ARE ALSO
COMMITTED TO COMPLETING THAT
SECOND REPORT- THAT AND WAS WHY
DO YOU. AND HAS NOT YET BEEN
PROVIDED- MISS WORDS I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE WAS ANYTHING ELSE
YOU WANTED TO ADD. THAT NUMBER
THAT NOTHINGBAD THANK YOU.
FOLLOW UP PLEASE SO WHAT CAN I
FOLLOW UP PLEASE- TO WIN WAS THE
REPORT DO. DURING JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SIR. HI THIS IS
KATHY WE WERE THAT- SPONSORS OF
THE LEGISLATION SO WHICH ONE IS
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY
THANK YOU SO THAT WAS PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC- AND SO. I GUESS
I'M JUST SO NOW WE'RE- MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY TO RECOGNIZE WE
HAD A PANDEMIC WE HAVE WE WERE
IN A PANDEMIC BUT THE REPORT WAS
OVERDUE ON JANUARY BEFORE ANY OF
THIS STARTED. SO. AND I WHAT I
HEARD- WAS IT. YOU'RE STARTING
THE WORK ON THAT THAT'S WHAT I
HEARD- AND STARTING TO WORK
STARTING THE WORK ON A PURPORTED
WAS DUE TO YEARS AGO. THAT
DOESN'T SHOW A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT-
AND THE AND THE EXPECTATION OF
THE LEGISLATION SO- DO WE HAVE A
DATE WHEN THAT REPORT IS GOING
TO BE COMPLETED. IF I CLARIFY
THAT ACTUALLY THE REPORT THAT
WAS DUE JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY IS THE REPORT THAT ONCE
COMPLETED- THE REPORT THE FOLLOW
UP REPORT WAS DUE IN JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY BUT I TAKE YOUR POINT I'M
NOT NONETHELESS THAT WITH THAT
TIMING. I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE
A DATE AT THIS TIME AND I O
JUST WANT TO RE EMPHASIZE THAT
WAS NOT MEETING TO SUGGEST THAT
WE WERE BEGINNING TO WORK ON THE
REPORT WHEN I WAS TRYING TO
EMPHASIZE WAS THAT THERE HAS
BEEN AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT. OF WORK
IN RESPONSE TO THAT LEGISLATION
THAT HAS BEEN MAKING A
DIFFERENCE AND THAT THAT IS- IN
ADDITION TO ACTUALLY BEING ABLE
TO GATHER THAT DATA TO SUBMIT
THAT REPORT SO WE DON'T HAVE A
DATE TO OFFER YOU RIGHT NOW BUT
CERTAINLY WILL GO BACK TO OUR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
WHICH HAS BEEN. COORDINATING
THIS WORK AND- SEE HOW QUICKLY
WE CAN TRY TO GET YOU AN
ESTIMATED TIME FRAME. COULD WE
MAYBE GET THAT ALL THE OTHER
THROUGH THE CHAIR MAYBE WE CAN
ASK FOR A BY THE EIGHT BY EIGHT
SORT BY DATE CERTAIN THAT WOULD
BE. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. JUST
TO FOLLOW UP ON THE- THE
QUESTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD- WHEN WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS YOU STATED
SPECIFICALLY THAT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC WHATEVER ELSE THAT
COMMENT WAS YOU KNOW WE'RE USING
THE PANDEMIC AS AN EXCUSE FOR
NOT- A PROVIDING US THE
INFORMATION AND- IT'S EVEN WORSE
THAT NOW WE DON'T HAVE AN
ESTIMATED DATE AS TO WHEN THIS
IS GOING TO BE- PROVIDED SO WE
STARTED. THE ONE REPORT WAS DUE
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THE OTHER
ONE JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY- AND
HERE WE ARE TWO YEARS LATER AND
YOU STILL DON'T HAVE A DATE AS
TO WHEN THAT'S GOING TO BE
COMPLETED AND I CAN APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE SAYING TO US THAT IT
HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE BUT
WITHOUT A REPORT YOU COULD BE
SAYING ANYTHING AND WE WOULD NOT
DOUBLE THE DIFFERENCE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO-
BASICALLY LET US KNOW THAT THE
WORK IS HAPPENING YOUR WORD. I
DO I APPRECIATE YOU SAYING IT
BUT THE WORD DOES NOT AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE IF YOU'RE TWO YEARS LATE
THAN THE WORDS REALLY DON'T MEAN
ANYTHING BECAUSE NOW WE DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING IN FRONT OF US TO
PROVE THAT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF WORK HAS BEEN DONE AND THE
TREMENDOUS OF WORK HAS BEEN
MAKING A DIFFERENCE. YOU KNOW
THESE ARE. PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH AND YOU KNOW THE
REPORT IS FOR US TO BE BETTER
INFORMED TO HELP YOU THIS IS NOT
JUST THAT WOULD SOME RANDOM
REPORT. THAT WE'RE ASKING THIS
IS TO ASSIST YOU IN WE CANNOT
ASSIST. IF THE REQUIRED REPORTS
ARE NOT BEING- FOLLOW THROUGH
WITH. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WE DO AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE REPORT AND
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE ABOUT THE TIMING OF IT
SUBMITS. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND IN REFERENCE TO THE
SHORT TERM THERAPEUTICAL
PROGRAMS AND SPECIFICALLY TO THE
YOUTH POPULATION- SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE SEEN. OVER
THE YEARS AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO- BRING SOME CLOSURE TO. BUT
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES.
IN ADDRESSING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES- AND
PARTICULARLY WITH THE YOUTH-
DURING OUR SHORT TERM
THERAPEUTICAL PROGRAMS AND I
KNOW- I'M- ALSO. TALKING ABOUT.
AN EPIDEMIC I THINK IS ALSO
GOING ON WITH THE OPIOIDS AND
OVERDOSES WITH FAT AND ALLS. AND
LOOKING TO THESE ADDRESSES SOME
OF THE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
HERE. SO I WANTED TO GET SOME
FEEDBACK ON THAT I KNOW THAT WE
ARE- ENGAGED IN THAT WE DO HAVE
A BILL THAT'S MOVING. BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO HEAR. FROM THOSE ON
THIS PANEL OF WHAT ARE THE
CHALLENGES AND WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE AREAS THAT WE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING. TRYING TO BE MORE
PROACTIVE OR SEEN SOME THINGS OF
THE PAST THAT WE NEED TO BE
ADDRESSING NOW. HAPPY TO ADDRESS
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS-
THERE ARE SOME REAL CHALLENGES.
AROUND THE RATE STRUCTURES
ASSOCIATED WITH SUBSTANCE USE
SERVICES- UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND THE
INTEGRATION OF THOSE SERVICES
AND TEST YOUR GP'S BECOMES VERY
COMPLEX WERE ACTUALLY IN THE
MIDST OF STUDYING MATHS. AT THE
ALLIANCE SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND-
EITHER REGULATORY BARRIERS THAT
EXIST. TO PROVIDING THOSE
SERVICES- GROUP THAT ASKED YEAR
TP STRUCTURE OR IF THERE ARE
OTHER TYPES OF STRUCTURES. AND
PROGRAMS THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT BUT BECAUSE WE KNOW.
THAT IT IS A CRITICAL NEED WHEN
YOU CAN LOOK IT USE THAT ARE.
THAT ARE STRUGGLING THE MOST
WITH SOME OF THESE COMPLEX NEEDS
THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED- IT IT IS
OFTEN. SUBSTANCE USE IS ONE OF
THOSE ISSUES AT LEAST ONE-
FOLLOWED MISTER CHAIR ON ON SOME
OF THE DIFFERENT- FUNDING
AVAILABILITY STATE FEDERAL. IS
SOME OF THE DIFFERENT-
DEFINITIONS THAT ARE BEING USED
TO ENTERING- GETTING RESOURCES
TO THOSE THAT ARE DRASTICALLY IN
NEED OF THE RESOURCE AND AGAIN
SPECIFICALLY WITHIN THE YOUTH
POPULATION.
HER ANSWER. DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SHORT I'M NOT SURE IF IT'S THE
FUNDING STREAMS THEMSELVES I
THINK BUT I WOULD SAY THE GAPS
THAT WE HAVE OBSERVED- ARE ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT. THERE WE'RE TRYING
TO SUPPORT THE YOUTH ACROSS-
MULTIPLE FIRST DOWNS- AND NEED
TO HAVE COMPETENT PEOPLE THAN
THOSE SYSTEMS IN ORDER TO
ATTRACT. LIFE NEEDS OF THE
POPULATION AND INCREASE THE
INTENSITY AND FREQUENCY OF SOME
OF THE SERVICES THAT WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED BUT ALSO JUST
REITERATE THAT WHAT WE'RE
FINDING THEM I THINK THAT THAT'S
REALLY THE VERY INDIVIDUALIZED.
APPROACHES AND DEVELOPMENT OF
THINGS LIKE THE ACT YOUR TEETH
NEEDS OF ONE I'M SOME OF THE
WORK THAT I DETAILS THAT WE'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH BAD UC DAVIS
MIND INSTITUTE AND SOME OF THE
VERY CHILD SPECIFIC- RECRUITMENT
AND SUPPORT OF BAD NEWS BUT WE
THINK THE FACT THAT. AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE REALLY THERE WE'VE
BEEN DOUBLING DOWN ON THAT
APPERT THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE MILLION IN THE COMPLEX CARE
FUNDING EIGHTEEN POINT ONE
MILLION OF THOSE FUNDS ARE
ONGOING FUNDS TO SUPPORT CHILD
BUT THE BIG EMERGENT NEED FAMILY
IN CANADA ARE YOU STARTING TO.
IDENTIFY SOME OF THOSE NEEDS AN
ACCESS FUND FOR THE. SERVICES
AND DEVELOPING INTENDED.
SERVICES SHOP CARE IN HERE TEN
SERVICE THE POPPED CARE. THE
QUALITY SURE HAPPENED FROM OUT
OF TO. INTO SUPPORT OUR REGIONAL
CENTER YOU- IN ADDITION
CONTINUING TO TRY TO DO THAT GAP
ANALYSIS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
COUNTY BY COUNTY IN ORDER TO
ACCESS THE FORTY THREE POINT
THREE MILLION IN OFFICE STARTING
TO BE SOME OF THE THINGS. THAT
MR MURRAY PROJECT TALKING ABOUT-
SOME OF THE CAPACITY THAT WE
NEED TO BUILD AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO SUPPORT YOU WHAT HAS HAPPENS
IF SUPPORTERS PHANTOM OF THE
COLOR KERING. VISIBILITY AND THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN OUR CHILD
WELFARE AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES WITH THEM. UNTIL WE ARE
SEEING SOME OF THAT AT THAT
POINT IN AND SEEN THAT WE HAVE.
WITH YOU KNOW WITH WE ARE THINKS
EXACTLY SOME OF THESE VERY
INDIVIDUALIZED INTENSIVE. MODELS
TO SUPPORT CHILDREN. JUST TO
FOLLOW UP MISTER CHAIR ON THIS
RE. THAT ARE OF AT ONE OF THIS-
SPOKEN I HEARD THAT OUT OF- THE
Q. FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES ONLY
EIGHT COUNTIES HAVE SOME TYPE OF
A- SHELTER. FACILITY FOR THOSE
THAT ARE OUT THERE. SOME
WONDERING- HOW TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THIS TOPIC AND WE
COULD ALSO HAVE A FOLLOW UP
MEETING ON A WRONG TO DIVE INTO
A LITTLE BIT MORE BUT- IF. EIGHT
COUNTIES HAVE SOME TYPE OF A
SHELTER I BELIEVE IT WAS A
SHELTER FACILITY- FOR- YOU THIRD
OF THOSE THAT ARE. IN THIS TYPE
OF A SITUATION- THEN WHO WE
WOULD SEE THAT THERE IS A
DRASTIC NEED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
FOR THESE TYPES OF
IMPLEMENTATIONS- AND THEN WHEN
WE HAVE A FOLLOW UP. DISCUSSION
MISTER CHAIR THROUGH THE CHAIR
WE COULD TALK ABOUT THE-
PROGRAMS IN THE FACILITY SAAB
FOR. HOW LONG PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY GETTING RESOURCES-
SPECIFICALLY- THE STAYS AS IT
TWENTY FOUR HOURS- I KNOW WE
HEARD THAT ON A- DISCUSSION
EARLIER THIS WEEK- IN THIS
COMMITTEE. BUT TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE DEEPER IMPACTS OF
THOSE IN THE RESOURCES ARE THERE
AND MAKING SURE THAT IT'S- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS BEING-
IDENTIFIED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
FOR THOSE THAT WHEN THEY NEED
THE RESOURCES. THEY HAVE PLACES
TO GO AND THAT THERE'S SOME.
AREAS THAT WE GET ON THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REMINISCED AND MAYBE I'LL
I'LL KICK THIS OFF IN A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR SHORTS OR OTHERS WANT
TO ADD. THAT AS WELL- I DO WANT
TO FIRST VERIFY THAT THERE ARE.
SLIGHTLY MORE THAN EIGHT
COUNTIES THERE ARE TWO TYPES OF
SHELTERS BOTH TEMPORARY SHELTERS
AND TRANSITIONAL SHELTERS AND
THERE ARE EIGHT WHO HAVE. A
TEMPORARY PLUS A FEW OTHERS WHO
HAVE TRANSITIONAL BUT I ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT- THE
REMAINING COUNTIES IN MANY
INSTANCES HAVE IDENTIFIED OTHER
SOLUTIONS SUCH AS- EMERGENCY
FAMILY HOME PLACEMENTS- OR
PERHAPS IN SOME INSTANCES MIGHT
BE UTILIZING. AT S. T. R.
TEEPEES IF THEY HAVE CHILDREN
WHO HAVE A HIGH LEVEL LOOK
NEEDED FOR WHOM THEY NEED TO. DO
AN ASSESSMENT AND THEN IDENTIFY
A PLACEMENT SO IT IS- NOT
NECESSARILY AT THE CASE IN ALL
CASES BUT I'M NOT HAVING A
SHELTER MEANS- THAT THOSE
COUNTIES THAT DON'T HAVE A
SOLUTION FOR WHAT TO DO WHEN A
CHILD FIRST COMES INTO CARE. OR
WHEN THERE IS A CHILD WITH
COMPLEX NEEDS WHO IS. IN NEED OF
REPLACEMENT CHANGE. THANK YOU
MISTER FOR BUT- EVEN AT THAT
WITH FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY ARE
STILL A DRASTIC NEED FOR THE
RESOURCES TO BE READILY
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE THAT NEED.
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO. THANK YOU
ON THIS QUESTION- MISS WORKS AND
IS- TROY I BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE
NOT ENTERED THE FOURTH BULLET. I
ON THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED. TO M. PERHAPS I WHICH
PAGE YOU'RE ON OR WHAT. YES PAID
SEVENTEEN UNDER YOUR- THE FOURTH
BULLET ON PAGE SEVENTEEN UNDER
YOUR BOTH OF YOUR NAMES.
REGARD TO THE EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION THAT'S CORRECT. WE DON'T
HAVE A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL- WITH
REGARD TO THE EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION AND- CONTINUE TO-
CONTEND THAT THE ARCADE PROGRAM
WAS REALIGNED- WHAT PART OF
THEIR REALIGNMENT TO THE
COUNTIES IN TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN BUT ALSO DEFERRED TO MY
COLLEAGUE THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WELL NOT TYPICALLY SAYS
WHAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT OF NOT
CONTINUING THE EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION INVESTMENT. SO JUST
RAISED BERMAN FINANCE A I THINK
THAT I'LL NEED TO DIFFERENT
APARTMENT IF THEY WANT TO
SCHEDULE WHAT THOSE RESOURCES
MAY HAVE BEEN USED FOR IN THE
PAST BUT I THINK THE SIMPLE
RESPONSES THE IMPACT IS THAT
THERE JUST ISN'T A PROPOSAL FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION TO AUGMENTS-
ACTIVITIES TAT ARE FUNDED
THROUGH THE TWO THOUSAND AND
REALIGNMENTS. A SPECIFICALLY THE
RFA PROGRAM- BUT BEYOND THAT
WHAT COUNTIES MAY HAVE USED
THOSE RESOURCES FOR- I NEED TO
DEFER TO THAT DEPARTMENT ON HOW
THE FUNDING WAS SET UP. FOR
REIMBURSEMENTS OR CLAIMING AND
SO ON. THANK YOU. YES HELLO SO
DO YOU HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT.
THE COUNTY HAVE REPORTED THAT
THE EIGHTY FIVE MILLION WHICH
USED PRIMARILY FOR THAT REPORT
ASSEMBLY APPROVE ALL. YEAH IF I
MIGHT THIS IS KATHY THUNDERING
THROUGH THE PDA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO- AS A CONNECTION AND- WE
HAVE WHAT'S CALLED A TRUE UP
PROCESS THAT WE'VE UNDERTAKEN
WITH. OF THE ADMINISTRATION AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND CFS
INVOLVEMENT TO LOOK AT ALL
ASPECTS OF THE CONTINUE OF CARE
REFORM REMEMBER THAT OUR
PROPOSITION THIRTY ESSENTIALLY
SEVENTH THAT IN A REAL LINE
PROGRAM WHICH CHILD WELFARE IS
PART OF THE TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT. OF IF THERE IS A
NEW REQUIREMENT THAT'S AN ACTIVE
IN STATE LAW FOLLOWING THE
ENACTMENT OF PROP THIRTY AT
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT THAT
OFTEN LEFT THAT IS FUNDED
COUNTIES ARE ESSENTIALLY THE
REMEDY IS COUNTIES DON'T HAVE TO
DO IT- WHICH IS NOT A GREAT
REMEDY IN THIS CASE BECAUSE
THERE IS- UNFORTUNATE THERE'S NO
NOTHING TO FALL BACK ON ME THE
ONLY WAY. THAT WE CAN IMPROVE
OUR HOME IS TO USE THE RFA
PROCESS THE OLD STRUCTURE WAS
STRIPPED OUT OF THE LAW AS PART
OF THAT COULD YOU TO CARE REFORM
SO THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE THE TRUTH
PROCESS AND THAT SPENDING THAT
IS SPECIFIC TO AREN'T THEY
ACTIVITIES. IS COUNTED AS PART
OF THAT AND THAT'S WHY WE KNOW
THAT COUNTIES ARE SPENDING A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
OVER AND ABOVE WHAT WAS INCLUDED
IN TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
WHICH AT THE TIME WAS JUST A FEW
COUNTIES PARTICIPATING IN A
PILOT IT WASN'T A MANDATE IT
WASN'T STATEWIDE WITH THE PILOT.
AND SO A FEW COUNTIES HAD SOME
MONEY INCLUDED BUT IT WASN'T
FULL SCALE IN THOSE COUNTIES AND
IT CERTAINLY WASN'T FIFTY EIGHT
AND SO- THIS IS AN AREA OF AS
YOU CAN TELL ALL ONGOING
DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN. US IN A
PDA- VENTURE TO SAY COUNTIES IN
GENERAL ON THIS POINT- AS WELL
AT AND THE ADMINISTRATION- BUT
GIVEN THAT- IT WAS NOT A
STATEWIDE MANDATE UNTIL THE T.
C. R. LEGISLATION WHICH IS WELL
AFTER. TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
ON WE FEEL STRONGLY THAT A WE
KNOW HOW MY IT IS. WE KNOW THAT
IT'S MY THAN A ONE. AND WE FEEL
THAT IT'S BE FUNDED. UNDER PROP.
IT DIDN'T GET. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY CLARIFY THAT. THANKS
FOR THE CLARIFICATION I
APPRECIATED AND I HAVE JUST FOR
FUTURE I'M I KNOW THAT- WE GET-
THESE THE AGENDAS PRIOR TO ALONG
WITH THE QUESTION SO IF YOU KNOW
OF. WE COME HERE WITH THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT THOSE
QUESTIONS ARE ANSWERED IT NOT
SKIPPED OVER SO I'D APPRECIATE
IT THAT FROM NOW ON THAT- ALL OF
THE QUESTIONS THERE ARE ON THE
AGENDA WILL BE ANSWERED. THANK
YOU WITH THAT I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE CHAIR TO BEGIN A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS I'M I'M
GONNA PICK UP WITH WHERE THE
CONVERSATION IS AND FOLLOW UP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE IT REALLY
IS ABOUT THE TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT. THAT I'D
LIKE TO FIGURE OUT IF YOU CAN
PLEASE COMPARE THE COSTS OF R.
F. A. AND THE EXTENT OF ITS
IMPLEMENTATION. AT THE TIME OF
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT. AND
THEN THE COST AND EXTENT OF
IMPLEMENTATION. I AM HOPING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN
PLEASE WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. TO PROVIDE
AT THIS COMPARISON IN WRITING TO
US SO THAT WE CAN WORK TOWARDS
THAT TRUE UP WHICH WAS
MENTIONED. MORE TO FOLLOW AFTER
MY- QUESTIONS ON THIS PANEL BUT
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS ABLE
TO. RETURN IN WRITING THAT
INFORMATION TO US. AGAIN JUST
PRESCRIBE FINANCE THE- I THINK
MAYBE FIRST WE CAN PROVIDE A FEW
CLARIFYING COMMENTS ON.ON THIS
IS THE- AND THE REAL ON THE
RESOURCE AND THE APPROVAL AND
REALIGNMENT AND HOW FUNDING. V.
MAYBE LOOK BACK ON A REAL
QUICKLY ON THE PROCESS IS NOT
NECESSARILY A NEW PROCESS
REQUIRED ACCOUNTING WHAT THE- A
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS
WITH THIS BECOMING A UNIFIED
PROCESS. FOR APPROVING A FOSTER
HOME OR FOSTER FAMILY THERE USED
TO BE THREE PROCESSES ONE FOR
LICENSING FOSTER FAMILY HOMES
ONE FOR APPROVING RELATIVE NON
RELATIVE EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS
AS FOSTER PROVIDERS. AND ANOTHER
FOR PROVING A DOCTOR FOUND IS.
THE RESOURCE MAINLY APPROVAL I
WAS INCLUDED IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN REALIGNMENTS AS A UNIFIED
PROCESS IT ORIGINALLY IT STARTED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AS PILOT
PROGRAMS BUT IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. REALIGNMENT IS INCLUDED
AS A PARTICIPATING COUNTIES WITH
AN EXPECTATION THAT IT WOULD BE.
IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE BY
COUNTIES BY TWENTY FOURTEEN I
BELIEVE IT'S WHAT IT WHAT SO.
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM. HAS
BEEN INCLUDED- THROUGH
REALIGNMENTS AGAIN THE IDEA WAS
TO STREAMLINE IT SO WHEN HAVE A
DUPLICATED PROCESS OF THOSE
OTHER PROCESSES FOR DO YOU
RENOUNCE. ARMED WITH REGARDS TO
THE REQUEST FOR A COMPARISON OF
FUNDING- WELL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON ISSUES SUCH AS THIS AND SOME
OF THE OTHER COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS LISTED IN THE AGENDA.
HOWEVER WE WOULD. IN THE MEAN
REVISION AND WE MAY NOT HAVE
CAPACITY DURING THIS TIME TO
ENGAGE IN THESE DISCUSSIONS. ARE
ONCE THE MAY REVISION IS
RELEASED- THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON ANY LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISION. THANK LET ME
THEN JUST START THIS HAS BEEN A
MULTI YEAR PROCESS AND THIS IS
BEEN AN AREA OF CONTENTION
BETWEEN THE STATE AND COUNTIES.
AND AS THIS APPEARS TO BE WHAT
WAS A PILOT AND- PARTIAL
IMPLEMENTATION BY TWENTY ELEVEN
WITH THE EXPECTATION OF
COMPLETION. BY TWENTY FOURTEEN
WE HEARD TODAY THAT OUR PHASE
NOT FULLY IMPLEMENTED ACROSS THE
STATE. THAT I'D LIKE TO REALLY.
INSIST THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HELPS US TO UNDERSTAND-
THIS RE ALIGNMENT AS I BELIEVE
IT WILL ALLOW U TO MAKE SURE
WERE APPROPRIATELY RESOURCING
AND- UP PROVIDING FOR A RESOURCE
FAMILIES- I WOULD I WOULD SIMPLY
POINT. TOWARDS THE LEGISLATORS
INSISTENCE ON THIS FUNDING OVER
THE PAST NUMBER OF YEARS AS A
SIGN OF OUR WILLINGNESS AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS FUNDING FOR
US. AND BELIEVE THAT WOULD IT
WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR US TO TRUE
UP THIS GOING FORWARD. I'D LIKE
TO- I WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS AGAIN
AFTER QUESTIONS I WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO MISFORTUNE MYSTERY IF I
CAN. LIKE TOUGH- FOCUS ON FAMILY
FINDING- CURRENTLY WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL THERE
ARE THERE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WHEN WE- FEDERALLY
MATCH THAT THAT TURNS INTO ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION. WHAT EFFECTS
ARE REALLY EXPECTED FROM THIS
PROPOSAL FOR FAMILY FINDING HOW
DOES THIS INVESTMENT COMPARE AND
CONTRAST WITH WHAT THE STATE HAS
DONE IN PRIOR BUDGETS- WITH
PEPPERS AS AN EXAMPLE. TO HELP
PROVIDE A SCOPE OF HOW THIS
FUNDING IS IN COMPARISON TO
OTHER FUNDING WE'VE DONE IN THE
SYSTEM. DEPUTY DIRECTOR SHORT-
THAT. THE PURPOSE OF THE FUNDING
IS REALLY TO WORK WITH THAT.
YEAH BALLAGE OUR CONTRACT FOR
TRAINING COACHING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO COUNTIES TO
DEVELOP SORT OF AN INTENSIVE
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE ABOUT THE TRAUMA
INFORMED TO TURN UP AND BAT WITH
THE END. THEIR PRACTICE MODEL
BUT IT'S REALLY ABOUT TRAINING
AND COACHING- IN ORDER TO ENABLE
THE COUNTY BOARD OF REFINED
THEIR FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
APPROACHES I SPOKE EARLIER ABOUT
SOME OF THE STRATEGIES. OF THE
BEAM I'M HAVE SIX BATHROOMS SO
IT WOULD. BE AN VETTING FROM
OTHERS. STRATEGY AROUND BETULA
PERMAN IN FAMILIES THAT THE
RECRUIT AND FATHERING. KAYPRO IT
A WAY THAT ALLOWS COUNTY TO-
TAKE THAT TRAINING AND THE
COACHING THE TECHNICAL EXPENSE
TO REFINE THEIR MODELS. IT'S
REALLY A DIFFERENT PURPOSE AND
THE FUNDS THAT MISS TENDERLY
MCDONALD OKAY EARLIER BETTER
ADEQUATE OR IF IT'S AFFECTED
THAT. DOLLARS WHICH WAS OR YOU
KNOW THE ACTUAL WITH WHICH WHICH
WAS INTENDED AT THE START OF THE
FIFTY YARD TO ALLOW COUNTIES IF
YOU. HAVE SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
FOR- REALLY FAMILY SPECIFIC
RECRUITMENT LIKE I LIKE I SAID
YOU KNOW WE DO HAPPEN INVESTMENT
IN SUPPORT FOR COUNTIES. THAT
THEY CAN HAPPEN TO YOU FOR THAT
FAMILY BASED RECRUITMENT PLUS
THAT FUNDING IS INTENDED TO
IMPACT THIRD ABOUT PRACTICE
MODEL WITHIN THE COUNTIES IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT MARK
EXCEPTIONALLY. AND WE'VE ALSO
HAD OTHER SUPPORT FOR THE ONE
THAT HAD SLOWEDTO THE COUNTIES-
IN THE INTERVENING YEARS MAKE
SURE THAT OUR PRINTER ROUGHLY
PROVIDING SUPPORT CONSERVE IT
TENDS TO YOU IN THE FAMILY
PLANNING LIKE THE ACRYLIC CARE
GET BURKE. PROGRAM IN THE
EMERGENCY CHARACTER PROGRAM
THIRD OF FUNDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO IMMEDIATELY
SUPPORT THAT RELATIVE OR FINDING
AND ROBUSTLY SUPPORT THEM SO
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF **** OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS THAT HAVE.
ENABLED COUNTIES TO WORK FULLY
NOT JUST FINE I GREW UP IN A
FINGERLING MCCONNELL THE FINDING
IS NOT ENOUGH WE ALSOHAVE TO
REALLY ENGAGE IN THE COURT THAT
LATE FROM THERE HAVE BEEN
ONGOING INVESTMENT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ABLE TO DO THAT ENGAGEMENT. AND SUPPORT. WHAT I'M GONNA UP
ON WHAT SO. MCDONALD SET UP
FIFTH AND THE- NEED FOR A TO
READ. THE IT'S NOT ONE AND DONE.
THAT I WOULD TO UNDER. AGAIN
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION HOW
MIGHT A REINVESTMENT INTO
FIBERS. ASSIST WITH THE EFFORTS
ALREADY UNDERWAY REGARDING
LOCATING AND SUPPORTING FAMILY
BASED CARE.
EITHER FOR JAN TROYER OR MISH
WART. CAN YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION HOW THE HOW THE FIFTY
DOLLARS FROM I'M SORRY JUST I
THINK I MESSED OKAY THAT'S A BIG
QUESTION I'M PENALIZED ON.
REINVESTMENT WHAT AFFECT WE
BELIEVE THAT FOR PERSONAL ORDERS
WOULD HAVE AND WOULD ASSIST US
WITH OUR EFFORTS WHICH ARE
ALREADY UNDER WAY REGARDING
LOCATING AND SUPPORTING FAMILY
BASED CARE. ARE WE ONE AND DONE
OR DOES THIS NEED TO CONTINUE
REPLENISHING. YEAH WE SHAPE THE
QUESTION AND WE SEE THAT THAT'S
THE FIRST FUNDING IF THE
BEGINNING OF CC ARE IN AN EFFORT
TO SEE PRACTICES THAT THE
COUNTIES THAT WE ASSUMED THAT
THEY WOULD THEN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE UNDER
REALIGNMENT- AND OUR PROPOSAL
THIS YEAR REALLY RELATES TO THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING AND SUPPORT THAT'S
PROVIDED THROUGH THE FUNDING
THAT THE CHAIR. REFERENCED
EARLIER- I DO AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT- THE COUNTIES HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY BELIEVE
THERE WOULD BE VALUE TO CONTINUE
AND NOT FUNDING IT'S JUST NOT
CURRENTLY- SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
WAS THERE ARE ARCHITECT WITH
WATSON. I ANTICIPATE HEARING
MORE FROM MY OFFICE ON THIS
FRONT I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO-
CANS IF I CAN- CHILD ADOLESCENTS
NEED SURVEY THAT WAS REFERENCES
REFERENCED EARLIER. WHAT ARE
CONCRETE GOALS FOR CONSISTENT
AND UNIFORM REPORTING COMING
FROM THE CAMPUS DATA. WHEN WILL
WE FINALLY BE ABLE TO ASSESS TO
MUCH OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS AND TRENDS. FROM CANS DATA
AN AGGREGATED STATE LEVEL. WE
HAVE ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES DO YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO THE PWF CARE IT'S
LIVE CAMS COOL BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT THEY AREN'T ALL USING THAT
TOOL IN ORDER TO COLLECT THEIR
KING AND- PAID AND ARE DIFFERENT
REASONS FOR THAT. SOME COUNTY
IT'S THEIR LOCAL AGREEMENTS WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE TO YOUR
POINT A TEAR ARAMBULA THEY NEED
HAVE A DIFFERENT. AGENCY LEADING
AND LEADING IN COMPLETION OF THE
CAMPAIGN ON THAT DATE IT GETS
ENTERED INTO THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ELECTRONIC RECORD AND NOT
NECESSARILY AND HEAT THAT KERRY
FLIGHT CAMP TOOL AND THAT MNY
OF THE CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES
ARE UTILIZING- AND WE ALSO HAVE
COUNTIES THAT ARE USE. THAT ARE
CONTRACTING WITH PROVIDERS IN
ORDER TO COMPLETE THE KANSEN
THOSE PROVIDERS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT CARE LIGHT CAN'T
TRAVEL SO WE ARE WORKING TO
DEVELOP A SOLUTION- INTERN IN.
IN ORDER TO ENABLE US TO-
CAPTURE ALL. OF THE COUNTY THAT-
THE THAT WE CAN START MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE A MORE COMPLETE
PICTURE OF THE GOING ON WITH
PEOPLE. THAT ALL. HAVE
IMPLEMENTED CAN'T ARE UTILIZING
THE CANS THAT YOU DON'T SEE IT
CONSISTENTLY IN THE DATA THAT WE
ARE COLLECTING ART- WHAT ACCESS
THEM IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY THAT
TRENDS. THAT YOU HAVE AND I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT THAT WE NEED
TO DEVELOP THAT SOLUTION AND ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING TO DO THAT. I
WOULD ADD ANOTHER LAYER WHICH IS
I BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO HAVE THE DATA- BOTH
CONSISTENT AND UNIFORM FOR CANS.
BUT HOW CAN WE AS THE DEPARTMENT
AND STATE ENSURE THAT WE ARE
MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
COME FROM THE FF'S PSA. BURKE
CONGREGATE CARE PLACEMENTS
SPECIFICALLY THAT A FULL CANS
ASSESSMENT INCLUDING THE TRAUMA
MODULE IS COMPLETED AS PART OF
THE QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS.
ASSESSMENT WHICH IS REQUIRED
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS. OF AN S. T.
R. T. P. PLACEMENT IF WE ARE NOT
REQUIRING. THAT THEY USE CANS
AND SUBMIT THAT INFORMATION FROM
US HOW ARE WE GONNA VERIFIED TO.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO
WHAT'S REQUIRED IN TERMS OF THAT
VERIFICATION CODE THAT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS THAT THERE WAS AN
ATTACHMENT BY THE QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUAL AND WE ARE. OPTING TO
USE THE CANCEL AND NOT
ASSESSMENT AND BELIEVE THAT THAT
IS BEING DONE IN THE DIFFERENT
Q. I ASSESSMENT SOME NOT ALL WE
HAVE NOT HEARD THAN ANY OF THE
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
UTILIZING. THAT TOOL AND ALSO
BEEN WORKING WITH THAT- CHILD
AND FAMILY TEAM IN ORDER TO GET.
THE COMPLETE INFORMATION THAT IS
NECESSARY IN MAKING THOSE
DETERMINATIONS AND THEN ALSO WE
NEED TO REPORT BACK. TIME TO
THAT BAD ON THAT THAT ASSESSMENT
THAT COMPLETED BY OUR QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS TO THAT COURT AND
THE COURT NEEDS TO MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION- ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THEY AGREED BUT THE
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAPPEN AND EITHER APPROVE OR
DISAPPROVE OF THE PLACEMENT SAID
THAT. ELEMENTS THAT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT TO THE-
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SPECIFIC TO
THE QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL
ASSESSMENT BEING DONE ON THE
COURT APPROVING THE CREEPING AT. BEST PLACEMENT- WE ARE ABLE TO
CAP. THAT THAT WORK IS BEING.
AND IT BEING GOOD BE USED CAN'T
. I'D LIKE TO THEM FOLLOW UP AS
THERE IS- SIGNIFICANT VARIATION
THAT OCCURS AMONG THE COUNTIES
THAT I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS STATE IS REACTING TO THAT.
VARIATION I AM TRULY APPRECIATE
THE GOALS OF C. C. R. REFORM AND
FOR MANY OF US WE WOULD. LIKE TO
ALREADY BE THERE BUT WHAT ABOUT
THOSE COUNTIES THAT SEEM TO BE.
DRAGGING THEIR FEET AND- ARE NOT
IMPLEMENTING MUCH OF THE CHANGES
THAT WE ARE WORKING ON HERE AT
THE STATE LEVEL- WHAT'S THE
STATE'S REACTION TO THAT. TWO
PART FOUR WE HAVE BEEN OFFERING-
I'M GOING IN ROBUST TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT TO
COUNTIES IN COLLABORATION WITH
OUR JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE.
SERVICES PARTNER IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE VERY INTENSIVE TRAINING
WITH REGARD TO THE QUEUE I
REQUIREMENTS FORGET HOW THAT
ASSESSMENT. NEEDS TO OCCUR AND
THEN WORK WITH THAT CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAM I'M IN THE
SUBMISSION OF THE INFORMATION
THAT'S REQUIRED TO THE COURT SO
WE'VE HAD ONGOING TRAINING-
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CALLS THAT
ARE OFFERED ON IT TWICE A MONTH
BASIS AND POSTING ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS. ON OUR
WEBSITE IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT COUNTIES HAVE THE MOST UP
TO DATE INFORMATION POSSIBLE AND
SUPPORT WE ALSO DO INDIVIDUAL TA
CALLED- AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS THE COUNTIES
IN OUR- HEALTHCARE PARTNERS ARE
PROBATION PARTNERS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- PARTNERS IN ORDER TO
MEET. REGULARLY- AND- IT ADDED
TERM WHAT ASPECTS OF FAMILY
FIRST ARTICLE VERY THAT LEVEL
AND ADDRESS THOSE. BUT WE DO
HAVE THIRD OF MORE. MATH BY
WHICH GATHERED. INFORMATION AND
GETTING INFORMATION BACK TO THE
FEEL OF AN IMPROVING AND
ENHANCING OUR TRAINING- I WILL
ASK THREE FINAL QUESTIONS MY
NEXT QUESTION IS FROM THE
SANDERLING MCDONALD- WE HEARD
ABOUT THE SS I APPEALS PROCESS
AND- I'M HOPING YOU CAN COMMENT
ON WHETHER OR NOT THOSE SAME
SOCIAL WORKERS CAN. MAKE SIMILAR
INQUIRIES FOR OTHER STATE SAFETY
NET PROGRAM SUCH AS CALFRESH FOR
MEDIC CAL- AND IF SO WITHOUT
REQUIRING QUICK INCREASED
RESOURCE IN JUST WANT TO GET
YOUR OPINION ON THAT. THAT'S A
REALLY GREAT QUESTION- SHERRIN
I- I MEAN EMPIRICALLY YES OF
COURSE THEY COULD DO THAT WORK I
WOULD SAY. FOLLOWING UP TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT
WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA- COUPLE
THOUGHTS ON THAT IS THAT- AS WE
THINK ABOUT YOUTH TRANSITIONING
INTO EXTENDED FOSTER CARE WE
KNOW THAT THEY DO CONTINUE TO
HAVE SOCIAL WORK SUPPORT. AND SO
SOME OF THAT MAY BE DONE IN THAT
WAY ALREADY BUT I WOULD SAY WE
KNOW THAT THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST IN ALL IN
ALL COUNTIES BUT VERY GREATLY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
RESOURCES. AT THEIR DISPOSAL
BOTH THE FUNDING BUT ALSO WHAT
KINDS OF ORGANIZATIONS COMPANIES
ARE LOCATED IN THOSE COUNTIES
YOU MAY HAVE A LARGE FORTUNE
FIVE HUNDRED COMPANY AND A
LARGER COUNTY THAT CAN DONATE-
COMPUTERS OR DONATE- GIFT CARDS.
INTENDED TO USE AND DO SO AS A
MATTER OF COURSE AND THE SMALLER
COUNTY YOU JUST MAY NOT HAVE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND SO- WHAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER TIME IS. A GREAT
DIFFERENCE IN BOTH THE RESOURCES
BUT ALSO THE TYPES OF SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS THAT YOU GET FROM
THESE PROGRAMS DEPENDING ON
WHERE THEY LIVE. AND SO PART OF
THE CONVERSATION AND ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED I THINK
IS TO LOOK AT THAT PROGRAM WHICH
WERE SUGGESTING REALLY NEEDS TO
BE DONE AT THIS POINT- THE
FAMILY FIRST- PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT HAS A PROVISION AND
THAT THAT MAKES SOME CHANGES. TO
THE IOP PROGRAM WHICH HAS SOME
FEDERAL FUNDING AND WE THINK
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE MODEL AND SEE WHAT
WE COULD DO TO BETTER SUPPORT
YOUTH AS THEY'RE TRANSITIONING-
THAT THE FACT THAT WERE
PARTNERING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FULLY ON. IN ADDITION TO LOOKING
AT HOW WE CAN GET A MORE HOUSING
RESOURCES. TO ARGUE WITH THE
TRANSITIONAL HOW. IS SO A I
COULD PIECE WE KNOW. AND HAVE
THIS AND COMMITTEE- IN THE PAST
HOW ARE YOU REALLY STRUGGLE TO
STAY HOW IS THEY THEY HAVE A LOT
OF HOUSING AND SECURITY AND SO I
THINK ALL OF THOSE PROGRAMS TO
MERE OTHER PIECE. AND THAT THERE
ARE SOME WAYS THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO THINK ABOUT ALL THE
BEST WAY TO SUPPORT OUR YOUTH
AND WORK WITH THEM AS THEY ARE
MOVING. IDEALLY TOWARD EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE UP TO AGE TWENTY ONE
BUT SOME TO DROP OFF AT AGE
EIGHTEEN THEY DON'T UNDER
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE AND THEN
AGAIN AT AGE TWENTY ONE.
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE AND SO WITH
A COUPLE DIFFERENT POINTS IN
TIME WHERE BENEFITS I ADVOCACY
PROBABLY YOU KNOW KIND OF CAN
DOVETAIL WITH SOME OF THESE
OTHER EFFORTS AS LONG AND HAPPY
TO CONTINUE ENGAGING WITH YOU.
AND OF COURSE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON. THE
YOU I LOOK FORWARD THOSE CON.
I'D LIKE TO NOW TURN THE PAGE
TWENTY TWO WITHIN THE AGENDA- I
WILL BEGIN WITH THE LEVEL OF
CARE PROTOCOL TOOL. I I'D LIKE
TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION THIS
IS REFERENCED IN THE AGENDA.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS THINKING
ABOUT SOMEHOW COMBINING THE
LEVEL OF CARE TOOL. WITH THE
CANS SO THAT THERE COULD BE MORE
COHESION IN TRACKING. AND DATA
REPORTING HOPING YOU COULD
COMMENT ON THAT. WE ARE
CONTINUING TO ASSESS THE LEVEL
OF CARE PROTOCOL AND CONTINUING
TO EVALUATE WHETHER OTHER TOOLS
LIKE BASECAMP COULD SUPPORT THAT
LEVEL OF CARE DETERMINATION AND
WE HAVE HAD. THE LEVEL OF CARE
IMPLEMENTED DEFENSE APRIL FIRST
OF LAST YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
AND IT IS OCCURRING NOW AND ALL
OF OUR NEW PLACEMENTS OR ANYTIME
THERE'S A PLACEMENT CHANGE AND
WE HAVE BEEN SEEING AN UPTICK.
IN THE NUMBER OF YEARS THAT ARE
AT STAFF- INTO LEVELS TWO THREE
AND FOUR AS WELL AS IN CAT THE
I. S. AT THE LEVEL BUT
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT- WHETHER OR
NOT THEY CAN TOOL COULD OPT. AT
THE PORT THAT DETERMINATION.
FOLLOWING ON THAT SO PAGE PAGE
TWENTY TWO AT THE BOTTOM.
REGARDING S. T. R. T. P.
TRANSITIONS- FROM THE DATA THAT
WE HAVE WE CAN SEE THAT THERE
ARE CURRENTLY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE UNLICENSED
FACILITIES. WHAT ARE THE
PATTERNS WERE SEEING RELATED TO
THIS ACROSS THE STATE AND- IS
THERE A MAP PERHAPS FOR US TO
LOOK AT. ARE THE COUNTY'S
EQUIPPED TO IDENTIFY AND SUPPORT
THE FACILITIES THAT HAVEN'T YET.
RECEIVED THESE MENTAL HEALTH
APPROVALS AND- I I'D LIKE TO
JUST POINTS TO THE COUNTY STRIKE
TEAMS THAT- HELPS TO INTERVENE
AND SUPPORT SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITIONS EARLY ON IN THE
PANDEMIC AS AN EXAMPLE AND-
WONDERING IF THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS NOTICED A PATTERN. WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK- PROVIDERS
ARE GIVEN TIME TO OBTAIN THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH APPROVAL PROGRAM
UP TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS- BUT WE
KNOW THAT PROVIDERS MAY NOT HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT BILL ABILITY OF
ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT FOR
THAT SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. WHAT THE HECK COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN- AND COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS MAY NOT HAVE
A CURRENT REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL
OPENER. NINETEEN CONTRACT WITH A
PROVIDER WHICH WOULD PREVENT
THAT PROVIDER FROM IT. TEAM
COMPARED MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM
APPROVAL- THE PREDATORS YOU
COULD STILL CONTACT WITH OTHER
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS BUT
EACH INDIVIDUAL CONTRACT TAKES
TIME TO EXECUTE. YEAH WE ARE
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- AND SUPPORT TO
PROVIDERS INVOLVING- THEIR
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
THEM TO IN THE TIMELY APPROVAL.
JUST TO CLARIFY THAT THE
COMPUTER ITSELF OUR LIFE AND
SPENDING BUT THEY ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO GET THE FINAL
HEALTH. PLAN APPROVAL AND SO IT
THAT- THAT THE NUMBER THAT YOU
CITED AS THE NUMBER OF OUR
ACTIVITIES THAT DON'T YET HAVE.
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH PLAN
APPROVAL. WE WILL FOLLOW WITH
THE I. WOULD WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'VE HAD ON THIS PANEL. I
WOULD NOW LIKE TO KINDLY ASK
THAT WE HAVE A MEETING CONVENES
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE STAFF. LMAO
THE ADMINISTRATION SPECIFICALLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN COORDINATION WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS.
ASSOCIATION SO THAT WE CAN WALK
THROUGH THE REQUEST THAT ARE
BEING MADE WITHIN THE C. W.D. A
PROPOSAL LIST. OF C. C. R.
INVESTMENT PACKAGES. THE PURPOSE
OF THE MEETING WOULD BE
PRINCIPALLY FIRST TO CLARIFY
WHETHER EACH INDIVIDUAL PROPOSAL
IS WORKLOAD BUDGET RELATED. I II
IT'S A PROPOSAL THAT ARGUABLY
PERMITS A COUNTY TO COMPLY WITH
THE CURRENT STATE REQUIREMENTS
AND THAT IDENTIFIES A GAP IN
RESOURCES BETWEEN WHAT IS
PROVIDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND WHAT IS REQUIRED BY
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT THE
ACTIVITIES PURSER PURSUANT TO
CURRENT LAW. OR IF THE PROPOSAL
IS GENUINELY A NEW POLICY
DISCUSSION THAT'S NOT CURRENTLY
NEEDED BY CURRENT LAW. AND THAT
SECOND. EXAMINES A COMPARISON OF
THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS AND
COSTS OF RFA AT THE TOP OF THE
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT AND
WHAT ARE A FAKE COSTS ARE NOW.
PURSUANT TO THE TRUE UP
METHODOLOGY ENACTED SINCE
REALIGNMENT. I'D LIKE TO REQUEST
THE ASSISTANCE OF THE L. A. O.
AND WE'RE GONNA AND FACILITATE.
MEETING WORKING WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND MY STAFF. I'D
LIKE TO BE PERSONALLY INVOLVED
IN THIS CONVERSATION. AT THIS
MEETING AND I PLAN TO REACH OUT
TO MY COLLEAGUES IN THE- AND BY
THEM AS WELL. I REQUEST THAT
MEETING TAKE PLACE AS SOON AS
PRACTICAL PRACTICAL GOAL FOR ALL
PARTIES BUT NO LATER THAN APRIL
FIFTH PLEASE. IS THE
ADMINISTRATION AMENABLE TO THIS
REQUEST. BEST NUMBER IS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I GET
EVERYDAY WE CANNOT COMMIT TO
HAVING THESE DISCUSSIONS PRIOR
TO RELEASE THE MAY REVISION BUT
WE LOOK FOR PROVIDING ASSISTANCE
WHERE WE CAN AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO
DETERMINE HOW WE'RE ABLE TO
BETTER ASSIST. I LOOK FORWARD
AND HOPE THAT WE WILL STOP
KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD
AND BE ABLE TO ANSWER MANY OF
THE- TOUGH QUESTIONS THAT ARE
FACING US SO THAT WE CAN.
APPROPRIATELY HAVE THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY
HERE IN THE SUB COMMITTEE. AND
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SIT DOWN WITH
THE WTA AND THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAFF. TO HELP TO RESOLVE THESE
ISSUES GOING FORWARD. WITH THAT
I WILL THANK ALL OF THE PANEL
FOR ISSUE TO AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON. TO ISSUE THREE. WHERE
WE WILL HAVE SIX TOTAL
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL FOR
ISSUE THREE-I BELIEVE THAT
JESSICA HOSPITAL THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF CHILD WELFARE WITH
CHILDREN NOW NEEDS TO GO FIRST.
IN THIS PANEL AND WOULD LIKE TO
CREATE THAT SPACE- SO IF WE CAN
PLEASE BEGIN WITH MISS HASPEL
FOLLOWED BY- ENTRY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR IN SUB COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS FAMILY FIRST PART ONE
IMPLEMENTATION TODAY. I'M JUST
GONNA HASPEL ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
OF CHILD WELFARE POLICY BUT
CHILDREN AND- CHILDREN'S
RESEARCH POLICY AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION. FOCUSED ON
BUILDING POWER FOR KIDS ZERO TO
TWENTY SIX CROSS EDUCATION HOW
IN CHILD WELFARE. IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR GENDER QUESTIONS I PLAN TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR CHALLENGES THAT
ARE. OCCURRING ONE-
IMPLEMENTATION PLANNING AS WELL
AS SOME RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
STEPS THE STATE CAN TAKE TO HELP
ENSURE FAMILIES RECEIVE
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE PREVENTION
SERVICES. I THE FIRST CHALLENGE
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IS JUST THE
NEED FOR CLEAR AND DETAILED
GUIDANCE ON IMPLEMENTING PART
ONE WITHIN THAT CONTEXT OF
CALIFORNIA'S BROADER PREVENTION
ASIAN IN THE ALLOWABLE USES OF
THE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE BLOCK GRANT FUNDING- ONCE
RELEASED WE HOPE. THAT THE
UPCOMING CDSS ALL COUNTY LETTER
THAT'S FOCUSED ON THE STATE PARK
RAMP FUNDING AND THE OPT IN
PROCESS. I WILL PROVIDE COUNTIES
WITH THE INITIAL GUIDANCE THEY
NEED TO BEGIN MOVING FORWARD. WE
WILL HOWEVER EXPECT THAT THERE
BE AN ANGLE WE NEED FOR.
GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS A CLEAR
PROCESS FOR ENGAGING
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING ADVOCATES
IN THOSE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE.
IN DEVELOPING ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE TOOL KITS AND
AMENDMENTS TO THE STATE'S FIVE
YEAR PREVENTION PLAN. IMITATIONS
OF WHAT SERVICES ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL NINETEEN UNDER PART
ONE REPRESENT A SECOND
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGE.
MOREOVER CALIFORNIA'S INITIAL
FIVE YEAR STATE PREVENTION PLAN
THAT WAS SUBMITTED FOR FEDERAL
APPROVAL IN AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. FURTHER LIMITS WHAT
SERVICES WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL MATCHING IN CALIFORNIA
IN THE NEAR TERM. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY FORTY ONE PROGRAMS
RATED AS PROMISING SUPPORTED OR
WELL SUPPORTED BY THE FEDERAL
TITLE FOR EACH PREVENTION
SERVICES CLEARINGHOUSE IN THEIR
ACOSTA I WOULD YOU PULL FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING. CALIFORNIA'S
ADDITIONAL FIVE YEAR PLAN
INCLUDES FIVE PROGRAMS THAT WERE
RATED WELL SUPPORTED AT THE TIME
OF THE PLANTS MISSION. WE
RECOGNIZE THESE PROGRAMS ARE
CHOSEN HI AS THE FEDERAL
EVALUATION REQUIREMENT CAN BE
WAIVED FOR WELL SUPPORTED
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE REVISED OUR MODEL FIDELITY
TOOLS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THEM. BUT FURTHER NARROWING THE
ARRAY OF SERVICES THAT MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE FOR FEDERAL CLEANING
DOES POSE I'M GOING
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES. TO
ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF KEEPING
CHILDREN IN YOUTH SAFELY WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND ADDRESS
DISPARITIES WE MUST ENSURE THAT
FAMILIES ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
SERVICES THEY NEED TO MEET THEIR
IDENTIFIED NEEDS. EVEN IF NOT
ALL SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE FOR
FEDERAL I NEED. WE WERE PLEASED
TO SEE THE STATE'S TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
PART ONE IN BROADER PREVENTION
SERVICES IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
THE STATE BLOCK GRANT FUNDING
CAN AND SHOULD BE USED TO BUILD
SERVICE GAPS ESPECIALLY GAPS IN
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE SERVICES.
HOWEVER THE ONLY FIRST PLANNING
IS THAT TIME STILL BEING VIEWED
IN A SILENT WAY WITH A FOCUS. ON
ON THE SERVICES CONTAINED IN THE
PROPOSED STATE PLANS THAT WILL
JUST IS A VERY THAT AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT- ON. THE
BROADER SERVICE RATE IS BEING
CONSIDERED- IT IS PART OF THE
FAMILY FIRST IMPLEMENTATION. I
CHALLENGES IN MEETING HER CHILD
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO BEGIN
FEDERAL CLEANING. ALSO BEEN
RAISED IN COULD SUBSTANTIALLY
DELAYED FEDERAL CLAIM MAIN IF
NOT QUICKLY ADDRESSED. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THE STATE DEVELOPS
A SOLUTION. IN COLLABORATION
WITH COUNTIES TO ALLOW PER CHILD
REPORTING INCLINING TO BEGIN AS
SOON AS CALIFORNIA'S FIVE YEAR
PREVENTION PLAN IS APPROVED EVEN
IF LONGER TERM AUTOMATION AND-
IS GOING TO TAKE LONGER TO
IMPLEMENT WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF INTRANSIGENCE AT THAT WE
CAN'T GET. MY NAME. BY TAKING
THE FOLLOWING THREE STOPS THE
STATE CAN HELP ENSURE CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES RECEIVE CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE AND TAILORED
PREVENTION SERVICES. THE STATE
SHOULD PROVIDE ONGOING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND ENCOURAGE
COUNTIES TO LEVERAGE THEIR STATE
BLOCK GRANT FUNDING TO BEGIN
PROVIDING FAMILIES WITH
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE SERVICES.
IS UNITS THEIR LETTERS OF INTENT
TO OPT IN HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED
AND THEIR BLOCK GRANT
ALLOCATIONS HAVE BEEN RECEIVED.
THE STATE SHOULD MONITOR HOW
THIS STATE BLOCK GRANT FUNDING
IS BEING USED LOCALLY TO PROVIDE
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE SERVICES.
A PORTION OF FUNDING ALLOCATED
TO SUPPORT STATE LEVEL ONE
EFFORTS SHOULD ALSO BE USED TO
EVALUATE AND BUILD THE EVIDENCE
FOR CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
SERVICES. TO ENABLE THEIR
EVENTUAL INCLUSION IN THE
PREVENTION SERVICES VERY HOUSE.
THOMASINE SPORTED OR WELL
SUPPORTED LEVELS. THIS STATE
SHOULD WORK CLOSELY WITH
COUNTIES AT COORDINATED STRATEGY
FOR BUILDING EVIDENCE. IN THE
THIRD STEP IS THAT THE STATE
SHOULD IDENTIFY CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC SERVICES THAT HAVE MET
OR ARE LIKELY TO IT NEEDS THE
FEDERAL EVIDENCE BASED STANDARDS
ANY RATING LEVEL SO THAT COULD
BE PROMISING SUPPORTED OR
UNSUPPORTED. FOR INCLUSION IN
THE STATE'S FIVE YEAR PREVENTION
PLAN WHICH COULD BE AMENDED
ANYTIME ONCE IT IS APPROVED.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THESE THOUGHTS ON I'M ALSO
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS IN WRITING- IN
APPRECIATE I THINK COMBINATIONS
FOR LET ME GO FIRST I
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO GET MY
DAUGHTER BY. HER PRESCHOOL AT
CERTAIN TIMES BOB SO I MAY NOT
BE. AVAILABLE TO STAND FOR THE
WHOLE PANEL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND- WE'LL NEXT HEAR
FROM ANGIE SCHWARTZ THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CDSS. THANK YOU
CHAIR ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THERE CAN I ASK FOR AN
UPDATE ON THE STATUS OF THE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION BLOCK GRANT. AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF PART ONE A
FAMILY BURKE PREVENTIONSERVICES
BACK. UP ALL OF THE STATUS OF
OUR ABILITY TO LEVERAGE THE
FUNDS TO ACCESS THE FEDERAL
TITLE FORTY NINE. BERMAN HAS
RECENTLY FINAL THE BLOCK GRANT
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY AND THE
GUIDANCE WILL BE POSTED IN THE
COMING WEEK OR TEO- IN ORDER TO
ENABLE COUNTY. BEGIN ACCESSING
THEIR SHARE AT TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
BLOCK GRANT. INVESTMENT WILL
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO COUNTIES
AND- TRIED TO BE AGAIN. BUILDING
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND TO ASSESS THEIR
READINESS TO DELIVER THAT HAVE
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT
WOULD TARGET. MARGINALITY AND
ALLOW US TO DEVELOP THIS
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE SERVICES
SUPPORT APPLE WAS JUST.
REFERENCING CAN YOU WILL HAVE
THE OPTION DEPENDING ON THEIR
LEVEL OF READINESS TO BEGIN I'M
UTILIZING THESE FUNDS PRIOR TO
THE APPROVAL OF OUR- FEDERAL
PREVENTION SERVICES PLAN THAT
HAVE TO BE APPROVED BEFORE WE
CAN START LEVERAGING THAT
FEDERAL. IN ORDER FOR COUNTIES
TO ACCESS THEIR SHARE OF THE
BLOCK GRANT THAT WILL PERMIT A
LETTER OF INTENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
ONE CELEBRATE LETTER OF INTENT
TO THREE SPEED- INDICATING THEIR
INTENTION TO OPT IN INTO THE
FEDERAL- THE FEDERAL FAMILY PARK
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT ONCE WE
HAVE THAT APPROVAL FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IT WILL BE
ABLE TO IMMEDIATELY START
ACCESSING THEIR SHARE OF THE
BLOCK GRANT ALLOCATION IN ORDER
TO BEGIN BUILDING THAT
FOUNDATION FOR THE BROADER
PREVENTION SERVICES AND SUPPORT-
AS WELL. IN THE M. SO THE
FOUNDATION FOR THEIR EFFORTS OF
DEVELOPING A COMPREHENSIVE
PREVENTION PLANS THAT EACH
COUNTY WILL HAVE TO SUBMIT. TO
THE DEPARTMENT BY JANUARY. OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WHAT THE
**** FOR. ARE RELEASED IN THE
GUY IS OUT WE ARE GOING TO
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN TO WORK WHAT
COUNTY IN ORDER TO ENGAGE IN THE
CIVIC ACTIVITY AGAIN ALONG THE
LINES OF WHAT THE- WHAT WHAT
JEFF RECOMMENDING. OUR INTENTION
IS TO PROVIDE ONGOING TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COUNTY THAT REQUESTED- AS WELL
AS WORKING TO START DEVELOPING
THE SYSTEM FOR MONITORING THE
MODEL ANALOGY OF OUR EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES. AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
PROCESS THAT WILL BE REQUIRED IN
ORDER TO ACCESS THAT FEDERAL
DOLLARS- COUNTY WILL BE ABLE TO
USE THAT PHONE FOR PLANNING
CAPACITY BUILDING.
IMPLEMENTATION OF READING THAT'S
AS WELL AS TO START PROVIDING
PRIMARY PREVENTION PRIMARY
SECONDARY AND TERTIARY
PREVENTION. AND INTERVENTION
SERVICES. HE WILL ALSO BE FOR
COUNTY AND WORKING WITH THEIR
CROPS SECTOR. THEIR LOCAL
SERVICE PER. THERE AND THOSE OF
THE DIXIE. TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES TO REDUCE
DISPROPORTIONATE ALITY AND
PARITY I'M CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
THEY WILL DO THAT PUT INTO THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE PREVENTION
SERVICES. PLAN- THE AUTOMATION
IS READY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY START CLAIMING THAT
FEDERAL TITLE FOR EACH FUNDS TO
FURTHER SUPPORT THE PREVENTION
EFFORTS ACROSS THE STATE. BUT
USING AND ONE THAT WILL ACTUALLY
OCCUR DEPENDS ON CHOICES WE MAKE
AS WE ARE BUILDING THE
CHARACTERS DAMAGE COMPLICATED
THE LEGACY SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE.
CURRENTLY ACTIVE UFC AND THAT'S
LIKE AT THE PEAK PLAGUE. DOES
NOT. THE TYPE OF PER CHILD
CLEANING AND TRACKING THAT IS
REQUIRED IN ORDER TO CLAIM THAT
FEDERAL DOLLARS. GOT THE LATEST
FOR YOU CLEAN WILL BE ABLE TO
START ALONG WITH THE PLAN I AM
WE IMPLEMENT CARE EXPRESSION ONE
WHICH IS PROJECTED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. IT'S
CLEAR. THERE I ALSO A QUESTION
ON THE AGENDA ABOUT THE STATUS
OF FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE FERC
PIECE THAT ARE LIKELY TO BE
IMPACTED BY THE I AM THE ROLE-
TO HELP THEM DETERMINE
TRANSITION THEIR PROGRAM ODELS
THAT THEY WILL NO LONGER BE
IMPACTED BY THE I'M DE ABRIL.
INITIAL DEADLINE TO SUBMIT
TRANSITION PLANS- IN ORDER TAX
THAT THAT'S AND- WHAT THE
STANDARD WANTS TO MARCH FOURTH
AND NOW WE'VE DONE BY THAT MYERS
FOURTH DEADLINE AND WE ARE CAN
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A SECOND
SUBMISSION DEADLINE IN ORDER TO
ALLOW FTA KEEP EATING COUNTY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
DEVELOP THEIR PLANS. SO FAR WE
HAVE RECEIVED FIVE TRANSITION
PLANS- AND FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
SUBMITTED THE PLANS WHEN THEY'RE
PRETTY BIG WE BELIEVE DEPARTMENT
AT THAT TIME SHE BEGAN IN. MAY
BUT GIVEN THAT WE ONLY RECEIVED
THE FIVE PLANS WE ARE GOING TO
ALLOW FOR THAT SECOND SUBMISSION
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY PARTNERING
WITH THE COUNTY AND STATE. CALL
THERE IS- HEADWALL PARTNERS AT.
OF HEALTH CARE SIR. TO DEVELOP A
WEAPON I. TO PROVIDED.
INFORMATION ON ACCESSING THE
FUNDS- AND THE BEST PRACTICES
AND MODELS BUT THAT. IN
TRANSITION TO IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO SERVE OUR
YET BUT UNDER PROGRAM MODEL THAT
WILL NO LONGER HAVE THEM COMING
WITHIN THE I AM DEEP ROLE- WE'RE
CURRENTLY FINALIZING A DATE. THE
WEAPON ARE- AND ALSO WORKING TO
OBTAIN LEADING QUESTIONS FROM
PROVIDE EVERYTHING COUNTY FOR
MAKE SURE THAT WE FULLY ADDRESS
THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL EIGHT
AND- DEVELOPMENT OF THE PLAN.
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
JUSTIN FREITAS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IT'S JUST
APPRAISED FOR FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
ANGELES SHORT WITH THE L. A. L.
THANK YOU VANGELIS RIGHT WITH
THE L. A. L. I HAVE JUST SOME
BRIEF COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
I'LL START WITH F. OF PSA PART
FOR RELATED TO CONGREGATE CARE
REQUIREMENTS AND THEN MOVE ON TO
PART ONE RELATED TO PREVENTION
SERVICES. AT SO FOR PART FOUR.
AT THE STATE IS STILL IN THE
EARLY MONTHS OF IMPLEMENTING-
THE NEW FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
FROM CONGREGATE CARE. WITH THIS
OF THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER WAYS
TO INSURE- THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES WORKING WITH COUNTIES
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. TO
DETERMINE WHERE ANY CHALLENGES
REMAIN AND WHAT ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE OR SUPPORT- MIGHT BE
NEEDED TO ENSURE WE'RE MEETING
ON THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS-
SOME. QUESTIONS THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WISH TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT
COULD INCLUDE WHAT STEPS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT TAKING TO
UNDERSTAND ANY CHALLENGES OR
OBSTACLES. THAT COUNTY OR OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ARE ENCOUNTERING
WHILE IMPLEMENTING NEW
CONGREGATE CARE REQUIREMENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OF CSF PROVIDING AND
AT THE AT THE FACILITATING ANY
WORK GROUPS ARE OTHER PROPHECIES
INVOLVING STAKEHOLDERS- AND ARE
THERE ANY OPPORTUNITIES. WITHIN
ANY OF THESE. I ACTION THAT
ALLEGES TO BE MORE INVOLVED IN
THESE PROPERTIES TO HELP ENSURE
EFFECTIVE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
AND I KNOW THAT- DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SHORT DID SPEAK UP THAT TO SOME
OF THE ON GOING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT'S HAPPENING
EARLIER- MOVING ON TO PART ONE
OF ADVOCATES SAY- AS YOU HEARD
FROM- THIS HOSPITAL. WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS PARTICULAR CONCERN
FROM STAKEHOLDERS OVER HOW TO
TRACK PER CHILD PREVENTION
SPENDING. WHICH IS FEDERALLY
REQUIRED FOR COUNTIES TO BE ABLE
TO BEGIN CLAIMING TITLE FORTY
FINE FOR ELIGIBLE PREVENTION
SERVICES AND SUCH TRACKING IS
BEYOND CALIFORNIA'S- CHILD
WELFARE DATA SYSTEM CURRENT
CAPACITY- THANK YOU FOR AS YOU
JUST HEARD FROM DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SUPPORT- NOT. THE PLAN IS TO
INTEGRATE THIS REPORTING
CAPACITY INTO THE FOURTH COMING-
CARES. OF THE NEW CHILD WELFARE
DATA SYSTEM WHICH REMAINS UNDER
DEVELOPMENT- HOWEVER IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO US AT THIS TIME IF SOME
SORT OF INTERIM SOLUTION AS
POSSIBLE THAT WOULD ALLOW AND
COUNTIES TO BE AGAIN- LEVERAGING
THOSE TITLE FORTY FEDERAL FUNDS
. YOUR HONOR I RATHER THAN
WAITING FOR THE CARE SYSTEM TO
COME ONLINE- ADDITIONALLY HAVE
YOU HEARD FROM THIS HOSPITAL
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE SOME CONCERN
THAT PREVENTION SERVICES
INCLUDED IN THE STATE TITLE
FORTY PREVENTION PLAN- ARE
LIMITED- AND WITH THAT IN MIND
WE- SOME SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO ASK YES
THAT. SPECIFIC ISSUE APART ONE
OF PSA COULD INCLUDE WHAT
FEEDBACK HAS THE DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
HOW IS THE DEPARTMENT
INCORPORATING THAT FEED BACK
INTO THE STATE'S PREVENTION PLAN
- AND ALSO IS THERE AN INTERIM
REPORTING SOLUTION. PRIOR TO THE
COMPLETION OF THE CARE. THAT
WOULD ALLOW COUNTIES TO BEGIN
CLAIM MAIN TITLE FORTY DOLLARS
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER. THANK
YOU AND HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM KATHY SANDERLING
MCDONALD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
C. WTA PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST KEVIN
CENTER LENGTHY BDA- REGARDING
PART ONE I WAS ASKED TO TALK A
BIT ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SERVING CHILDREN FAMILIES WITH-
PART ONE GIVES US. SO SEVEN BACK
FOR A MINUTE- REMEMBER THAT ARE
PART ONE AS MS SCHWARTZ NOTED
ALLOWS. STATE SEN IN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES TO DRAWDOWN TITLE FOR
EACH FUNDING FOR THE FIRST TIME
FOR SERVICES TO FAMILIES UP
UNTIL THIS POINT WE'VE ONLY BEEN
ABLE TO DRAW THAT FUNDING DOWN
FOR PLACEMENT. YEAH A PLACEMENT
SPENDING SO YOU KNOW A FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENT ON CONGREGATE
CARE PLACEMENTS AND SO IT'S
LIMITED- IT'S MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND IN
HOME PARENTING SERVICES FOR THE
MOST PART ADDITIONALLY SOME
SERVICES FOR PARENTING YEARS WHO
ARE IN OUR SYSTEM. OF IN
PARTICULAR ARE AS WELL THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF RULES THAT MUST BE
FOLLOWED I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS FOR YOU KNOW THE
DISCUSSION OF THAT THE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE PROVIDING
THE NECESSARY CHECKS AND
BALANCES THAT INFORMATION IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO FULLY CLAIM
THAT TITLE FOR EACH. FOR EXAMPLE
IF THE SERVICES ESPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES CAN BE FUNDED
THROUGH THE MEDICAID PROGRAM
THROUGH MEDICARE ALL THEN THAT
IS SORT OF THE FIRST RESORT
PAYER ENTITLED FORTY BY THE LOCK
IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE LAST
RESORT PAYER SO THERE'S SOME
LAYERS TO KIND OF HOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
FUNDING. AS WELL AS YOU HEARD-
THERE'S THESE CATEGORIES THAT
LAND A PROGRAM ON THIS CLEARING
HOUSE THEY NEED TO BE PROMISING
SUPPORTED OR WELL SUPPORTED
OTHERS DEFINITIONS OF THOSE IN
THE LAW AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AS
WELL AS- REQUIREMENTS FOR HOW
MUCH OF THE STATE SPENDING OR
COUNTY SPENDING. IN OUR CASE
WOULD NEED TO BE IN EACH OF
THOSE CATEGORIES ANOTHER SET OF
REQUIREMENTS OF LAYERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MEETING. SO.
WHAT THE PROPOSAL THAT CHILL NOW
INSTEAD OF THE A CO SPONSOR. AND
WAS A BY LATEST. TO BUY THE NEW
DEMONSTRATION STUFF BY MORE THAN
EIGHTY. THIS PAST BUGET CYCLE
WAS TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. AND WE USE THAT PART
ONE AS A JUMPING OFF POINT. THE
ISSUE HERE IS WE KNOW IT'S NOT
THE END ALL BE ALL THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION THAT WE SAW WHEN IT
WAS UNDER DISCUSSION T THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. IN A MUCH MORE
ROBUST SET OF SERVICES AND WE
KNOW THAT PREVENTION SERVICES GO
WELL BEYOND MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND IN
HOME PARENTING SERVICES THERE'S-
A WHOLE LOT MORE SERVICES THAT A
FAMILY COULD NEED. IN ORDER TO
AVOID NOT JUST TO BE SURE TO
COLLECT BUT LIKE WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE AVOID FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENT. AND SO WHAT WE WANT
TO TRY TO DO WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
IS TO ENSURE THAT THE FUNDING
CAN BE USED NOT JUST FOR THOSE
CLEARING HOUSE. FEDERALLY
SERVICES WE CAN PROVIDE. AND
DRIED OUT TITLE FOR EACH FOR.
THEIR SERVICES TO AND FOR THE
GENERAL FUND AND HOW IT WAS
STRUCTURED IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET ALLOWS COUNTIES TO DO
THIS. THE IDEA IS TO PARTNER
WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE. AND REALLY TRY TO
TACKLE THE DISPARITIES AND THE
DISPROPORTIONATE ALITY THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT ON PART ONE THAT.
WE TALKED ABOUT LAST YEAR AS
WELL. WE ARE YOU KNOW THE- WE
DON'T DON'T WANT TO CAL TO MARK
OF THE CLIPBOARD SAY WE KNOW
WHAT YOU NEED TO COMMUNITY BUT
INSTEAD TO REALLY PARTNER
MEANINGFULLY IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND ALYSSA. WHAT DO
YOU THINK YOU NEED HOW CAN WE
BRING OUR RESOURCE CENTER IN
ORDER TO BEAR AND AN- INCREASE
SERVICES THAT YOU ALREADY HAVE.
CREATE NEW SERVICES AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE CULTURALLY
RELEVANT EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT ON
THAT CLEARING HOUSE LIST IDEALLY
WE COULD TRY TO HELP BUILD THAT
DATA. AND BUILD THAT SORT OF
RESEARCH BASE TO BE ABLE TO
EVENTUALLY GET PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT ON THE CLEARING HOUSE. BUT
THE FUNDING THAT YOU SUPPORTED
AND PUT INTO PLAY AND THAT'S
AVAILABLE NOW- OR SOON WE HOPE
IS GOING TO ENABLE US TO NOT
JUST DRIED OUT FOR EACH. ONLY
FOR THE LIMITED SERVICES BUT TO
DO A MUCH BROADER- APPROACH TO
PREVENTION. OF THAT WE THINK IS
REALLY THE BETTER WAY TO GO. AND
SO- KIND OF WHERE WE ARE I MEAN
YOU'VE HEARD THE FINDINGS NOT
YET FULLY OUT THE INSTRUCTIONS
ARE NOT YET FULLY OUT. OF IT WE
KNOW WHAT IT TAKES MORE TIME TO
GET MONEY OUT THE DOOR THERE
WERE A LOT OF INVESTMENTS IN
CHILD WELFARE- AND WE DID NEED
TO GET OUR PREVENTION PLAN
APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. BUT IT IS MARCH AND
SO WE ARE VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING THE MATERIALS
IMAGE TOWARDS MENTION- AND SINCE
IT DOESN'T RELY. ON US OUR
ABILITY TO TALK TO CLAIM TITLE
FOR HE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
THE CARE SYSTEM IS NOT THERE
YET- IT'S A COMPLICATED SET OF-
CLAIMING TO REALLY AUTOMATE. BUT
WE CAN GET GOING ON THIS WE
DON'T HAVE TO JUST WAIT FOR CARE
AND WAIT UNTIL WE CAN PLAN FOR
EACH. COUNTIES CAN START WORKING
WITH THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES NOW
AND START YOU IDEALLY PROVIDE
THE SERVICES FUNDING SERVICES.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMMUNITIES AND. GET GOING ON
THAT SO THAT WE CAN WILL WE
START TO TAP. WHAT WE KNOW OUR
THESE LONG STANDING DESPAIR. AND
JUST BEFORE. AND TO REALLY
INCREASE EQUITY INTEREST OF AND
SO. FAMILIES STRENGTHEN FAMILIES
AVOID FOSTER CARE- I'LL JUST
SAY- WAFTING ON THIS PART ONE
QUESTION. IS WE CERTAINLY WOULD
BE INTERESTED IN EXPLORING AN
INTERIM SOLUTION- ACT NOTED BY-
BY THE L. A. L. O. THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME OPTIONS- WE KNOW
WHAT WOULD NOT BE IDEAL THE
IDEAL IS TO GET CARE- PROGRAMS.
THERE'S A LOT TO DO ONE CARES
AND- PROGRAMMING DOESN'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE COULD HELP TO CREATE THAT
INTERIM SOLUTION. TO NOT ONLY
STANDS THE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
ON GOOD SERVICES BUT ALSO DRIVE
DOWN FOR EACH FOR THOSE THAT WE
CAN- WERE UP WERE. ALL IN ON
THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO HELP WITH
THAT. ON FOUR WE'RE ALL AFTER-
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS ON THE
CHALLENGES FROM COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES ON PARK FOR-
SO FAR I THINK THAT THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE HAS JUST BEEN THAT-
PURPORT TOOK EFFECT ON OCTOBER
FIRST OF LAST YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST OF THE STATE
GUIDANCE ON IMPLEMENTATION JUST
CAME OUT A DAY OR SO A DAY OR
TWO BEFORE THAT OCTOBER FIRST ST
AGAIN IT WAS A LUMINOUS IT WAS.
A LOT FOR THE STATE TO GET
TOGETHER- IT DID LEAVE COUNTY IS
KIND OF SCRAMBLING TO TRY TO
IMPLEMENTED WE DID. MAKE SURE TO
LET THE ADMINISTRATION KNOW THAT
WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO AVOID
THAT AS OF THAT OCTOBER FIRST
ST- WE DO APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDED COUNTIES
WITH A TEMPORARY FUNDING- TO
ADDRESS ISSUES SUCH AS WHAT A
COURT. MIGHT OVERRULE THAT
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL
RECOMMENDATION I'M PLACE TO USE
THAT TO ASK YOUR GP ANYWAY OR
WHEN WE USE THE FACILITY THAT
HAVEN'T YET BEEN ACCREDITED.
GIVEN THAT NEWLY LICENSED AFTER
YOUR GPS YOU HAVE UP TO TWO
YEARS TO BECOME ACCREDITED-
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PARTNERING
WITH US ON THAT ISSUE WHICH IS A
VERY REAL ISSUE- AND SO WE
DEFINITELYHAVE ALSO BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH HER COUNTY
PARTNERS. AT THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS PROBATION CHIEFS
UNEMPLOYMENT HE SAID ISSUES AS
WELL AS PDFS NVH THE ACT AS
ISSUES ARISE. I WILL JUST
CONTINUE TODAY OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I'M TRYING TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS THESE
WHERE WE CAN WITHIN THE FEDERAL
STRUCTURE THAT WE MUST LIVE
WITHIN. AND ENSURE THAT COUNTIES
ARE ADEQUATELY FUNDED FOR THE
WORK- AND I DO JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY FROM THE PRIOR PANEL
CONVERSATION THAT- THESE
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS. ARE NOT
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES STAFF
OTHER COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
STAFF THAT WAS WRITTEN INTO THE
STATUTE- AND WE DO APPRECIATE
THE SUGGESTIONS THAT MAY SHORT
PROVIDED ON. CONTINUING TO TAKE
A LOOK TOGETHER AND HOW WE'RE-
AT PER FOR. I THINK- TELL WAS
WERE A LEAD. AND A LOT OF WHAT
YOU SEE WERE. IN THAT FOR LAW.
PRACTICE WE NICE TO WHAT WE
STARTED DOING NOW YOU KNOW WITH
RCC ARE YEARS AND YEARS AGO BUT
THERE WERE SOME DIFFERENCES AND
THERE ARE SOME CHANGES I NOW
YOU KNOW I'M I'M THE STARTER
MERZ I WILL ADDRESS A LOT OF
THAT I THINK FROM HER. MEMBERS
PERSPECTIVE BUT CERTAINLY FROM
OUR MEMBERS PERSPECTIVE THERE'S
A LOT OF CHANGES AND IT'S A
REALLY GOOD IDEA TO CAN YOU
TALKING ABOUT HOW THAT'S GOING
AND- YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE DO WE
NEED. FOR THE LEGISLATURE FROM
THE STATE IN OUR STATE LAW FROM
OUR PARTNERS TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
RIGHT. NOW THANK YOU AND AGAIN
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ONLY
GET TO THAT POINT. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM CHRISTY
CHRIS STONER MARKED. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHEN ARAMBULA BOB WE
WERE ASKED TO RESPOND TO TWO
QUESTIONS THE FIRST OF WHICH-
WAS VERY SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
S. T. R. C. P.'S SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
AND HOW- A TATIAN. OR F. PSA WAS
OCCURRING AND THEN SECONDLY TO
ANSWER HOW THE STATE CAN IMPROVE
ON ITS IMPLEMENTATION OF FF'S
PSA PARK FOR- THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF A PSA HAS HAD SIGNIFICANT.
IMPACTS HONEST YEAR KEEP. AS OF
SOME OF THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
HAVE MENTIONED. AS A CLOSER
REVIEW OF FEDERAL AND STATE
REGULATIONS OCCURRED IT BECAME
CLEAR THE S. T. R. T. P.'S WITH
MORE THAN SIXTEEN BEDS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BE AT RISK OF BEING
DEEMED AN INSTITUTION FOR MENTAL
DISEASES OR AND I AM DE. UNDER
THE CENTER FOR MEDICAID AND
MEDICARE'S REGULATIONS- DH CS IS
CURRENTLY WORKING TO REVIEW S.
T. R. T. P. IS AND WILL MAKE
THESE DETERMINATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE COURSE OF THIS YEAR AND BY
THE END OF DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WHAT CAMPUS SPACE S.
T. R. T. P. IS WITH MORE THAN
SIXTEEN BEDS WHO ARE MOST AT
RISK OF THIS DESIGNATION
SUBSTANTIAL ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGES MUST BE MADE. AND EVEN
WITH THESE CHANGES A LOSS OF
THIS TO YOUR GP OPTIONS FOR
YOUTH WILL RESULT IN THE NEXT
NINE MONTHS. IT'S HARD TO
CALCULATE WHAT THE EXACT NUMBER
WILL BE- OUR ESTIMATES RANGE
RANGE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN HUNDRED
TREATMENT BEDS. PSA WAS DESIGNED
WITH THE ASSUMPTION THAT
FACILITY SERVING THE HIGHEST
RISK YOU ARE IN THE SAME COUNTY
AS THE PLACING AGENCY. THE
NATURE OF FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA
RESULTS IN A WELL ABOVE
COMPLEXITY FROM ISSUES RELATED
TO PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER TO THE
NEED TO ENSURE STABLE TRÊN
STABLE TRANSITIONS THROUGH AFTER
CARE SERVICES AS PART OF PARK
FOR. MUCH OF THE BURDEN ON
MANAGING THESE COMPLEXITIES
FALLS ON PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS
. AS I MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS
PANEL THE ASSUMPTIONS USED TO
CREATE THE S. T. R. T. P. RATE
UNDER C. C. R. WERE FLAWED AND
THE CURRENT RATE STRUCTURE DOES
NOT ADEQUATELY FUND THE INTENSE
LEVEL OF SERVICES AND STAFFING
REQUIRED TO EFFECTIVELY TREAT
AND SUPPORT YOUTH IN
TRANSITIONING TO FAMILY BASED
CARE. COVERT NINETEEN HAS ALSO
DRASTICALLY IMPACTED S. T. R. T.
P.'S WHO CONTINUE TO WAIT FOR
EMERGENCY RELIEF PASSED IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
WHICH COVERED ONLY 25% OF THE
TOTAL LOSS OF REVENUE AND
EXPENSES INCURRED BY
ORGANIZATIONS. THE ALLIANCE IS
SPONSORING BUDGET REQUEST TO
ADDRESS BOTH THE REVIEW AND
ADJUSTMENT OF THE RATE AS WELL
AS ADDITIONAL COBIT RELIEF TO
COVER ADDITIONAL LOSSES. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUAL PROCESS HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING AS- AS OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED AND WE'RE BEGINNING TO
SEE SOME OF THESE IMPACTS AT THE
S. T. R. T. P. LEVEL NOW. AGAIN
THIS REQUIRES ONGOING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO COUNTIES AND
PROVIDERS THAT WILL LIKELY BE
NEEDED FOR QUITE SOME TIME AS WE
CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THESE NEW
REGULATIONS. IN TERMS OF-
THOUGHTS OF THE STATE MIGHT
IMPROVE IMPLEMENTATION OF PART
FOUR- I FIRST HAVE TO SAY THAT
THE ON GOING AFTER THE PSA
TECHNICAL CALLS HAVE BEEN
HELPFUL- AND CDSS STAFF HAS ALSO
BEEN VERY ACCESSIBLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AS THEY COME UP. ON A
ONE TO ONE BASIS S. T. R. T. P.
IS AND THEY'RE COUNTY PARTNERS
NEED MORE DIRECT GUIDANCE AROUND
FF PM PHONE BUT IMPLEMENTATION
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. BECAUSE MANY
OF SECURITY PEAS ARE SERVING
YOUTH FROM MULTIPLE COUNTIES
COORDINATION IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT DISCUSSIONS ARE TAKING
PLACE WITH EACH OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS AND PARTICULARLY
THE LARGER ONES AT MOST RISK. AN
ACTIVE PLANNING TO ENSURE
STABILITY FOR THE USE. IS
HAPPENING- THE SCHWARTZ- TALKED
ABOUT THE TRANSITION PLANNING
FUNDING WHICH WE WERE VERY
GRATEFUL TO GET AND- ALSO
CONTINUE TO THINK THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE COORDINATION AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDED SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO HEAR. THAT BE
DOING MORE AROUND THAT. MANY
MANY ASK YOUR GP IS ACTUALLY
BEEN IN THE POSITION OF ACTUAL
OF EDUCATING PARTNERS AROUND
THESE COMPLEXITIES BECAUSE IT
IT'S THERE'S A LOT OF TECHNICAL
SPECIFICITY THAT HAS TO BE
UNDERSTOOD- AND THAT OF COURSE
OF COURSE WORKING WITH MULTIPLE
COUNTY'S AGAIN VERY CHALLENGING
FOR ORGANIZATIONS. ENCOURAGING
ENGAGING THESE AUSTERITY P.
ISN'T PLANNING FOR AFTER CARE
SERVICES IS ALSO CRITICAL
ALTHOUGH EACH COUNTY WILL NEED
TO DEVELOP A PLAN. ORGANIZATIONS
SERVING YOUTH FROM MULTIPLE
COUNTIES NEED COORDINATION WITH
ALL OF THOSE COUNTIES WE'VE GOT
TO STAY FOCUSED ON CONTINUITY OF
CARE FOR THESE YOUTH REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER A YOUNG PERSON IS
BEING IS ACCESSING SERVICES
ACROSS COUNTY LINES. CONTINUED
SUPPORT AND CA IS NEEDED
REGARDING THE QUEUE WAITING
QUEUE I PROCESS. AND TO ENSURE
THAT THE F. SECURITY KEYS ARE
NOT BEARING THE BURDEN OF A LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING RELATED TO HOW
THE QUEUE I ASSESSMENT AND THE
PLACING AGENCY PROCESSES
INTERACT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REMARK AND
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I WILL BRING IT
UP TO THE DÍAS SITE I WILL- MAKE
TO SPECIFIC REQUESTS FROM THE
CHAIR- IN BOTH OF THEM ARE
CURRENTLY ON THE AGENDA- THEY
ARE NOTED ON PAGE TWENTY NINE OF
OUR AGENDA. I'D FIRST LIKE TO
ASK THE L. A. O. TO ASSIST IN
THE DRAFTING OF SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE TO BE
DEVELOPED IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND OUR SUB
COMMITTEE. TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
ADOPTION OUT TO ME REVISION- ON
A HIGH LEVEL PROGRESS REPORT
TYPE UPDATE FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PARTS ONE AND
FOUR OF THE FF PSA. TO BE
PROVIDED ON A PERIODIC BASIS IN
WRITING TO THE LEGISLATURE. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO INVITE THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
RETURN TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE ONCE
THE PREVENTION PLAN IS FINALIZED
TO PRESENTED. AND AS WE HEARD
FROM KATHY SANDERLING MCDONALD'S
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY AS THIS
IS A JUMPING OFF POINT. THAT I'D
LIKE TO BRING BACK- WHAT WAS
DISCUSSED UNDER ISSUE ONE IN OUR
ABILITY TO RELEASE AN ANNUAL
REPORT WHICH IS ANALYZING OUR
PROGRESS. TOWARDS MEETING
SPECIFIC OBJECTIVES IN REDUCING
THE DISPROPORTIONATE ALITY IN
DISPARITIES WITHIN CHILD. AN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES SINCE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THOSE DISPARITIES
THAT SEEMS LOGICAL FOR US TO
SIMILARLY FOCUSED ON PREVENTION
AND THOSE SAME POPULATIONS AND
WOULD APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT.
REPORTING BACK ONCE THE
PREVENTION PLAN HAS BEEN
FINALIZED WITH THAT WE WILL
THANKS VERY MUCH ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS ON ISSUE THREE AND WE
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE FOR. WHERE
WE WILL HAVE NINE PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL WE WILL BEGIN WITH
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR JENNIFER
TROYER WITH CDSS FOLLOWED BY
ANGIE SCHWARTZ WITH CDSS. THEN
IT'S JUSTIN FREIDA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ANGELES SHORT WITH THE
L. A. O. GIOVANE WILKES THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH.
SIMONE TURRICAN LEAD THE
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING AND HEALTH
FOR JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH GENDER PRIOR WHO'S THE
INTERIM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIRECTOR.
TIFFANY WOULDN'T WITH THE- WITH
SEIU CALIFORNIA'S THEIR SENIOR
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ADVOCATE
AND KATHY SANDERLING MCDONALD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH CWD.
LET'S BEGIN WITH MISS TROY YEAH
WHEN YOU'RE READY. ACTUALLY THIS
IS OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF SPORTS
I BELIEVE METROCARDS TO STEP
AWAY FOR A MOMENT SO I'M JUST
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND JUMP RIGHT
AND AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER IN
THE AFTERNOON. OUR VISION UNDER
CPR'S FOR ALL CHILDREN TO BE
CONNECTED TO PERMANENT FUNDING
FAMILIES CHILDREN HEAL IN THE
CONTEXT OF FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
SERVICE THEY STAND AT THAT
PARTICULAR IMPORTANT FOR
CHILDREN HAVE EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA. AND WHO ARE
FACING THE GREATEST CHALLENGES
THREATENING. ARE WORKING. WITH
OUR COUNTY PART. BUT OUR
LEARNING SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CHILDREN CAN
HAVE THEIR NEEDS MET AND FAITH
HEALTHY AN APPROPRIATE
ENVIRONMENT. OUR PROVIDING
TRAINING AND RESOURCES AS WELL
AS TECHNICAL ASSISTANT.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT SOMETIMES
HAPPENS ON A BROADER SCALE AND
OTHER TIME GOLD CIRCUMSTANCES OF
INDIVIDUAL CHILDREN. THE
CHALLENGES IN MEETING THE NEEDS
OF A SMALL COHORT OF OUR YOUTH
BUT THE MOST COMPLEX NEEDS ARE
MULTIFACETED. AND WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS WORK TOGETHER FOR A
LONG TIME. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR PROVIDED A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE BILLION IN CRITICAL
INVESTMENT THAT THE PARTIES THAT
ARE. AND WE'RE. WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO IMPLEMENT THEM.
BEFORE I THEM THE QUESTIONS ON
THE AGENDA SPECIFIC TO THE HOW
WERE IMPLEMENTING THAT HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE MILLION AYE BUT
WANTED TO. HIGHLIGHT SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT OTHER
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT WOULD ALSO INCREASE
THE PART PARTY CONVENTION EIGHT
YEARS- THE FIRST FALL WOULD NOT
BE ADMINISTERED BY PDF THAT. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES INCLUDE A
PROPOSAL UNDER THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO PROVIDE A REFUNDABLE
THOUSAND DOLLAR TAX CREDIT FOR
YOUNG ADULTS EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE. THE WORK FORM ACROSS THE
YEAR AT AGE THIRTEEN OR OLDER
CONTINGENT ON FEDERAL APPROVAL
UNNECESSARY DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT. THIRTY ALSO A
PURPOSE TO THE REQUIRED CASE
MANAGEMENT AND SUPPORT SERVICES
TO INCREASE UTILIZATION OF
PASTILLAS INDEPENDENT PILOT
PROGRAM- TO SUPPORT AN INCREASE
OF THE USE OF THAT THAT'S WHY I
ABOUT YOUR ARE YOU UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY FIVE. SENATE BUDGET
OFFICE- WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT
THE SUPPORT- FOR SOCIAL SECURITY
ARTICLE MENTAL SECURITY INCOME
BENEFIT APPEAL PARTY CONVENTION
EACH YEAR. I THE DEFINING THE
HOW IT DOES PROPOSALS THE
PERFECT CAR TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
BUT THEN TURN DIRECTLY FOR THAT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE MILLION.
BUT I JUST MENTIONED THAT WOULD
BE IN SUPPORT OF ARGUED WITH OUR
MOST COMPLEX CARE NEEDS. AT THE-END OF POINTS OUT THERE DEFENDER
DIVIDED INTO THREE CATEGORIES.
TO SUPPORT COUNTY FROM THE ART.
FIRST IF THE EIGHTEEN POINT ONE
MILLION IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
COUNTIES TO ACCESS- FUNDING TO
SUPPORT A SPECIFIC CHILD AN
INDIVIDUAL CHILD THAT HAS
EXCEPTIONAL CARE NEEDS. SECOND
THIRTY FORTY THREE POINT THREE
MILLION AVAILABLE FOR CAPACITY
BUILDING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE FULL CONTINUUM OF
PLACEMENT OPTIONS AND SERVICES
TO THIRTY YES BUT THE MATTER-
COMPLEX NEEDS AND THEN THE THIRD
OF FIFTY ONE POINT THREE MILLION
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
CHILDREN CRISIS CONTINUE ON
PILOT. TO TEST INNOVATIVE MODEL
OF DELIVERING AND SUPPORTING IT
ACROSS THE ENTIRE CONTINUUM.
BRIEFLY DELVE INTO WHERE WE ARE
IN IMPLEMENTATION OF EACH OF THE
BACK PART WITH REGARD TO THAT
PERSPECTIVE THE FUNDING THE
EIGHTEEN POINT ONE MILLION TO
SUPPORT THE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OF
A SPECIFIC CHILD THOSE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE TO COUNTY TO REQUEST
THAT THEY NEED IT- AND THEY'RE
AVAILABLE NOW TODAY WE BRING
SPEED- REQUEST FOR FUNDS FOR
ELEVEN YEARS AND NINE OF THAT
REQUEST THE BEEN RATE. APPROVED
WHICH YOU REQUESTED HAVE BEEN
RECEIVED EARLIER THIS WEEK ARE
PENDING I'M IN THE MOST COMMON
USE OF THE FUNDS THAT FUNDS HAVE
BEEN REQUESTED FOR HAS BEEN FOR
VENDOR RIGHTS PLACEMENT FOR
YOUTH THAT ARE- REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMERS. MEDICAL TRANSPORT
VARIOUS COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE PLACE SPENT RELATED TO THE
CHILD'S MEDICAL NEEDS AND
ENHANCE INTENSIVE. SERVICES
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM. WHAT REGARD
THE FORTY THREE POINT THREE
NINE- WHICH WILL SUPPORT. AND
ADDITION COUPON THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THE GUIDANCE TO COUNTIES TO ACT
OF THE FUNDS FISCAL. PART
RECOVERY. AND COUNTY PARKER IN
THE PROCESS OF CONDUCTING THE
SELF EVALUATION NOT REQUIRED IN
ORDER TO IDENTIFY GAPS WITHIN
THEIR LOCAL CONTINUUM OF CARE.
AND THEN FOLLOWING THAT THEY
WILL BE DEVELOPING COMPLEX
AIRCRAFT THE BUILDING PROPOSALS.
THAT IDENTIFIES THAT ENHANCE AND
SPECIALIZED SERVICES AND
STRATEGIES AND MODELS THAT THEY
WILL CREATE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THAT GAP. TO
DATE OF SIX COUNTIES HAVE
COMPLETED THE SELF ASSESSMENT.
AND ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT VERY
MANY COUNTY WE HAVE SEEN SOME
TRENDS ALREADY- IN TERMS OF THE
GAP EMPLACEMENT AND PERFECT THAT
THE CROP THE CONTINUE- AMPLE
COUNTY HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT THEY
HAVE- OR LIMITED PLACEMENT
OPTIONS. FOR CHILDREN THAT HAVE
CO OCCURRING INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISORDER AND
MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSES FOR
CHILDREN WHO ARE REGIONAL CENTER
FOR CONTEMPORARY. THANK YOU-
THAT NEED SUPPORT PERFECT THANK
YOU ORDER PARK COMMERCIAL SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION POPULATION
ARCHITECT HERE AS WELL AS OUR
LGBTQ PLUS. POPULATION AND
COUNTY HAVE ALSO IDENTIFIED THAT
THEY HAVE LIMITED OR NO
PLACEMENT OPTIONS FOR YOU THAT
ARE ALSO INVOLVED WITH ARE
KEEPING ALL JUSTICE THAT'S THEM.
I'M PARTICULARLY EACH. CERTAIN
TYPES OF. IN TERMS AFFECT THE
BURKE THAT NOT COMMIT CRIME LIKE
PARKS. MENTAL HEALTH SETTINGS-
THAT ARE ALL NEED FOR A- AND
WHAT ACTION BEAR TO GET ACROSS
TURKEY PER. AND COMMUNITY
TREATMENT FACILITIES- IMPLANTS
OF ALL EVERYTHING COUNTY HAVE
ALSO IDENTIFIED IN THESE GAP
ANALYSIS NOT JUST THE PLACEMENTS
THAT THEY NEED TO BUILD AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BUT OFFER THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THAT THEY-
HAVE CAPTAIN. WITHIN THEIR
EXISTING CONTINUE ON HERE
THEY'VE IDENTIFIED THAT THERE.
ARE LIMITED OPTIONS WITH REGARD
TO THINGS LIKE PLASTIC CARE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
SAYS- APPLIED BEHAVIORAL AND
ABOUT ANALYSIS OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY PHYSICAL THERAPY SPEECH
THERAPY AND LIMITED TO MAIL
OPTION. FOR THINGS LIKE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY LIKE THAT
THERAPEUTIC BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT
AND HOME BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT
CRISIS SUPPORT IN DAY TREATMENT
MODELS. FOR THOSE THAT HAVE GAP
THAT WE WILL BE WORKING TO
ADDRESS- WITH THE COUNTY- AND
THAT THEY WILL BE SUBMITTING
PROPOSALS I'M SURE THAT CAPACITY
BUILDING PROPOSAL IN TERMS OF
HOW THEY WILL BE ATTRACTING.
THOSE GAPS WITHIN THEIR
CONTINUE- WE ARE ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF PUTTING TOGETHER. A
GROUP OF FOLKS TO SORT OF LOOK
AT THAT GAP ANALYSIS THAT WE ARE
IDENTIFYING AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE COMING TOGETHER ESTATE
PARTNERS AND LOCAL PARTNERS IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
GAPS THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT WE CAN
CONCRETELY. I'M FIGURE OUT HOW
TO ACTUALLY BUILD THE CAPACITY
NEEDED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR
THE CONVERSATIONS ARE STARTING
WELL. IN TERMS OF THE CRISIS
CONTINUE ON PILOTS OF THE
CHILDREN PRESIDENTIAL CRISIS
CONTINUE ON THAT THE SIXTY ONE
POINT THREE MILLION THERE IS
THAT REQUEST FOR APPLICATIONS
THAT IS CURRENTLY BEING
DEVELOPED- AND WILL BE AVAILABLE. IN ORDER FOR- OR OR- TO-
APPLIED BE PART OF THAT PIE PRO
WHEN A ONE FIFTY PASS STOCK
WORKLOAD WELL DEFENDED TEMPLE OF
THE FAMILY FOR SERVICES TO MAKE
SURE THE WE CAME INTO COME WITH
ALL REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE PART
OF THAT PART FOR PEACE THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT EXTENSIVELY TODAY
WE HAD TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL LAW BY OCTOBER
FIRST- OR OTHER RIDE RIPPED OFF
THE FEDERAL FUNDING SO SHORTLY
AFTER OCTOBER FIRST. WE SHIFTED
FOCUS TO DRAFTING- THE RFA FOR
THE CHILDREN CRISIS CONTINUE ON
PILOT- AND ARE IN THE END STAGES
OF PUTTING THAT ARE ESTATE
TOGETHER WE'VE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY IN COLLABORATION
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS AND WENT
DARK YOUR DEPARTMENT IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE OUR ESTATE
PART OF THE DRAFT THE FULL-
CONTINUE- AND SUPPORT SEND
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
THE PART. OF THE PILOT- THIS
FRAME BY WE'RE IN THREE THE ARE
- IS THE MIDDLE. TO END OF EIGHT
ACTUALLY THE END OF APRIL FOR
THE RELEASE STATES- AND THEN THE
RESPONSES WOULD BE DUE BACK TO
US BY THE MIDDLE OF JUNE BUT A
PERIOD IN BETWEEN WHERE WE WOULD
BE. I'M ENGAGED IN QUESTIONS
AND- ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS IN
ORDER TO INFORM THAT BED. WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THE COMPLEX CARE
FRIENDS THAT I JUST OVER IT WILL
ENABLE COUNTIES TO MEET SPECIFIC
NEEDS OF INDIVIDUAL CHILDREN WHO
ARE IN EMERGENCY SITUATIONS.
WELL OFF THE BUILDING MORE
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT THE FULL
CONTINUUM OF NEEDS AND AVOID
USING EXPERIENCING. THINGS LIKE
SPACE AND OFFICES AND HOTELS
THAT WE ALL READ ABOUT IN RECENT
NEWSPAPER REPORTS IN THE TENT
AGENDA AFTER EFFECTIVELY CRAP TO
ADDRESS- WHAT WE ARE DOING- IN
THE- EIGHT COUNTIES IN THESE
SITUATIONS. ON THAT TOPIC I JUST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND STATE
OUT RIGHT THAT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
COUNTIES AND ALL OF THE WAYS
THAT WE. BE HELD AND- TODAY'S.
HEARING ENSURE THE ALL OF OUR
YOU ARE SUPPORTED AND LYFT AND-
THAT BEST MEET THEIR NEEDS IN
BOTH THE SHORT AND LONG TERM.
ANYTHING LESS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
TO SUPPORT COUNTIES IN THESE
EFFORTS WERE WORKING TO HELP
THEM INNOVATE AROUND THE USE OF
THE FUNDS THAT I WAS JUST KIND
OF REVEALING. AS WELL AS
DEVELOPING RESOURCES TRAININGS
AND OTHER SUPPORT THAT COUNTIES
ARE FOLLOW WHAT FULLY AWARE OF
THE ARRAY OF REPORTERS AND
FUNDING OPTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE- AND ABLE TO LEVERAGE
THE- MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO
DEVELOP THE CAPACITY AND TO MEET
THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF CHILDREN.
TO THAT END WE RECENTLY CREATED
AND POSTED THE COMPLEX CARE
RESOURCE GUIDE. THAT DETAILS AND
THAT'S AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE
MODOC BELT LINKS IN THAT ISSUE
BRIEF THAT AS CHIEF DEPUTY AND
DIRECTOR TRAN MENTIONED EARLIER
IN HER COMMENTS TODAY- THAT
DETAILS THE MANY FUNDING STREAM
CONTRACT. TECHNICAL WITH THEM
BUT AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT COUNTY
THINK CARING FOR YOU AT THE
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS. WERE ALSO
WORKING ON PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT WILL BE PUBLISHED
THEY ACTUALLY. DETAIL AND GET
MORE- MORE. ABOUT THIS THE TYPES
OF MY- IN PROGRAMS THAT COULD BE
DEVELOPED- AND YOU WORK AT I'M
SORRY. THE SPECIFIC MODEL THEM
PROGRAMS THAT COUNTIES COULD
CREATE USE THAT EIGHTEEN POINT
ONE MILLION TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC
NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND ACTUALLY
GET THE PERFECT IDEA OF THE TYPE
OF THING- THAT DOES DOLLARS
COULD BE USED FOR ITS WEALTH THE
FORTY THREE POINT THREE MILLION.
THE BUILDING AND WE ALSO HAVE A
TOOL KIT AND DEVELOPMENT TO HELP
CREATE STEP BY STEP GUIDE. HOW
TO ACTUALLY CREATE SOME OF THESE
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND- IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
ARE YOU ARE YOU TO THE COMPLEX
CARE NEEDS. AND WITH THAT I
WILL- PAS THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO JUSTIN
FREITAS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SEARCH FOR HIS
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM ANGELES
SHORT BUT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE. THANK YOU YOUR
ENCLOSURE WITH THE L. A. O. I WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE AT THIS
TIME BUT WE'RE STANDING BY TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM JOHN WILKES THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I AM DIVINE BOOKS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH.
AND TODAY I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
NEEDS OF YOUTH. AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WHO LIKE US
ALL HAVE INTERDEPENDENT MAKE AND
ARE EMPOWERED. TO RISE ABOVE TO
FIND SOLUTIONS THAT HE'LL GROW
AND SUPPORT YOU TO DRIVE INTO
THE PROMISING FUTURE THEY
DESERVE. YOUTH OF COLOR AND
YOUTH IDENTIFYING AS LGBTQ PLUS
OUR STUFF FOR. YOU TO THE IMPACT
OF THE PANDEMIC. AND ATTACKS ON
THEM THEIR LOVED ONES IN THE
FUTURE THEY HOPE TO SEE. THE
LIVELIHOOD OF YOUTH ESPECIALLY
THOSE INVOLVED WITH THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM I HAVE EXPERIENCE
EDUCATION DISRUPTIONS. ROQUAN
RELATIONSHIPS IS A CO SEXUAL AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE HOUSING
INSTABILITY FOOD INSECURITY
HOMELESSNESS AND- WOW WE NOW ARE
MOVINGIN A POSITIVE DIRECTION.
THE RECOVERY WILL BE SLOWER FOR
SOME YOUTH AND YOUNG PEOPLE. AND
WE MUST ENSURE THEY HAVE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
FULLY RECOVER FROM THE TRAUMAS
THEY HAVE ENDURED. THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATOR M. ADMINISTRATION
OLDER YOUTH IN CARE OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM RECEIPT EXTENDED
SUPPORTING CARE EXTENSION WAS
CRITICAL IN STABILIZING NON
MINOR DEPENDENTS AND YOU
TRANSITIONING INTO ADULTHOOD
HAVE MORE PERMANENT HOUSING
OPTIONS. BUT WITH SUPPORTING
CARE EXTENDED TO DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
USED BEAR THE WEIGHT OF THE
EXITING CARE WITHOUT A PLAN. AT
A TRAUMA AND HARDSHIP TO FIND A
PLACE TO LIVE IN AN OVERLY
COMPETITIVE AND LIMITED
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING OPTIONS
. MEANWHILE MANY YOUTH WHO
NEEDED CARE OR MESSED AND
SIMULTANEOUSLY AND DURING A
HARDSHIP AND NAVIGATING
CALIFORNIANS UNDER RESOURCE
UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
SYSTEM. TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS STEPPED IN
TO PROVIDE YOUTH WITH CONTINUE
AND- SAFE PLACES TO HEAL GROW
AND BE POSITION TO THRIVE. CBO
SUPPORTED YOUTH WITH PHASING OUT
OF CARE WITH ROLLING BLACKS THE
BILL EXCEEDS VERSUS HITTING THE
HARD DEADLINE OF DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
THE PEOPLE THAT BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS AND PROVIDE CASE
MANAGEMENT TO YOU LIKE WHAT'S
ENVISIONED THROUGH THE YOUTH THE
FOSTER YOUTH INDEPENDENT PILOT.
MUST RECEIVE INCREASED
INVESTMENTS FOR CBO TO RETAIN
AND SUSTAIN SUCH CRUCIAL MY FOR
A YOUNG PERSON'S TRANSITION
THROUGH AND OUT OF CARE.
ULTIMATELY OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
YOU NEED FOR MILLION STRONG AND
CARING RELATIONSHIPS ALONG WITH
A SECURE AND SAFE PLACE TO HEAL
GROW AND EVENTUALLY JOINED THE
WORK FORCE. TO BE EVENT SHE SELF
SUFFICIENCY AND THRIVE. AND
AGAIN WITH EDUCATION DISRUPTIONS
INCREASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
NEEDS AND THE NEED FOR
MEANINGFUL WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES WE MUST UTILIZE
SOLUTIONS THAT EMPOWER YOU. AND
EMPLOYERS TO WORK TOGETHER FOR
THE GREATER GOOD. INCENTIVISING
EMPLOYERS WITH TAX CREDITS THE
HIGHER SYSTEM EVOLVE YOU PAID
LEARN AND GROW INTERNSHIPS
APPRENTICESHIPS AND PROVIDING
SCHOLARSHIPS TO INCREASE
PROFESSIONALS AND SOCIAL WORK.
OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WITH PEOPLE
THAT HAVE THE LIVE M. CULTURAL
EXPERIENCES THAT WE COLLECTIVELY
ARE ADVOCATING. FOR AND NEED
TODAY. CBO'S YES AND TODAY ARE
SERVING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEY TOO NEED
TO BE SERVED WITH INCREASED
FLEXIBLE AND ON GOING
INVESTMENTS AS THEY SUPPORT AND
CARE FOR YOUTH IN. AN EXITING
CHILD WELFARE JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND HOMELESSNESS CBO'S ARE
ESSENTIAL CARE GIVERS AND
MENTORS AND WE KNOW THEY HELP
DEVELOP STRONG RELATIONSHIPS TO
KEEP YOU. ON A GOOD TRAJECTORY
AND SUPPORT BUFFER A TOOL YOUNG
PEOPLE CAN DEVELOP TO COUNTER
ACT THE EFFECTS OF TRAUMA ON
THEIR DEVELOPMENT. YOU ALL HAVE
JUST HEARD FROM SOMEONE WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND HOMES SO
PLEASE HEAR ME WHEN I SAY YOU
ARE MORE RESILIENT WHEN THEY
HAVE AN ECOSYSTEM OF
RELATIONSHIPS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT MEET
THEM WHERE THEY ARE AND SUPPORT
THEM WHERE THEY NEED. AS FAR TO
GO AND BE A PART OF OUR
COLLECTIVE GOAL TO COLLECTIVELY
. BUILT THE BRIGHTEST FUTURE
HUMANLY POSSIBLE THAT IS GOOD BY
PRINT AND FILLED WITH LOVE FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU TO
PHONE NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
SIMONE TURRET TO LEAVE WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF HOUSING AND
HEALTH WITH THE JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH PLEASE BEGIN
. THANK YOU CHAIR AND THANK YOU
FOR INCLUDING ME ON THIS PANEL-
AGAIN MY NAME IS THE MON TEREK
LEE AND I'M WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH. OUR STATE
HAVE BEEN VERY RESPONSIVE TO THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AMONG YOUTH
EXITING FOSTER CARE I DON'T HAVE
TO MENTION YOU KNOW TO FIND JUST
MENTIONED- EXTENDING SUPPORT FOR
YOUTH WHO. I WOULD HAVE AGED OUT
DURING CARE- DURING THE PANDEMIC
H. OUT FROM CARE- AT TWENTY ONE
BEING ABLE TO REMAINING CARE-
WAS OBVIOUSLY A HUGE- IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT MADE BY THE STATE. I
THINK THE STATE HAS ALSO LONG
RECOGNIZED THE HOMELESSNESS RISK
OF THE POPULATION TWENTY ONE
YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISH THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM CLASS FOR THP
PLUS. IN DIRECT RESPONSE TO
ALARMING RATE THE HOMELESSNESS
AMONG FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THE
PROGRAM IS STILL THRIVING TODAY
AND FORTY SEVEN COUNTIES AND
PROVIDES UP TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO YOUTH WHO
LEAVE FOSTER CARE OR OUT OF FROM
PROBATION UP UNTIL THEY TURN
TWENTY FOUR. THE PROGRAM SERVED
ABOUT THIRTEEN HUNDRED YOU'VE
GOT A MOMENT IN TIME AND YOU
FIFTIES P. PLUS MAKE PROGRESS IN
EDUCATION APPOINTMENT DURING
THEIR TIME IN THE PROGRAM AND
THE VAST MAJORITY. AT THE TO
STABLE HOUSING. SB PLUS WITH
RELY TO THE ELEVEN SO WHEN WE
LEARN THE FOR THE PROGRAM
SIGNIFICANTLY OUTWEIGHED THE
PROGRAM'S CAPACITY. THE STATE
ESTABLISHED A NEW STATE FUNDING
SOURCE THE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM. ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. THE
MAJORITY OF THE FUNDING IS BEING
USED TO EXPAND LOCAL TV PLUS
PROGRAM. AND SO FAR OUT THAT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
ENABLE COUNTIES TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF YOU THINK THIRD BY
OVER TWO HUNDRED YEARS. THE
STATE ALSO RECENTLY INVESTED IN
THE THP PLUS HOUSING SUPPLEMENT
PROGRAM ALSO ADMINISTERED BY
HDD. TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE HI
SCOTT COUNTIES HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING TO PAY MONTHLY RATES TO
THEIR PROVIDERS. THAT ARE HIGH
ENOUGH TO AFFORD LOCAL RENTAL
CAR. IF NINE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IS BEING IMPLEMENTED
IN WILL SOON BENEFIT SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE YOU ACROSS SIX HIGH
COST COUNTIES. ON AND TELL HIM
TO THE NECK QUESTION. YES PLEASE
. WELL I'M STILL REALLY SPEAKING
TO THE HOUSING NEEDS THAT REMAIN
UNMET FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
REALLY THE NUMBER I NEED A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN THE AREA
OF HOUSING IS WE NEED MORE OF
IT- THESE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE NAVIGATING SOME OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE HOUSING MARKET THE
COUNTRY WITH NO REAL RENTAL
HISTORY AND AVERAGE ANNUAL
INCOME OF LESS THAN TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND NO
ONE TO COSIGN WITH THEM OR
OFTENTIMES TO REALLY GUIDE THEM-
THE PANDEMIC HAS REALLY KIND OF
SHOWN A FLASHLIGHT ON THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN YOU COMING
FROM FOSTER CARE AND YOUTH AND
THE GENERAL POPULATION. WHO ARE
ON AVERAGE YOU KNOW LIVING WITH
THEIR PARENTS INTO THEIR
THIRTIES AT THIS POINT AT THE
END OF THE LAST FISCAL YEAR
THERE WERE FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE YOU ON THE WAITING LIST
FOR TRANSITIONAL HOUSING THAT'S
ACTUALLY AN UNDERSTATEMENT
BECAUSE THAT THAT EXTENSION OF
CARE THAT OCTAPHARMA MENTIONED
IN THAT I REFERENCED IN THE
BEGINNING OF MY REMARKS- SO AT A
MINIMUM WE REALLY NEED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS MORE INVESTED IN
THE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
TO INCREASE CAPACITY BY AT LEAST
FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE YEAR. BUT
WE ALSO NEED THESE PROGRAMS TO
BE RESPONSIVE TO YOU TO REQUIRE
LINK YOUR SUPPORT IN TWO YEARS
THIS INCLUDES YOUTH COMPLETING
SCHOOL YOU COOK DISABILITIES AND
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES THAT YOUNG PARENTS
AND OTHERS- AND INVESTMENT OF AN
ADDITIONAL TEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS COULD ADD ONE
MORE YEAR TO THE CHIEF OF
PROGRAM MODEL USED BY COUNTIES
WITHOUT GROWING WAITING LISTS
AND LASTLY WE ARE TAPPING INTO A
KEY FEDERAL RESOURCE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. AND OUR
DIRECTOR SHORTS- REFERENCE THIS
BRIEFLY EARLIER. YOU DEPARTMENT
OF. AND- URBAN DEVELOPMENT ADMIN
TO. PER FOR FORMER. YOUTH AGES
EIGHTEEN THROUGH TWENTY FOUR.
THE FAMILY UNIFICATION PROGRAM
OR FOX. AND APOSS USED
INDEPENDENT FINISHES FYI. BOTH
PROGRAMS PROVIDE HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHERS ADMINISTERED LOCALLY BY
PUBLIC HOUSING AUTHORITIES
COUPLED WITH THE PORT OF
SERVICES PROVIDED BY COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES. WHILE
THE VOUCHER IS FUNDED BY HON.
THERE IS NO DESIGNATED FUNDING
FOR THE THIRD WITH THAT. MANY
COUNTIES REPORT OBSTACLES IN
UTILIZING THE FEDERAL RESOURCE
AND AT THE END OF THE LAST
FISCAL YEAR. THERE WERE EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY ABOUT TRUTH IN
OUR STATE AND JUST TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT OF THEM WERE FY I
ABOUT TRUTH WHICH CAN BE
REQUESTED. ON DEMAND THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT THESE ARE IT SHOULD BE
ACCEPTABLE VOUCHERS. SOME
COUNTIES DO NOT REQUEST VOUCHERS
FOR THE REQUEST TO FEEL BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT OFFER THE REQUIRED
SERVICES WITHOUT DEDICATED
FUNDING. IN COUNTIES WITHOUT
YOUR LEVEL OF HOUSING NAVIGATION
SUPPORT PROVIDED REALLY VERY.
AND IT'S OFTEN NOT ENOUGH IN
SOME COUNTY THAT REQUIRES SIX TO
NINE MONTHS TO CONVERT ABOUT HER
THE ACTUAL HOUSING. BURGER
HOUSING AUTHORITY CANNOT REQUEST
ADDITIONAL DOCTORS AND LYFT 90%
OF THEIR EXISTING DOCTOR ARE
UTILIZED. MEANING IN ACTIVE
LEASES. IT MEANS THAT EVEN WHEN
DOCTORS ARE IN CIRCULATION. IF
YOU ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND
HOUSING HOUSING AUTHORITY CANNOT
REQUEST ADDITIONAL VOUCHERS AND
YOUTH WHO ARE IN NEED REMAIN ON
THE WAITING LIST. WHICH TOTAL
TWO HUNDRED NINETY YOUTH AT THE
END OF THE LAST FISCAL YEAR. AN
INVESTMENT OF EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE STATE
EXISTING HOUSING NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM. AN INCREASE IN THE
UPPER AGE LIMIT TO ALIGN WITH
FACTOR AGE ELIGIBILITY. WOULD
PROVIDE COUNTIES WITH FUNDING TO
IMPROVE UTILIZATION OF THE
FEDERAL VOUCHER. THE STATE HAS
RECOGNIZED THE NEED FOR THE
FUNDING THROUGH A SHORT TERM
PILOT PROPOSED FOR EXTENSION AS
REFERENCED BY DIRECTOR SHORT.
INVESTMENT OR RECOMMENDING WOULD
ADDRESS THIS IN THE LONG TERM.
INVESTMENT THAT MENTIONED TO
TOTAL THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM. AND HOW THE
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM OPENED
MINISTER BY HDD AND. SITUATED IN
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FOR PARTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND FOR A WHOLE FROM. HEARING
THANK YOU NEXT HEAR FROM JIM PER
WHO THE INTERIM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES DIRECTOR
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS AGAIN
MENTION YOUR PRIOR ON THE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES IT IS A
PRIVILEGE TO BE A PART OF
TODAY'S DISCUSSION ENJOYING
LISTING PARTNERS ON THIS PANEL.
AS AS THE LARGEST CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY IN THE NATION WE
CONSTANTLY FACE THE IMPORTANT
ISSUES OF COMPLEX CARE
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH NEEDS AS
WELL AS WORKFORCE AND CAPACITY
CHALLENGES. WE KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING INVESTMENTS
TO SUPPORT AND IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR THE CHILDREN NEWS IN
FAMILIES WE SIR AND TO PREVENT
ENTRY INTO THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. THIS IS ONE OF THE MANY
REASONS WHY OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS JUST CO SPONSORING A
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO MAINTAIN
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES. ANGELES
COUNTY HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
PREVENTION WORK FOR SOME TIME
AND IS NOW IN THE MIDST OF
TRANSITIONING TO THE FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES BACK
ARE AFFECT TSA. NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE NEED TO OFFER CRITICAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS SOCIAL
WORKERS IN THEIR ENDEAVOR TO
HELP STRENGTHEN FAMILIES SO THAT
CHILDREN. BRING YOUR MAIN SAFELY
AT HOME. I WORKFORCE IS. SOCIAL
WORKERS AND OTHER CHILD WELFARE
PROFESSIONALS I'M IN THIS
LITERALLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT TOOLS THAT WE HAVE. IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND WELLBEING
OF ABUSED AND NEGLECTED
CHILDREN. THIS OF COURSE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE BUT AS A
LIFELONG CHILD WELFARE
PROFESSIONAL I CAN ATTEST. THAT
DUE TO THE SEVERE STRESSES ON
FAMILIES. AND THE TREMENDOUS
TRAUMA MANY OF THE CHILDREN IN
OUR SYSTEM HAVE EXPERIENCE IT
HAS NEVER BEEN SO IMPORTANT TO
HAVE A WELL STAFFED. AND WELL
TRAINED WORKFORCE WORKERS WHO
HAVE TIME. TRAINING AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AND THAT THEY NEED
AND THAT THEY DESERVE. BECAUSE
OF THIS WORKFORCE REALITY THE
COUNTY HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN STAFFING AND
SERVICES TO PRESERVE CHILD
SAFETY AND REUNIFY FAMILIES.
WITHOUT THE REQUESTED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
ON THE ALLOCATION WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT BEING FORCED TO
MAKE TOUGH DECISIONS ABOUT
STAFFING. THAT COULD IMPACT REX
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE. SO WHAT
ARE THE MAIN CHALLENGES FACING
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CHANGES IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. MULTIPLE
OVERLAPPING FACTORS SUCH AS LOSS
OF FUNDS AND FLEXIBILITY WITH
THE TITLE FOURTEEN LABOR. VASTLY
INCREASED EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
COST INSUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR
STATE MANDATED PROGRAMS HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT. THE NINETEEN NINETY ONE
AND TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT SHIFTED FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY FROM THE STATE.
TO COUNTIES FOR CERTAIN PROGRAMS
WHICH AFFECTED FUNDING FOR THE
CHILD WELFARE POPULATION. SO FOR
EXAMPLE AB TWELVE EXPANDED THIS
POPULATION WITHOUT A
CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
REVENUES AS WAS ANTICIPATED AND
ORIGINALLY INTENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. RESULTING IN LARGE
AND GROWING EFC COSTS FOR THE
COUNTY. ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THERE WAS A LOSS OF FLEXIBILITY
IN FUNDING THAT CAME WITH THE
TITLE FORTY WAIVER WITHOUT CHILD
WELFARE FINANCING REFORM TO
ADDRESS. DECLINING FEDERAL
ELIGIBILITY ALL. ANTIQUATED INTO
PRESS. AND LIMITATIONS IMPOSED
BY THE NINETEEN NINETY SIX EIGHT
TO FAMILY. WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN A FTC LOOK BACK BECAUSE
THE NON FEDERAL SHARE COSTS ON
TO GROW CONCERT- SIGNIFICANTLY.
THE COUNTY HAS MADE AND IS
MAKING LARGE INVESTMENTS IN
CRITICAL CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
TO PRODUCE BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. AMONG THE
INVESTMENTS MADE OUR- DCFS HIRED
OVER A THOUSAND SOCIAL WORKERS
AND TWO HUNDRED SUPERVISING
CHILDREN'S SOCIAL WORKERS OF
NOTE. COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE INVESTMENTS INCREASE
ANNUALLY WE HAVE ALSO INVESTED
IN SERVICES SUCH AS PREVENTION
AFTER CARE NETWORK'S UPFRONT
FAMILY FINDING. PLACEMENT
STABILIZATION SCHOOL STABILITY
AND TRANSPORTATION MEDICAL HUBS
AND SCHOOLS LGBTQ PLUS SERVICES
AND OUR OFFICE OF EQUITY. THE
ANNUAL TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST WILL HELP THE
COUNTY MAINTAIN THESE CRITICAL
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES. WOW WHAT
ARE PRIORITY CONCERNS MOVING
FORWARD AND WHAT ARE THE
FORESEEABLE IMPACTS FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES AS WELL AS
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM STAFF
EMPLOYED BY THE COUNTY. THE
COUNTY IS CONCERNED ABOUT BEING
FORCED TO MAKE TOUGH DECISIONS
ABOUT STAFFING AND OTHER
INVESTMENTS THAT CAN IMPACT
DIRECT SERVICES TO THE CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE. IF
WE DO NOT RECEIVE THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
REQUEST THE POTENTIAL IMPACTS
COULD INCLUDE THE COUNTY
REVERTING BACK TO STAFFING
LEVELS THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO THE
RECENT CRITICAL INVESTMENTS.
LOWER STAFFING LEVELS WILL
RESULT IN INCREASED CASELOADS
AND WORKLOADS LEADING TO AT RISK
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES
RECEIVING LESS INDIVIDUALIZED
SUPPORT INCLUDING THOSE WITH
COMPLEX NEEDS. NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON TIMELY RESPONSES TO YOU
ENCLOSURE OF REFERRALS
REUNIFICATION AND- OF VIRTUAL
TRAINING AND USE LESS SUPPORT OF
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH TO HELP
THEM DEVELOP SELF SUFFICIENCY
SKILLS. AND LINK THEM TO MUCH
NEEDED COMMUNITY RESOURCES ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY I
ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON OUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND YOUR
PARTNERSHIP TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF THE DEPARTMENT
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. AND IT'S
POTENTIAL HARMFUL IMPACT
AFFORDABLE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
TIFFANY WHITENED WITH SEIU.
CALIFORNIA PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. TIFFANY WHITE
WITH THAT YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA-
AGAIN THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY I'LL BE RESPONDING TO TWO
QUESTIONS PROVIDED BY THE
COMMITTEE SO I'LL JUST JUMP
RIGHT IN THE FIRST QUESTION IS
HOW HAVE INVESTMENTS THAT L. A.
COUNTY MADE HELPED WORKERS
PROVIDE BETTER SERVICES TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
INVESTMENTS HAVE GONE A LONG WAY
AND HAVE HAD A REAL EFFECT ON
LIVES BOTH THE WORKERS AND THE
FAMILIES THEY SERVED I THINK WE
CAN WE HEARD BACK FROM THIS-
PRIOR JUST A MINUTE AGO THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING HELPED
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF SOCIAL
WORKERS WHICH IN RETURN HELPS
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF CASES EACH
WORKER MAINTAINED A REDUCTION IN
CASELOAD ALLOW THE EXISTING
FAMILIES AND THE NEW FAMILIES TO
RECEIVE THE PROPER SIR SUPPORT
AND SERVICES THEY NEED IT.
ADDITIONAL WORKERS ALSO ALLOWED
FOR SERVICES TO BE PROVIDED IN A
MORE TIMELY MANNER AND ALLOW FOR
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES TO BE
TAKEN IN ORDER TO BETTER SERVE
AND MITIGATE ANY FUTURE NEEDS
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES TO RECEIVE
CONTINUITY OF SERVICES SO
ANOTHER INVESTMENT THAT WAS
INSTITUTED WAS A PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO HELP SUPPORT THE
SOCIAL WORKER AND PROVIDE
CONTINUITY OF SERVICES AMONG
OTHER THINGS. THE PROGRAM
PARTNERED NEW AND RECENTLY HIRED
WORKERS IT SEASONED WORKERS AND
CREATED A MENTOR SHIP PROGRAM
THAT PROVED TO BE VALUABLE AND
ALSO REDUCE TURNOVER WHICH
ULTIMATELY PROVIDED BETTER
CONTINUITY OF SERVICES WE HAVE
SEEN THAT IF THE WORKERS ARE
BEING INVESTED IN AND SUPPORTED
OUTCOMES WHAT'S REALLY BE BETTER
FOR ALL. ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF AN
INVESTMENT THAT TRULY MADE A
DIFFERENCE WITH THE MOU BETWEEN
LA DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND THE LA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
MO YOU CONNECTED A PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE WITH THE SOCIAL WORKER AND
THEY WENT ON EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CALLS TOGETHER. THIS PROVED TO
BE BENEFICIAL ON A NUMBER OF
LEVELS AGAIN THE SOCIAL WORKER
WAS SUPPORTED WITH THE
ASSISTANCE FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL BUT ULTIMATELY THE
PAIR WAS ABLE TO BETTER SERVE
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND IN
SOME CASES ENSURE THAT FAMILIES
WITH HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS RECEIVE THE SERVICES
NECESSARY WHICH REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN THAT WERE
BROUGHT INTO CARE. HAVING THE
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY I AM. RAPPER
SERVICE. IS CRUCIAL FOR THE WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES. HAVING THE PROPER
ONGOING FUNDING AND SUPPORT
LEADS TO BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
CHILD. OR CHILD SAFETY WELL
BEING A PERMANENCY AND THEY USE
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION TO
INDEPENDENCE. THESE ARE JUST A
FEW EXAMPLES TO ADD TO THE ONCE
AGAIN THEM AS PRIOR INDICATED-
EARLIER AND TOGETHER THESE
INVESTMENTS. DEMONSTRATE THE
NEED AND IMPORTANCE FOR THE
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS. L. A.
COUNTY IS CLOSE TO MEET IN HE
S. B. TWENTY THIRTY TWO. I'M
THIRTY SOCIAL WORKER A STAFFING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE
CONTINUED FINANCIAL INVESTMENTS
WILL HELP KEEP THEM ON TRACK TO
DO JUST THAT. THE SECOND
QUESTION IS WHAT ARE. YOUR
WORKERS WORRIED ABOUT IF THIS
FUNDING IS NOT PROVIDED TO L. A.
COUNTY. SIMPLY PUT OUR WORKERS
ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE CHILDREN
AND THE FAMILIES THAT THEY
SERVE. AS DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANTS THEIR PRIMARY GOAL AND
FOCUS IS ON THE WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN AND THE FAMILY AS A
WHOLE. ABSENT THIS CONTINUED
FUNDING THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN THAT
WOULD GO WITHOUT SERVICES AND
THE EFFECTS OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE NEAR TERM AND IN THE FUTURE.
NOT HAVING ACCESS OR CONTACT
WITH THE WORK WITH THE WORKER
CAN BE HARMFUL TO THE CHILDREN
SO THE CONTINUED FUNDING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH L. A. COUNTY.
AS NECESSARY TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN. ARE WORKERS ARE ALSO
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IF WE
HAVE A REDUCTION IN STAFF. WILL
CASELOADS RISE AGAIN WOULD BE
HIGH TURNOVER BUT EVEN MORE THAN
THAT IS WILL WE HAVE MORE ABUSED
AND NEGLECTED CHILDREN THAT ARE
PUT AT RISK BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
RECEIVING THE SERVICES. THEY
NEED. SO I'LL JUST CONCLUDE THAT
THE FUNDING IS NOT ONLY
NECESSARY BUT IT'S CRITICAL I'M
TO CONTINUE THE INVESTMENTS MADE
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS. SUPPORT OUR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AND PROVIDE THEM
WITH THE CONTINUITY OF SERVICES
TO ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF YOU ACT.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
KATHY SANDERLING MCDONALD
EXECUTIVE. DIRECTOR WITH DWTS.
THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
CAPIZ LIMIT. C. D. WE WERE ASKED
TO- SHARED SOME OF OUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT THE LONG TERM GOALS OF OUR
SYSTEM OF CARE FOR YOUTH WITH
COMPLEX NEEDS AND ALSO TALK A
BIT ABOUT- TRANSITION AND OUR
WORKFORCE AS WELL SO ALL TACKLE
ALL THREE OF THOSE- THOSE ISSUES
FOR YOU NOW. REGARDING THE LONG
TERM GOALS OF HOW WE PROVIDE
CARE FOR YOUTH WITH THE MOST
COMPLEX NEEDS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT A COUPLE THINGS
ONE WALKING A FEW WHO WITH THE
MOST COMPLEX CARE NEEDS. ARE
CERTAINLY NOT THE MAJORITY OF
OUR YOUTH ARE THEY ARE SOME OF
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE MEMBERS
SPEND THE MOST TIME WORKING WITH
AND SEEKING PLACEMENTS AND
SERVICES FOR. AND IN ADDITION
THAT THE NEEDS TO SERVE THESE
ARE JUST THAT'S RELATIVELY SMALL
BUT IMPORTANT POPULATION ARE NOT
NEW AND THEY WERE CREATED BY THE
C. R. THEY'VE EXISTED FOR YEARS
AND HAVE GROWN IN IMPORTANCE AND
VISIBILITY OVERTIME. I THINK AS
WE UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT THE
NEEDS AND- HAVE MORE ATTENTION
PAID TO ENSURING THAT WERE.
MEETING YOUTH AND FAMILIES NEEDS
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM MORE QUICKLY
AND MORE THOROUGHLY THAN WE MAY
HAVE IN THE PAST. I WILL SAY
THAT THE ISSUE WAS ALSO
EXACERBATED BY CCR THOUGH IN THE
SENSE THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE C. R. AND TO SOME DEGREE
ALSO WHAT WE'LL SEE I THINK WITH
THE FAMILY FIRST. PREVENTION
SERVICE ACT IMPLEMENTATION HAS
RESULTED IN FOR BETTER OR WORSE
A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF PROVIDERS WE HAVE FOR
YOU THREE NEED OF HIGH END
BEHAVIOR HEALTH IN. PARTICULAR
TREATMENT SERVICE. SO WHILE WE
WERE A- THE THAT WAS PROVIDED IN
THE CURRENT YEAR AND ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE STATE AND WITH
OUR COUNTY AGENCY PARTNERS AND
SERVICE PARTNERS. TO ENSURE THAT
IT'S WELL SPENT AND THAT IS
BROUGHT TO BEAR TO- ASSIST AND
HELP US. REALLY SURVEYS YOUTH IN
A BETTER WAY WHAT WE REALLY
THINK OF NEEDED AS A STATEWIDE
APPROACH WITH STATE LEADERSHIP
TO IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS THE
SYSTEMIC ISSUES. THAT EXIST
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM IN LIKE I SAID
EXISTED BEFORE CPR I WILL NOW BE
FRIGHTENED WITH CCR AND WITH
AFFECT PSA- THIS STATE
SUBLICENSING STANDARDS ENFORCES
THE STANDARDS TO REPLACE
SOMETHING OVERSIGHT. AND THAT'S%
RATE FOR FOSTER CARE PROVIDERS
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
ANALYSIS THAT THE STATE IS
WORKING ON REQUIRED BY AB TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE. RESULTS IN
RECOMMENDATION OF NEW TYPES OF
SERVICE PROVIDERS THEIR NEW
TYPES OF PLACEMENTS IT'S REALLY
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED THAT
LEADERSHIP FROM THE STATE.
BACKED BY COUNTY IS BACKED BY
SERVICE PROVIDERS- BOTH LIKE THE
ALLIANCE AND CHRIS AND HER GROUP
OF OUR OTHER COUNTY AGENCIES TO
REALLY HELP MAKE THAT WORK. BUT
WE NEED THE FOREFRONT TO REALLY
HELP. CREATE THAT MAKE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND REALLY DRIVE
BACK TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
CREATE THAT THEIR SERVICES AND
THE NEW PLACEMENTS WE ALSO NEED%
ACROSS EACH OF THE CONVERSATION.
DHC AT EDS EDUCATION OUR
REGIONAL CENTER PARTNERS NOT
JUST THE STATE LEVEL REALLY ALL
THE TO BE AT THE TABLE IN ORDER
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO REALLY MAKE
THIS WORK BECAUSE SO MANY OF.
THE YEAR BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- ARE SERVED IN MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS THAT I WOULD. I ALSO
NEGLECT TO MENTION PROBATION
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY. WE DO HAVE YOU TO
CRAFT BETWEEN THE SYSTEM. FOR
HOME- I'VE BEEN THAT MAY BE TRUE
BY A TRUMP EVENT OR REMEMBER A
TRUCK DRAMATIC ABOUT THAT
OCCURRED. OR NOT RECEIVING
SERVICES THAT THEY NEEDED AT THE
POINT IN TIME WHEN THEY REALLY
NEED OF THAT. CAN CREATE
BEHAVIORS THAT- THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN ARE RESULTING IN
DAMAGE ARE HARM TO THEMSELVES OR
TO OTHERS AND ALL IT TAKES IS
ONE PHONE CALL THAT'S WHY WE
WORK SO CLOSELY WITH YOUR CHAIR
ARAMBULA. TO PUT FIRST AT THE
PLACE THAT FAMILY REJECT
RESPONSE SYSTEM THAT'S ROLLED
OUT THAT STILL YOU KNOW IN ITS
INFANCY BUT WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
HUNDREDS OF CALLS TO THE
HOTLINE. WHERE THESE TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS CAN HELP TO
DIFFUSE THE SITUATION SO THE
CALL THE GO TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OR THE CALL DOESN'T GO TO A
SOCIAL WORKER AND SAY COME GET
pWANT THEM HERE ANYMORE AND ADD
TO THAT SERIES OF A FEELING OF
REJECTION AND FAILURE THAT WE
KNOW SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE FEEL
AND REALLY- INTERNALIZED. AND
THAT HAPPENS WITH FURTHER. ALONG
WITH THAT- AND SO. A COUPLE
THINGS THAT I JUST TO SEE. WERE
TO FUNDING THAT WAS FROM IN THE
YEAR. FIRST REGARDING THE CHILD.
FINDING WE'RE PROPOSING THAT THE
PROCESS FOR COUNTIES TO BE ABLE
TO SPEND THAT FUNDING BE I
SWITCHED UP A LITTLE BIT.
CURRENTLY THE PROCESS IS THAT
THAT COUNTY BUT TO PUT A REQUEST
IN THE STATE THAT MUST REVIEW
AND APPROVE THE REQUEST AND ONLY
AT THAT POINT YOU HAVE THAT
COUNTY PROVIDE THOSE. SERVICES
WITHOUT FINDING WE REALLY THINK
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY IS CRITICAL
HERE WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE NO ISSUE
WITH ACCOUNTABILITY. BUT WE
THINK THAT COUNTY THAT IS HAS A
YEAR. WHO WAS IMMEDIATELY AT
THAT MOMENT EXPERIENCING INDEED
WHICH IS WHAT WE TYPICALLY HEAR
ABOUT. SHOULD NOT HAVE TO ASK
FOR PERMISSION TO PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT YOU'VE EVEN THAT
MOMENT AND THEN WAIT FOR
APPROVAL WHETHER THAT'S A DAY OR
WEEK IT'S STILL. THAT THE STATE
NEED IS NOW AND SO WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN INSTEAD IS
THAT COUNTIES UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR. AND
THAT THEY ARE ALLOWED TO SPEND
THOSE FUNDS PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES FOR THOSE USED AND THEN
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION TO THE
STATE ON HOW THE FUNDS WERE USED
IN FOR HOME AND WHY. SO IT'S AN
AFTER THE FACT REPORT RATHER
THAN A PERMISSION REQUEST THAT
COULD DELAY THE PROVISION OF
NEEDED SERVICES WE JUST. WE
THINK THIS IS A SORT OF WHATEVER
IT TAKES MOMENT EVERYTHING AT
THE MOMENT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE WHATEVER IT TAKES SO
THAT'S- THAT'S ONE THING- WE
ALSO. ARE REVIEWING YOUR HEAD OF
WHAT IT IS THAT COUNTIES OF
REQUESTED WHAT MAY HAVE BEEN A
LOUDER OR QUESTION. I KNOW THAT
MOST OF WHAT'S BEEN ASKED FOR
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BUT WE THINK
THAT IT MAY BE ON THE NEEDED FOR
US TO BROADEN. OUR THE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE A LITTLE BIT ON WHAT
THE WHAT THE FUNDING COULD BE
USED FOR SO WE'LL FOLLOW UP
WITH. THE STATEMENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WITH YOUR COMMITTEE
AND STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT WE.
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS WE
MOVE OUR WORK- AND THEN I JUST
SORT OF ONE MORE THING TO IS
THAT WE ARE COULD TO MONITOR
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE YOUTH
WHO CAME BACK INTO OUR STATE IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE FROM THE
OUT OF STATE CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITIES YOU I'M SURE CALL A
BIG TOPIC OF OUR CONVERSATION
LAST YEAR WAS THAT- ALL OF THE
OTHER THREE CONGREGATE
FACILITIES WERE DECERTIFIED AT
THE SAME TIME- A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE USED ACROSS CHILD
WELFARE OR PROBATION WERE
BROUGHT BACK TO CALIFORNIA. AND
WE HAVE BEEN RECEIVING WILL BE
UNTIL DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE WERE RECEIVING MONTHLY
UPDATES ON THE FIELD AND WE DID
SEE SHIPS OVER TIME FROM MANY OF
THE YOUTH INITIALLY RETURNING TO
RELATIVE PLACEMENTS
UNFORTUNATELY THAT DROPPED FROM
42% 226% OF THE PLACEMENTS WHICH
WAS THE LARGEST PERCENTAGE
DECREASE OF A CATEGORY- AND IT
LOOKED LIKE IT THOSE YOUTH ENDED
UP I'M GOING TO CONGREGATE CARE
JUVENILE HALL OBVIOUSLY NOT
IDEAL SHELTER FACILITIES YOU
KNOW NOT EVERY COUNTY HAS AGAIN
ALSO NOT AT A PERMANENT TYPE OF
PLACEMENT. FOR UNFORTUNATELY-
THEY THEY ARE NOT IN PLACE WE
DON'T KNOW THEY RAN AWAY IN SOME
WAY AND THAT OBVIOUSLY IS IT'S
NOT WHAT WE WANT I MEAN THAT THE
CONCERN. I THINK IS THAT- WE
DON'T THINK THE YOUTH ARRESTED
FOR GETTING WHAT THEY NEED. WE
HAVE GIVEN WILL BE WORK WITH TO
TRY MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN- WORK
TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY PLACEMENT
OPTIONS WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. ON THAT IN
OUR STATE PARTNERS PROVIDE I
THINK AT TIMES- ROLLING UP OUR
SLEEVES A LITTLE MORE AND MAYBE-
REALLY. HAVING THAT- GO TO A
FRUITION OF ACTUAL PLACEMENT IS
SOMETHING THAT MAY NOT HAPPEN AS
MUCH AS I COUNTIES WOULD LIKE
AND SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WORK WITH THE STATE. TO TRY TO
ENGAGE IN TA AND ALSO PUSH THE
ENVELOPE ON WHAT THAT SHE A
INCLUDES I THINK THAT'S OUR JOB
AT THAT AT THE COUNTY PARTNERS.
THAT AS ALL OF US NOW. ONE THING
I GONNA USE TO THE WHO ARE
UNANSWERED I MENTIONED OF COURSE
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING PROGRAM
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON. IN
ADDITION- SORRY- MY DOOR ABOUT
THIS RIGHT AND NOW I HAVE
DOLLARS THE HOPE WE COULD NOT
REALLY- WE ALSO ARE WORKING WITH
A FAMILY MEMBER COOLEY ON A
REQUEST FOR A TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM. FOR MINORS- THE
ISSUE HERE IS THAT THE FAMILY
FIRST ACTING MAKES. SOME OF THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING OPTIONS
THAT WE HAD NO LONGER AT ABLE TO
BE FOUND IN A FEDERAL WAY AND SO
WE- WANT TO BE ABLE TO COMPLY.
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF FAMILY
FIRST SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
OPERATE THESE FACILITIES AND SO-
WE'RE PROPOSING SOME CHANGES TO
HOW THAT PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED
WE THINK THAT THAT WILL
DEFINITELY HELP IT CERTAINLY
ADDRESS OF THE ISSUES THAT
MATTER WEALTHY PASSED AS WELL.
AND THEN FINALLY- WE DO KNOW
THAT WE WERE ASKED TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE WORK FORCE ISSUES.
THAT COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES ARE EXPERIENCING AND AT
WHAT POINT DID A REALLY ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES AND- I MEAN THAT'S
A THAT'S A FANTASTIC QUESTION
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
REALLY. I'M IN A LOT OF PLACES
STRUGGLING WITH TO BE QUITE
HONEST WITH YOU. IN PARTICULAR-
WE ARE WE VALUE TREMENDOUSLY
SOCIAL WORKERS- WHO HAVE A
MASTERS IN SOCIAL WORK OUR OUR
DEGREED SOCIAL WORK
PROFESSIONALS ARE A HUGE
RESOURCE AND HALF THAT. FOR OUR
PROGRAMS AND IN PARTICULAR THESE
MASTERS DEGREED. PROFESSIONALS
ARE. REALLY CRITICAL NOT TO FROM
HIM SERVICES. BUT IN OUR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SYSTEM. AS WELL
AS OTHER A- THAT WE WERE WITH
AND SO- I FOR. OUR SOCIAL WORK
SCHOOLS ARE IMPACTED THEY CAN
NOT ALLOW EVERYONE WHO WANTS
THAT AND INSTEAD OF YOU AGAIN
BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
SPOTS. THAT ARE NECESSARY AND SO
WE'RE PARTNERING WITH BE
CALIFORNIA'S ASSOCIATION OF
DEANS AND DIRECTORS OF THE
SOCIAL WORK SCHOOLS AS WELL AS
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS. AND S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL TO
PROPOSE A TRUTHFUL ONE WOULD
ALLOW- AN INCREASE AND FIVE TO
BETTER MEET THAT DEMAND AND THEN
THE OTHER PART OF THE PROPOSAL
WOULD. SUPPORT FIELD PLACEMENTS
THOSE ARE THAT PLACEMENTS THAT
THAT OUR STUDENTS DO IN YEARS
ONE AND TWO OF THE PROGRAM FOR
THEIR ACTUALLY PLACED WITHIN
AGENCY THEY SEE HOW IT WORKS ON
THE GROUND THEY GET THAT
SUPERVISION. AND IT'S A REQUIRED
PART OF THEIR WORK AND SO BEING
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING OUR SOCIAL WORK
SCHOOLS ON BOTH WITH SLOTS AS
WELL AS WITH THOSE FIELD
PLACEMENT OPPORTUNITY. TO ENABLE
THE SOCIAL WORK STUDENTS TO SEE
WHAT'S GOING TO BE LIKE WHEN
THEY'RE PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES
IN A PUBLIC AGENCY WERE HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN RECRUIT MORE TO WORK
IN THE PUBLIC AND NONPROFIT
SECTORS. AND SUPPORT THEM SO
THEY KNOW YOU KNOW KIND OF WHAT
THE JOB IS AND IDEALLY WE CAN
REDUCE TURNOVER AND BURNOUT
WHICH ARE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN OUR WORK FORCE JUST AS
WE SEE THROUGHOUT SO MANY OF
THAT THE WORKFORCE ISSUES THAT
WERE SPEAKING TO THE PANDEMIC.
ALL RIGHT NOW TO DIFFICULT JOB
AND SO- WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
WORKFORCE- OUR GROUP IS MEETING
WITH EACH HIGH- SHORTLY I THINK
NEXT WEEK TO TALK ABOUT OUR
PROPOSAL AND SEE HOW IT CAN. FIT
TOGETHER- BUT WERE EXCITED ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITIES AND WE THINK
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT. OUR SCHOOLS OF
SOCIAL WORK THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES. MY REMARKS HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WILL IT UP TO THE
DÍAS NOW I WILL BEGIN BY- ONE
EXPLORE. THANK TREVAN WILKES
HIS. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH IT IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. FOR US TO
HAVE PEOPLE WITH LIVED
pTHESE TABLES AND- REALLY
APPRECIATED YOUR COMMENTS AND-
OPTIMISM. OF HOW WE ARE ABLE TO
RISE ABOVE THE ADVERSITY THAT WE
HAVE SO THAT WE CAN HEAL AND
GROW. I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ASK
TWO QUESTIONS NOW IF THE
ADMINISTRATION IF I COULD
FOLLOWING UP ON- SIMONE CORRECT
LEASE QUESTION REGARDING THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM.
SHE HAD STATED THAT THERE'S NO
FUNDING FOR THE SERVICES THAT WE
HAVE FOR- THE FOSTER YOUTH WHO
ARE IN THE SYSTEM. THAT I'D LIKE
TO UNDERSTAND- AFTER
IMPLEMENTATION OF CAL AIM- OR
THROUGH THE CHILDREN'S AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
WILL WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
FUNDING. FOR SERVICES WRAPAROUND
SERVICES FOR THIS POPULATION.
QUESTION WILL BE FRIENDLY
SCHWARTZ IF YOU'RE STILL ON. I'M
HERE- IN TERMS OF THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES FOR OUR YOUTH AND OUR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING- THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE I THINK THE
RECORD THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED
WITH CALAMP. CERTAINLY APPLY TO
ALL OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE AND SO
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET THAT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND I THINK
THE IMPROVEMENTS AND
STREAMLINING THAT WERE MADE IN
THE CALLING PROCESS TO HAVE THAT
ELIGIBILITY- ESTABLISHED BY
VIRTUE OF THE FACT THAT THESE
ARE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
FOSTER CARE. WELL AID AND NOT SO
HOPEFULLY WE ARE REMOVING SOME
OF THOSE. HERE'S TO BEING ABLE
TO RECEIVE THAT SUPPORT- AND THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT AND THE
TURKMENS. I'M I WILL ASK MY
FINAL QUESTION AND I'D LIKE TO
DRAW A COMPARISON TO OUR- DDS
POPULATION THAT FOCUSES ON
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS AN OUTREACH
AS WELL WITHIN THAT POPULATION
WE HAVE BOTH. A STAR AND A CAST
TEAM THAT HELP US TO DO SOME OF
THE TA AND OUTREACH THAT'S
NEEDED WITH COUNTY IS THAT I'D
LIKE TO ASK EXPLICITLY WHETHER
OR NOT WE HAVE A NEED TO PER
STRIKE TEAMS. WITHIN OUR CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES POPULATION
SIMILARLY TO HELP US WITH OUT OF
REACH AND WORKING WITH COUNTIES
HOPING THE ADMINISTRATION CAN
COMMENT ON THAT. AGAIN APOLOGIES. I'M SORRY ADDING AND IT
STRUGGLING TO GET MY I THINK MY
CONNECTIONS A LITTLE SLOW AND
I'M STRUGGLING TO GET MY STUFF
UP YET I APOLOGIZE AND WE DO
HAVE A TWENTY EIGHTY THREE
STRAIGHT TEAM- THAT INCLUDES OUR
STATE PARTNERS- AND IS THERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE COUNTY THE LOCAL
OPERATE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AS
THEY'RE DOING- BEAR TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE WORK AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND THEN ALSO IS INVOLVED
IN THE- TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CALLS. WHO CONTENDS THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS REALLY
AROUND THE STOMACH ISSUES AND
PART OF HOW TO BUILD THE SYSTEMS
NEEDED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
BEEN A BIT TIME THAT STRAIGHT
FEMALE CALLED IN TO SUPPORT THE
NEEDS OF AN INDIVIDUAL YET BUT
THEN BROUGHT TO THE ATTENTION OF
THAT TEAM- IN ORDER TO TURN
APART ACROSS THE THIN
COLLABORATION FOR MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THAT YOUNG AND THAT WE
DO HAVE THAT BOTTLE- AND UTILIZE
IT REGULARLY. THANK YOU FOR THE
RESP- FINE I JUST LIKE TO KINDLY
ASK THE DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE
TO UPDATE US ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE COMPLEX
CARE NEEDS INITIATIVE INCLUDING.
WHEN THE R. F. P. IS RELEASED
AND THE RESULTS AS THESE
ACTIVITIES HELPED ONE PULLED-
WITH THAT I WOULD LIGHTLY.
THANKS VERY MUCH ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS HERE TODAY. AS A
REMINDER WE WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY ISSUE. ON THE
AGENDA. WE DO HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF EOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEREFORE I WANT TO URGE YOU. TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF SO THAT
WE CAN HEAR FROM EVERYONE. WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. AS A
REMINDER THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE. WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. OPERATOR
WE ARE READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT. POSTED THE TO LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THIS IS JUSTIN GARRETT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AT THE SECOND GRATEFUL
FOR THE RECENT SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS TO FURTHER SUPPORT
FOSTER CHILDREN YOUTH AND KIND
OF LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
BE STRONG PARTNERS ON
IMPLEMENTATION TO ENSURE
SUCCESS. I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
DEDICATED SIGNIFICANT TIME TODAY
TO FOCUS BOTH ON EXCESS
INVITATIONAL THE RECENT
INVESTMENTS AS WELL AS THE MAN
IN ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
ESPECIALLY THE PACKAGE BEING
PROPOSED BY CWDM. IN PARTICULAR
WE WANT TO LEND OUR VOICE TO THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION THAT
OCCURRED TODAY ON RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL. AT THE SECOND
COSPONSORING THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET ASK LISTED EVERY
DAY NET YEAH YOU. KNOW WE AGREE
WITH THE ARGUMENT ARTICULATED BY
STATE AGAIN THAT THE RP PROCESS
WITH A NEW REQUIREMENT. AFTER
TWENTY ELEVEN AT THE INCREASE
COUNTY WORKERS NEEDS TO BE
FUNDED. I WAS HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND WILL HELP
SUPPORT THIS CRITICAL CC ARE
WORKING HELP COUNTIES ME OTHER
CHILD WELFARE MANDATES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MEXICO TO LINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING TIME LACK OF PLANNING
TURN DOWN ABOUT BUSH NOT
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS HERE
GIVE A NOD TO THE INCREASE
INVESTMENT REQUESTS FOR THEY
MIGHT BE TALKING BRIDGE PROPOSAL
FOR FORTY EIGHT NINETY AND- I
THINK AND GROW. AND A REACH-
EARLY RESEARCH ON A PROGRAMS OF
THINGS OKAY THE PLACEMENT MY
CHILDREN AT GREATEST RISK FOR
EXPERIENCING PLACEMENT
INSTABILITY- AND THAT EVIDENCE.
OF BIRTH AND DEATH IN INFANTS
EXPERIENCED THE MOST PLACE AND
MAN DURING THE FIRST MONTH OF
THEIR PLACEMENT COMPARED TO
OLDER CHILDREN. BY ADEQUATELY
SUPPORTING INITIAL TOPIC
REPLACEMENT CLICK MY PIN QUIT
PROVIDING ACCESS TO CHILD CARE.
IT'S REALLY THE KEY TO HELPING
WITH THE PLACEMENT INSTABILITY.
AND FOR THE INITIAL REQUEST FOR
FUNDING WILL HELP COVER ALL THE
COMPANY INCREASED COSTS ARMAR
THAT REGIONAL MARKET RATE. OF
LIKE FAMILY MEMBER KIDS YOU CAN
BENEFIT FROM ABOUT SURE BUT- WE
NEED MORE PEOPLE AND NAVIGATORS
OF THE HEARD ABOUT STATE THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK WITH A KITCHEN
CHAIR THAT CONNECTED CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THAT MEET THEIR FAMILY
NEEDS. AND HELP DEFINE THE
TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING. SHOE
FOCUS ON THE NEEDS OF OUR CARE
GIVERS FOR RESILIENCY TO SUPPORT
THE CHILDREN. AND ADULTS IN
THEIR LIVES THANK YOU. THEY YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT COLOR PLEASE.
MEXICO TO LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE THANK YOU
MISTER TERRY MEMBERS BOB LANE
WITH- WE APPRECIATE YOU
INCLUDING OUR VOICE AND STATE
HERE AND WE WANT TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR THE- PHOTOSTAT
PARTICULAR THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
AND PATIENT FAMILIES FIRST
PREVENTION ACT AND THE CHILD
WELFARE DISPARITIES I'M IN
CLOSING I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT PROVIDERS ARE SUFFERING
STILL DO THE WORK FORCE
SHORTAGES WE SIMPLY CANNOT
PROVIDE SERVICES WITHOUT CENTRAL
STAFF. IN FACT ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS ACTUALLY HAD TO SHUT
DOWN BEDS IN THEIR CLINICS
PASTED A LACK OF STAFFING IN
SOME CASES ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFFS- WHO ARE CAPABLE ARE
PROVIDING CLINICAL SERVICES TO
HELP ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE WHERE
THANK YOU FOR THE HISTORIC
FUNDING IN THIS BUDGET AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION AND
THIS TIME OF CRISIS AND HISTORIC
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MEXICO TO LINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JORDAN SO
THANK CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A TWENTY
ONE MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE STATE BUDGET AND
ONGOING FOR THE GOVERNOR
SPONSORING A TAX CREDIT BUILDING
ON CALIFORNIA'S SUCCESSFUL
POVERTY REDUCTION APPROACHES. TO
THE CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT A YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
WE ALL COLLECT REQUESTED
INCREASE TO THE ANNUAL BUDGET
FOR THE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BY
TWENTY FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FIND THE- THIRD YEAR
OF PHP PLUS AND CREATE
ADDITIONAL HOUSING FOUGHT FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. NEXT WE WOULD LIKE
TO REQUEST AN INCREASE AT THE
ANNUAL BUDGET FOR THE HOUSING
NAVIGATOR PROGRAMS AND INCREASE
THE UPPER AGE LIMIT TO ALIGN
WITH THE FEDERAL HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHER PROGRAM SO THAT YOU CAN
ACCESS HOUSING NAVIGATOR
PROGRAMS THROUGH THE AGE OF
TWENTY FOUR INSTEAD OF THE EIGHT
TWENTY ONE AND EXPAND THE
PRIORITY POPULATION FROM FOSTER
USED TO ALSO INCLUDE FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND CHANGE THE NAME
OF THE PROGRAM TO THE HOUSING
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM. FINALLY WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROMOTE COORDINATION FOR YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE COORDINATION FOR
YOU THE FOSTER CARE TO ACTIVE
FUNDS FOR EXTRACURRICULAR
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES ESPECIALLY
WITH THE IMPACT THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC FOSSEY'S DESERVE TO BE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY WORK. AND
COMPASSION THANK YOU. THANK
OPERATOR CALLER. AND IF YOU LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT IN THE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE ONE
MOMENT. THAT WE HAVE ONE PERSON
Q. AND UP JUST A MOMENT.
KELLY GUIDELINE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY COSTS AND LEGAL
DIRECTOR AT CALIFORNIA TROUBLED
FAMILIES COALITION AND I WANT TO
THANK I THANK EVERYONE FOR THIS
HEARING THIS EVENING AND- IT HAS
BEEN REALLY INSIGHTFUL HERE
ABOUT DISPROPORTIONATELY AND
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE
DISPROPORTIONAL IMPACT ON CHILD
WELFARE ON THE AMERICAN INDIAN
AND ALASKA NATIVE. COMMUNITY
EVEN THOUGH THE INITIAL WALK
PRACTICE FREQUENTLY EVEN TODAY
REFERRED TO AS THE GOLD
STANDARD. IN CHILD WELFARE FOR
EXAMPLE HAVING EMPHASIS ON SKIN
CARE AND AN EMPHASIS ON
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE SERVICES
. HOWEVER BECAUSE THE ONE
MISSING PIECE. WHICH IS. THAT
EVERY PARTY IN THE COURT ROOM
RELATED TO CHILD WELFARE CASE.
HI PUBLICLY FUNDED LEGAL COUNSEL
EXCEPT TRIED. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED TO USE
THE PHRASE THAT KATHY SANDERLING
USED EARLIER THIS IS A WHATEVER
IT TAKES MOMENT. HELLO AFFECTED
UNDER ATTACK FROM STATES LIKE
TEXAS. AND AS THE GOVERNOR SAID
IN HIS ANNUAL ADDRESS CALIFORNIA
HAS TO PUSH BACK AND PROVE THAT
THERE'S A BETTER WAY. THE
CALIFORNIA WAY WE MUST FIND A
SOLUTION TO THIS ONGOING IN
EQUITY IN DEPENDENCY CASES IN
CALIFORNIA AND FIND A WAY TO
CRAFT A SOLUTION THAT ALLOWS
TRIED HAVE ACCESS TO LEGAL
COUNSEL. ON PAR WITH AND IN
EQUITY WITH ALL THE PARTIES THAT
ARE IN THESE CASES. YOU KNOW THE
DATA TELLS US WE WILL HAVE
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR NATIVE
CHILDREN DECREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF DAYS IN CARE. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE TIME THAT EVENING THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS TIME NO
OTHER THAN KILL THANK YOU
OPERATOR I WILL TAKE THAT AS THE
CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
TODAY AND AS WE ARE COSING DOWN
THE MEETING I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK ALL OF THE STAFF
THAT HELPED US TO PREPARE THAT
ROAD OF EXCELLENT TO GENDER THE-
DGS WHO HELPS TO KEEP OUR-
CAPITAL CLEAN THE TECH TEAM TO
DISTRIBUTE THIS ACROSS THE STATE
IN THE SERGEANTS WHO KEEP US
SAFE. BUT AS ALWAYS I WANT TO
THANK THE PUBLIC FOR MAKING THIS
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROCESS
HERE TODAY WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED. HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.